Das stimmt. Und war es jetzt ein Putsch oder nicht?
Ja, schwierig zu sagen. Das ist eine große Blackbox und es ist ja interessant,
dass man so wenig weiß. Die Bundesregierung ist ein bisschen verwirrt,
dass angeblich US-Geheimdienste schon früher informiert waren, dass da so etwas droht.
Was sie uns im Nachhinein sagen.
Was sie uns im Nachhinein sagen. Wir haben es eigentlich immer schon gewusst.
Also müssen wir auch da wieder fragen. Wussten die es vorher oder nicht?
Ja, das kann auch alles Strategie sein. Es kann Strategie sein,
dass man sich in Belarus neu aufstellen will.
Es kann Strategie sein, dass man dort Eliten hat in Putins Reich,
die aber keine Putin-Anhänger mehr sind, seitdem sie durch die Sanktionspolitik
einige Milliarden verloren haben. Also alles möglich.
Und es ist doch erstaunlich, wie sehr alle sofort Einschätzungen geben können.
Politiker aus dem Garten heraus senden ins Studio und sagen irgendetwas,
aber das mit einer großen Souveränität vorgetragen.
Ich bin auch da überrascht, wie verroht der Diskurs ist.
Also wenn ich zum Beispiel einen Tweet lese von dem von so vielen merkwürdigerweise
geschätzten Experten Carlo Massalla, der schreibt I like the smell of civil
war und bezieht sich dann noch auf Apocalypse Now und.
Wir wissen, was bürgerkriegsähnliche Zustände bedeuten.
Es war von Anfang an abzusehen, dass nicht links-progressive LGBTQ-Anhänger
gegen Putin einen Putsch versuchen.
Das war von Anfang an deutlich. Dass man sich einer solchen Wortwahl bedient
und sich damit qualifiziert für Tagesthemen, Anne Will und weitere Sendungen,
finde ich sehr erstaunlich.
Wenn man in diese Richtung geht, wenn man sagt, sagt ja das was was der der
der absolute NATO Kurs ist,
dann kann man alle roten Linien überschreiten und wird hofiert,
während ja wir ja schon wissen, wenn man ein bisschen anklingen lässt,
möglicherweise müsste man irgendwann auch mal über Verhandlungen nachdenken.
Oh wei, oh wei, da ist man also falsch aus. Ich fand es auch sehr schön,
hast du das gelesen von Mariam Lau, das ist diese Zeitjournalistin,
die war auch bei Arne Wild.
Ich habe mir Arne Wild nicht angesehen, aber ich sehe da manchmal so Tweets
und dann sagt sie, ja das wäre eine tolle Runde gewesen, sie hätten sich so
schön gegenseitig ergänzt. Und klar, es waren ja wieder nur die Leute da, die eben da sitzen.
Und das ist vielleicht so was Neues, was wir jetzt erleben, Ergänzungsjournalismus.
Und dann setzt man noch mal so eine böse Figur hin, da müssen dann Harald Welzer
oder Richard David Precht miteinander sitzen, bekommen dann von den Ergänzungsjournalisten
nochmal gesagt, dass sie komplett falsch liegen.
Ja, vor allem das haben die ja im Oktober in dem Buch, das wir ja auch besprachen,
Wälzer und Precht, beschrieben.
Und anscheinend wurde das wirklich nicht als Kritik, sondern als Handlungsanweisung verstanden.
Seitdem läuft das ja nur noch so. Es ist wirklich ganz erstaunlich.
Das einzige, was man jetzt irgendwie gesichert sagen kann, ist,
also über den, äh, in Anführungszeichen Putschversuch oder was auch immer da in Russland,
Putin hat am Morgen des Tages gesagt, das sind alles Verräter und die müssen
alle zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden und zehn Stunden später durften alle das
Land verlassen und waren amnestiert.
Und da muss man ja sagen, okay, das einzige, worüber wir uns noch verständigen
können, ist das, was alle Menschen im Fernsehen gesehen haben,
weil es den Leuten, die dort noch an der Macht sind, wichtig war,
dass diese Rede von Putin am Abend und am Morgen jeweils 10,
20, 30 Mal wiederholt wurde. Ja.
Und mehr Informationen haben ja all diese Experten auch nicht.
Das ist ja das Interessante.
Selbst die Bundesregierung beklagt sich darüber, dass der Informationsfluss
zwischen den Geheimdiensten nicht so ausgezeichnet läuft.
Also selbst die, die nicht besonders informiert sind, sind eigentlich genauso gut informiert wie wir.
Und diese Experten, die wir da hören oder die aus der dritten Reihe der Politik
gerade kommen und leider kein Ministerium bekommen haben, die haben ja auch
nicht mehr gesehen als wir. Die sind ja auch nur bei Twitter unterwegs.
Aber aus einem tiefen Brustton der Überzeugung können sie genau sagen,
was jetzt da gerade passiert und warum dies jetzt eng wird für.
Also wir kennen diese Formulierung noch aus der Trump-Ära.
Da wurde es auch mal jetzt ganz
eng, ja jetzt ist Schluss mit Trump und so macht man das jetzt da auch.
Man kann sich das ja sehr wünschen und ich wünsche mir das auch.
Hätte allerdings auch schon gerne so aufblitzen, welche Alternative da kommt.
Also dass der Wagner-Gruppenchef plötzlich übernimmt, finde ich jetzt auch nicht so reizvoll.
Nee, genau. Und in der Hinsicht ist es wirklich,
also man kann, also ganz uninteressant ist ja nicht,
auch wenn man nichts darüber sagen kann inhaltlich, aber Agnes Strack-Zimmermanns Verhalten,
also Deutschlandfunk ruft an und fragt, wie ist denn die Lage und sie so,
wir müssen jetzt ganz vorsichtig sein, wir können auch gar nichts sagen,
das hat ja ganz viel damit zu tun, dass sie damals sich so in die Nässe entsetzte,
als diese eine Rakete nach Polen flog und sie dann, ja, das ist der russische
Angriff auf und so und hat sich dann gar nichts mehr getraut.
Und Michael Roth von der SPD, Ausschussvorsitzender des Europäischen Ausschusses
im Bundestag oder so, stand im Garten.
Genau, der stand ja in seinem Garten und hat dann, das ist der Super-GAU für Putin,
wo man sich ja auch wieder fragen muss, naja, aber es gab auch mal einen Putsch-Versuch
in der Türkei und hatte man den Eindruck,
das war danach ein Super-GAU für Erdogan oder war das ein Super-GAU für zehn
hunderttausende Leute, die da irgendwie hops genommen wurden und bis heute im Gefängnis sitzen.
Und er wurde wiedergewählt, schon wieder. Also diese ganzen Einschätzungen schießen
alle so ins Kraut und gehen so drunter und drüber.
Ich meine, wir wünschen uns alle nicht, oder wir wissen nicht genau,
wer kommt denn so nach Putin? Diese Frage steht seit ewig im Raum.
Nur wir sehen doch, insbesondere jetzt durch die Erfahrung mit Donald Trump
und so weiter, man kann sich im Amt auch radikalisieren.
Man kommt so naiv da rein und plötzlich stellt man fest, ach so,
das kann ich jetzt so machen und plötzlich kommen die so auf ganz neue Ideen und so.
Und für Putin ist das doch auch gerade so eine Feststellung,
wo stehe ich eigentlich gerade?
Also so was Verortung angeht, hat ihm das ja wohl sehr viel Orientierung gerade
gegeben, was ist noch möglich und was nicht und die Sachen, die ihm jetzt noch
in seinem Handlungsbereich liegen, naja, das ist noch möglich.
Da wäre ich mal ganz vorsichtig bei der Einschätzung, ob das jetzt irgendwie
der Untergang von Putin oder ob da nicht noch mal irgendwie,
ja genau, ob das noch mal die Schrauben angezogen werden, sozusagen,
was diese ganze Regimentätigkeit, von der wir ja immer noch nicht genau verstehen,
wie das, wie das funktioniert.
Es gab eine Einschätzung, ich glaube im Deutschlandfunk,
man kommt ja auch nicht mehr ganz hinterher, da war ein Russlandexperte,
der meinte, Prigoshin hat nie zum System Putin gehört und litt auch die letzten
Monate darunter gar keinen direkten Zugang mehr zu haben, weshalb eben über
die Medien kommuniziert wird mit solchen Aktionen, wenn es sich zuspitzt.
Obwohl er Leib Koch war, obwohl er so leicht geworden wurde durch Putin.
Aber er kam nie in diesen inneren Freundeskreis, in diese informale Bande,
die am Ende tatsächlich alles hält.
Und er meinte dann, ja, das ist weiter ein Rätselraten, was,
also wie das System Putin jetzt betroffen ist oder sogar bedroht.
Man sieht nur, ah ja, von außen gab's eine Bedrohung. Und man weiß jetzt gar
nicht, was das für das Gefüge intern bedeutet. Man sieht ja auch gerade niemanden.
Es werden dann diese Witze gemacht.
Wahrscheinlich gerade irgendwo, wo man kein Handyempfang habe.
Und deswegen müsste man jetzt warten, bis er wieder Empfang hat und solche Sachen.
Und man hört ja auch nichts von Putin aus diesem inneren System.
Aber dass es da gerade zur Umjustierung kommt und so, das liegt auch wirklich nahe.
Und halte ich eigentlich auch für sehr gefährlich so insgesamt.
Man macht sich ja dann auch immer ein bisschen mehr Sorgen auch um die russische
Bevölkerung, die ja da einfach als ...
Man will jetzt nicht diesen Vergleich machen, klar, die Zivilgesellschaft in
der Ukraine leidet bedeutend mehr, aber wir hatten doch auch immer Mitleid mit
der russischen Bevölkerung, die unter Putin gelitten hat.
Und irgendwie denke ich mir jetzt gerade, ja, das sollte man vielleicht nicht so ganz vergessen.
Man kann sich zum Beispiel mal ansehen, wie das mit Mao war,
als da die seine Tage gezählt waren, was sich da im Hintergrund tat,
wer dann kurzzeitig regierte, dann seine Frau, die intervenierte, die Viererbande.
Also wenn man sich diese ganzen Konstellationen ansieht, dann sieht man auch,
mit welchen Kontingenzen der Geschichte man es zu tun hat, dass es dann in die
eine oder andere Richtung gelaufen ist. Und hier haben wir ähnliche Konstellationen
und da ist es seriöser, die Lottozahlen vorauszusagen.
Ja, Kräme, Astrologie. Immer ein beliebter Sprichwort.
In ruhigen Zeiten. Aber wenn es dann brenzlig wird, wissen immer alle ganz genau Bescheid.
Das ist immer ganz erstaunlich und man muss echt sagen, derzeit weiß niemand
Bescheid, nicht mal die Protagonisten.
Also selbst wenn man jetzt Brioche da irgendwie im Exklusivinterview hätte,
der könnte einem auch nicht sagen, was mit ihm in drei Tagen ist.
Also in der Hinsicht sind diese ganzen journalistischen Versuche sowieso so
ein bisschen fehlgeleitet.
Aber gut, es ist Juni 2023.
Wir beginnen also mit dem Kram vor unserer Haustür.
Wollen wir erst noch darauf hinweisen, dass wir einen Live-Salon aufgenommen
haben, der jetzt online ist, der dort zu hören ist. Wir haben uns wieder in Frankfurt getroffen.
200 Salonisten waren auch mit dabei. Es war ein sehr schöner Abend,
ein sehr warmer Abend, aber noch relativ angenehm, würde ich sagen.
Und wir haben dort über die Apple Vision Pro gesprochen.
Das ist eine Brille, mit der man angeblich viel besser mit der Wirklichkeit
dann interagieren kann.
Wir haben aber dann doch aufgezeigt, dass das sehr isolationistisch ist,
sehr dystopisch und aber vielleicht doch eine Zukunft, die uns da droht.
Jedenfalls meine Überraschung bei der Sache, Stefan ist kein Fan der Apple Vision
Pro, obwohl du in den letzten Monaten, Jahren zum großen Apple-Fan geworden bist.
Also an dem Tag, als sie vorgestellt wurde, am 5.
Juni war ich ja in Rom das allererste Mal und dachte dann abends auch,
ja, das ist der Anwendungsfall.
Nicht in Rom sein und trotzdem in Rom sein. Sehe ich das alles nochmal?
Muss natürlich jemand ordentlich kartografieren, mal durchs Forum Romanum gehen und so.
Einmal die ganzen alten Städte abschreiten, damit ich die dann Zuhause.
So konsumieren kann. Ich muss mich ja da nicht mal bewegen, sondern sag einfach
Pfeil nach vorne. Ich will nach vorne gehen.
Das wäre ein Anwendungsfall, den ich mir vorstellen kann. Ansonsten warte ich
eigentlich noch auf die große, na gut, es ist sowieso nicht für die Masse jetzt, 3.500,
Euro ist teurer, aber ich warte eigentlich noch auf die große Welle,
dass irgendwer in irgendwelchen YouTube-Videos hunderttausend Mal erklärt,
dass das für den Bildungsbereich ganz wertvoll ist.
Die haben wir ja auch bei OpenAI und so. Das ist ja alles für den Bildungsbereich gemacht.
Man kann es sich vorstellen. Wir haben noch gesprochen über Threadwives.
Das werden wir gleich noch mal aufgreifen.
Nämlich die Frauen, die sich als traditionelle Frauen verstehen wollen,
inszenieren in den sozialen Medien. Das haben wir schon angefangen,
darüber zu sprechen. Und wir hatten als Thema noch die FDP und das Gaslighting.
Das ist ja ein Begriff, der sehr virulent ist.
Du hast uns mal anhand von Clips und anhand eines Films von 1940 gezeigt,
inwieweit eigentlich die FDP Gaslighting betreibt. Also wer das hören will,
das ist jetzt online zu finden.
Ich habe als Rückmeldung bekommen, dass es alles sehr überzeugend war.
Die acht Punkte des Gaslighting eigentlich natürlich für Beziehungsmissgestaltung
gedacht, aber wirklich lehrbuchartig umgesetzt von der FDP. Sehr viele Leute
hatten heuristische Erweckungsmomente.
Ja, ich denke jetzt auch immer dran, wenn ich irgendeinen FDP-Menschen sprechen
sehe, denke ich immer, in welche Kategorie fällt das gerade von Gangstlighting.
Es ist sehr hilfreich, würde ich auch sagen. Man sollte viel mehr so die ganzen
Beziehungsratgeber und sowas mal durchgehen und nach Begrifflichkeiten suchen,
um den Wahnsinn zu verstehen.
Wir wollen wieder viel verstehen, auch im nächsten Salon, da sprechen wir gemeinsam
über das Buch Chinesisches Denken der Gegenwart Schlüsseltexte zu Politik und Gesellschaft.
Und zwar haben Daniel Lese und Xi Ming im CH Beck Verlag ein Buch herausgegeben,
das jetzt nicht über China schreibt,
sondern ein Buch, das von den Leuten aus China ist, von Intellektuellen,
von Aktivisten, zum Teil von Dissidenten, aber auch ganz, ganz viele aus dem inneren Kreis der KP.
Und das ist ja besonders interessant. Also welche Politologen,
Geostrategen, KI-Experten, Philosophen sind jetzt da eigentlich im Kreis um
Xi und andere wichtigen Persönlichkeiten?
Was denken die? Wo geht es hin? Was denken die auch über uns, über den Westen?
Also wir bekommen jetzt wirklich mal andere Blicke, nämlich chinesische Blicke
präsentiert in diesen Texten und das ist, glaube ich, sehr hilfreich,
nicht nur immer Texte über China zu lesen, sondern auch mal Texte direkt aus China.
Also wir waren ja bisher nicht unzufrieden mit den Texten über China.
Wir hatten ja, waren ja auch mal bei einem Vortrag von dem Strittmatter und
so, die das alles, Also die Leute, die vor Ort dann berichten.
Aber es gibt halt diese große Sprachbarriere.
Die natürlich dann auch noch mal darüber hinausgespannt wird,
dass wir uns auch nicht dafür interessieren, was die dafür Filme produzieren
oder so. Das ist ja dann mit Amerika oder Frankreich, England, Italien ganz anders.
Es sind 650 Seiten übersetzte und kommentierte chinesische Texte.
Also näher ran, mehr Approximationshoffnung kann man, glaube ich,
nicht haben. Da kann man sehr gespannt sein.
Und ich kann schon sagen, dass ich außerdem noch zwei Bücher vorstellen will
und zwar einen Roman, der Tanzende von Victor Jastar, der sehr, sehr gut ist.
Und dann ist natürlich jetzt diese große Frage, brauchen wir einen linken Populismus
und da trifft es sich gut, dass Chantal Mouffe ein neues Buch veröffentlicht hat.
Also sie ist ja die Theoretikerin eines linken Populismus und ich glaube,
ich habe alle Texte von ihr, die auf deutsch erschienen sind,
alle Bücher gelesen und jetzt ist ein neues schmales Buch erschienen.
Eine grüne demokratische Revolution, wo sie auch für einen linken Populismus,
Bezug auf Ökologie, auf all das argumentiert.
Ich würde aber auch dann die Gelegenheit nutzen, nochmal so ein paar Grundüberlegungen
von MUFE aufzugreifen, um zu erklären, was damit eigentlich gemeint ist und
warum so ein demokratischer Konsens vielleicht gar nicht so gut ist.
Sehr gut. Das führt uns wirklich direkt nach Sonneberg. Kennst du Sonneberg?
Ich kenne Sonneberg nicht.
Niemand kennt Sonneberg. Ich komme aus Thüringen. Für mich war,
wenn die Antenne in Thüringen irgendwas mit und in Sonneberg, bla bla bla.
Rückseite vom Mond. Also niemand hat irgendeinen Bezug zu Sonneberg.
Das vergisst man immer schnell, wenn plötzlich Sonneberg drei Tage in den Medien war.
Plötzlich denken alle, sie kennt irgendwie Sonneberg und so.
Nein, wir kennen alle Sonneberg nicht. Das ist für uns, das sind Marsmenschen,
die da rumlaufen. Also so ungefähr.
Man hat da null Bezug zu und man sollte auch nicht so tun, als ob da drei Tage
Medienstress irgendwas ändern.
Aber in Sonneberg fand eine Landratswahl statt.
Und wir können zumindest im Rahmen unserer Lieblingsthemen mal Sonneberg uns
annähern, indem wir zum Beispiel kurz aufklären, Demografie.
Und damit ist jetzt vor allem die Einwohnerzahl gemeint.
Wenn ich die Zahl nenne, können wir, glaube ich, ohne weitere Kommentare schlussfolgern,
wie die Altersstruktur da aussieht.
Sonneberg ist ja heute der zweitkleinste Landkreis zu Hochzeiten der DDR,
bis zu 84.000 Einwohner. Und es sind heute 56.000.
Wir können also sehen, das ging da ganz schön rapide runter.
Es ist nicht ganz halbiert, aber crazy ist das schon. 1994 waren es 71.454.
Und seitdem, also in knapp 30 Jahren, ist es auf 56 geschrumpft.
GPT sagt, minus 21 Prozent sind es.
Minus 21 Prozent, das ist ja interessant.
Das sind ja ungefähr diese, wenn jetzt sieben Millionen im Erwerbspersonenpotenzial fehlen,
dann können wir ja, so die Hälfte der Branchen in Deutschland droht jetzt die
nächsten 13 Jahre, also dreimal schneller als das, was wir in Sonneberg jetzt
sehen, an Personal einfach zu verlieren.
Meine These, wir sollten in Sonneberg vielleicht nicht nur einfach,
das ist am Rande der Welt, sondern vielleicht ist es so eine gesamtdeutsche Zukunft.
Unter dieser Maßgabe uns das mal anschauen und denken, oh krass,
ja, also minus 20 Prozent, klar jetzt gerade sind es ja 84 Millionen,
die das statistische Bundesamt ausweist, aber wir wissen ja,
Die Kurswende beginnt immer auf dem Peak,
also es ist gerade der Spitzenpunkt erreicht und dann geht es nach unten und minus 21 Prozent,
das ist ziemlich vorbildhaft für alle Landkreise in Deutschland,
außer die urbanen Städte, aber die haben ja auch keine Landräte,
sondern Oberbürgermeister, also da tickt die Zeit dann ein bisschen anders in den urbanen Zentren.
Aber das, was man da in Sonneberg als Resultat gesehen hat, nach 30 Jahren Schrumpfung,
also Wir werden gesamtdeutsch so schrumpfen.
Und da passt ja dann sehr schön, dass es mitunter viele Stimmen gab,
die sagten, ja, aber die haben doch eine niedrige Arbeitslosigkeit.
Und dann stellt sich aber heraus, das mag ja sein, durch diese Schrumpfung ist
es ja kaum anders möglich, aber 44 Prozent arbeiten dort zum Mindestlohn.
Und der liegt bei 12 Euro.
Und da wurde auch die Tage jetzt um 3,1 Prozent erhöht.
Ja, also so das alles von der Inflation gefasst. Wir müssen das jetzt gleich
nochmal gesondert, du hast ja Clips mitgebracht, aber jetzt muss man sich klar
machen, also im nächsten Jahr wird der Mindestlohn dann 41 Cent mehr betragen, also 12,41 Euro.
Und 44 Prozent der Arbeitenden dort in Sonneberg beziehen diesen Mindestlohn.
Ja und bei der Bundespressekonferenz zum Thema die Mindestlohnkonferenz oder
Kommission wie sie heißt,
verkündet dieses Ergebnis, hat dann die Arbeitgeberseite auch nochmal gesagt,
man macht das aus wirtschaftspolitischer und staatspolitischer Verantwortung,
man darf ja niemanden überfordern.
Das ist die Botschaft für Sonneberg. Also es betrifft einfach die Hälfte der
Arbeitnehmer in Sonneberg.
Dass es so gut wie keine Anhörung gibt. Und wenn wir uns das auch nochmal vergegenwärtigen,
man vergisst das so schnell.
Die Ampel war angetreten vor inflationären Tendenzen zu sagen,
wir brauchen zwölf Prozent Mindestlohn und die FDP hat damals eingeschlagen
und gesagt, gut, machen wir.
Dann kam diese, aber erst im nächsten Jahr.
Und dann kam das Jahr der Inflation. Das heißt, alles was beschlossen wurde
von der Ampel mit den zwölf Prozent, mit den zwölf Euro, wurde von der Inflation
schon damals aufgefressen.
Wenn man wusste, eigentlich müsste schon zum damaligen Zeitpunkt der Mindestlohn
bei 13 Euro gewesen sein.
Was aber nicht geschah. Und jetzt haben wir immer noch zwölf Euro,
obwohl wir diese immense Inflation
haben, die ja vor allem auch im Lebensmittelbereich stattgefunden hat.
Das also was mit diesen zwölf Euro, die man da die Stunde verdient,
vor allem verkonsumiert wird.
Und dann haben wir jetzt eine Mindestlohnerhöhung, die so aussieht,
dass sie von der Inflation nicht nur gefressen wird, sondern dass trotzdem die
Inflation härter nochmal die Leute trifft, die eine Mindestlohn bekommen.
Das bedeutet, dass man 2019 mit einem wesentlich geringeren Nominal-Mindestlohn
ein besseres Leben führen konnte 2019 als heute mit dem Mindestlohn.
Und es betrifft ja nicht nur den Mindestlohn an sich, sondern der Mindestlohn ist ja die Untergrenze.
Das bedeutet natürlich auch, dass sich alle, die ein bisschen drüber verdienen,
14, 16, jetzt auch keine Hoffnung machen können auf große Lohnsteigerungen,
weil der Arbeitgeber natürlich immer darauf verweisen kann, naja Mindestlohn
ist auch nur um 41 Cent gestiegen. Ich habe das jetzt von...
Einem guten Freund gehört aus Berlin, der zum Mindestlohn arbeitet und dem wurde aber jetzt,
als er eine Teamleitung übernahm, in so einem Callcenter versprochen,
ja, man will ihm schon auch eine Gehaltserhöhung geben, man will jetzt mal abwarten,
was an Mindestlohn mehr kommt und dann würde man da nochmal schauen.
Und jetzt ist also diese Mindestlohnerhöhung so gering, dass natürlich auch
das, was man ihm dann zusätzlich geben wird, nicht der Rede wert ist.
Und das ist die Situation, in der wahnsinnig viele Leute sind.
Man kann sagen, ja, 20 Prozent der Arbeitenden in Deutschland,
denen geht es immer kontinuierlich etwas besser, aber den restlichen 80 Prozent,
denen geht es schlechter und die Reallohnverluste sind so stark wie seit 2008 nicht mehr.
Genau, und man kann ja nochmal, diese Inflation ist ja auch immer so ein,
keine Ahnung, da kommt es ja darauf an, auch wie man sie berechnet,
wie man sie fühlt, wo sie wirklich am Ende landet.
Man hat ja auch so eine sozusagen Live-Berichterstattung zum Thema Inflation
und so ein Jahr später gucken die Wirtschaftshistoriker drauf und sehen das
doch nochmal ein bisschen anders.
Der Warenkorb muss irgendwie zusammengesetzt werden, also da ist auch viel Politik mit drin.
Jetzt hast du ja gerade gesagt, ja, der Mindestlohn war schon wegen Nichtarmutsfestigkeit
in der Diskussion, bevor diese Inflation durch die Energiepreise und so weiter,
also dieser Preisschock, sagen wir mal, kam.
Und jetzt danach hat man gesagt, okay, dann geben wir euch 3, Prozent mehr.
Zwischen diesen drei Komma und der eigentlichen Inflation liegt eine kleine
Lücke. Die muss man herausfühlen.
Denn im Börsenbericht der ARD ist man selber sich nicht ganz sicher,
was jetzt mit Inflation gemeint ist.
Die Inflation in Deutschland wird von den Verbrauchern dreimal so hoch wahrgenommen,
wie die tatsächlich ermittelte.
Zu diesem Ergebnis kommt eine Studie des Kreditversicherers Allianz Trade.
Mehr dazu von Markus Gürnel aus der Frankfurter Börse.
Während die offiziell ermittelte Teuerung im Mai bei 6,1 Prozent lag,
wird sie gefühlt bei 18 Prozent wahrgenommen, so die Autoren der Studie des Kreditversicherers.
Einer der Hauptgründe liege darin, dass die Preissteigerungen bei Lebensmitteln
den Verbrauchern besonders auffallen. Bei den Einkäufen des täglichen Bedarfes
wie Nahrungsmittel sind die Preise auch tatsächlich überdurchschnittlich gestiegen
und im Statistischen Warenkorb der größte Preistreiber.
Andere Güter haben weniger oder gar nicht zugelegt. Auch Sonderangebote bleiben
in der Wahrnehmung weniger im Gedächtnis.
So kommt die offizielle Statistik mit dem Warenkorb bestimmter Güter auf eine
Inflationsrate im Mai von gut sechs Prozent.
Durch die enorme Teuerung bei Lebensmitteln gefühlt aber auf deutlich mehr.
Ich will das mal übersetzen auf Normaldeutsch. Es gibt einen Warenkorb,
der geht über alles hinweg.
Cocktails in der Bar, Auslandsaufenthalte durch Urlaub. auch immer.
Und dann gibt es so diesen gefühlten Warenkorb, wie er hier sagt,
Leute, die eh schon arm sind, die einkaufen gehen. Bei denen liegt die Inflation bei 18 Prozent.
Und jetzt hören wir aus Sonneberg, okay, 44 Prozent der Arbeitnehmer betrifft
das dort. Die haben also nicht eine Inflation von 10 oder 11 Prozent,
sondern einfach von 18 Prozent gehabt.
So, und das ist ja eigentlich alles gar nicht lange her. Das ist zum Beispiel
hier ein Clip aus der letzten Nachrichtentage.
Und dennoch findet das in dieser Berichterstattung zum Thema Sonneberg alles gar nicht statt.
Also die demografischen Sachen, die ich gerade nannte, auch nicht.
Da könnte man sich ja die Altersstruktur dann anschauen, wenn einfach 30.000
Leute fehlen. Wer sind denn das? Naja, die Jungen natürlich.
Wir wissen ja, wie der Bundestagswahlkreis dort aussieht.
Das ist ja der 196. Suhl-Schmalkalten-Meining-Hildburghausen-Sonneberg.
Da ist ja 2021 wer angetreten? Hans-Georg Maaßen. Wir wissen von Suhl,
das ist die älteste Stadt Deutschlands, mit 51 Jahren Durchschnittsalter.
Da denkt man halt ein bisschen anders. Und da ist auch diese Welt,
in der man noch Schüler mit einem Schulranzen in die Grundschule gehen sieht,
auf der Straße, ganz weit weg.
Da muss man wirklich ein paar zig Kilometer fahren, um sowas noch mal zu sehen.
Hans-Georg Maaßen hatte damals 22,3 Prozent. Der AfD-Kandidat hatte 21,2.
Die SPD hat den Wahlkreis geholt, weil sie Frank Ulrich ins Feld geschickt hat
und die schon eine Art Sammelbecken da gemacht haben für alle. Der kam dann mit 33,6.
Also nicht jetzt unbedingt mit super Rückenwind nach Berlin.
Ich habe mal nachgeschaut. Er hat bislang genau eine Rede in Berlin gehalten
zum Haushalt von Faeser, um nochmal zu sagen, ja, da ist aber Sport so ein bisschen
kurz und ich als Olympionik.
Und genau das ist seine Rolle, wegen der er auch gewählt wurde.
Er ist halt so ein bunter Hund da in diesem Wahlkreis.
Jetzt kann man sich fragen, ja gut, jetzt wurde der Sesselmann zum Landrat gewählt.
Was sagt denn Frank Ulrich dazu?
Gar nichts. Es gibt überhaupt gar keine Wortmeldung des Bundestagsabgeordneten.
Wenn man dann Frank Ulrich Sonneberg oder Frank Ulrich Sesselmann,
um es einzugrenzen, sucht, findet man genau zwei Texte. Einen der Zeit,
einen im Spiegel, also gestern Abend 18 Uhr, Stichpunkt hierfür.
Also weit nach der Wahl, vier Tage danach. Und diese Texte greifen Frank Ulrich
einfach noch mal auf, um noch mal zu erinnern, was 2021 war, aber nichts aktuelles.
Also da gibt es überhaupt gar keine Politik dort. Der Bundestagskandidat oder
der Bundestagsabgeordnete äußert sich zu gar nichts.
Wir haben auch von dem CDU-Typen, der da jetzt unterlegen war,
auch nur so ein, ja, das ist die Ampel schuld, solche Sprüche.
Und es ist...
Was ja wahnsinnig kurios ist, diese CDU-Argumentation, die Ampel ist schuld.
Auf die kommt man gleich ausführlich zu sprechen. Ich will nur noch einen Punkt
zum Thema Landrat. Was ist eigentlich ein Landrat?
Deutschland ist ja dreigegliedert. Es gibt die Bundesländer und der Bund.
Der Bund schafft natürlich immer die Tagesthemen. Also das sind ja unsere Olaf-Scholz-Festspiele,
da wo wir das Tagebuch der Angela Merkel und so weiter serviert bekommen.
Auch wenn die gar nicht wollen, werden die da Bericht erstattet.
Die Ministerpräsidenten müssen sich schon sehr anstrengen, um in den Tagesthemen vorzukommen.
Also das ist schon schwierig. Deswegen sind ja Rainer Haseloff und so diese,
die jetzt alle zur Wahl stehen, Woidke auch immer nur sauer,
wenn sie dann mal diese großen Termine haben, weil Friedrich Merz nochmal vorbeikommt
oder so, werden sie fast so drive-by irgendwie mitgeschutet mit der Kamera und
dürfen dann nochmal kurz den Satz sagen.
Und dann gibt's diese kommunale Ebene. Da interessiert sich genau niemand für.
Wir haben ja sogar ein öffentlich-rechtliches System, dem es verboten ist,
auf dieser kommunalen Ebene zu Bericht erstatten, weil man will ja die Presse dort nicht gefährden.
Das haben ja die Zeitungsverleger durchgesetzt. Nur vielleicht sollte man das
auch noch mal überdenken, welche Presse in Juhl, in Sonneberg,
wir hatten ja schon bei der Bundestagswahl festgestellt, ach so,
es gibt gar keine Thüringer Zeitung mehr, die,
Ja, es gibt nur noch Mantelproduktion für Thüringen, TLZ und diese ostdeutsche
Landeszeitung und so, das ist ja alles, das ist ja gar nicht mehr existent.
Naja, es wird auch kaum gelesen, wir haben Regionaljournalismus so sehr ausgedünnt,
überall, also auch in Rheinland-Pfalz zum Beispiel.
Da gibt es dann mitunter Leute, die da noch für ackern und auch gut im Geschäft
sind, aber das erreicht dann oft ja gar nicht mehr die Leute,
weil die die Zeitung nicht mehr abonniert haben.
Auch muss man ja überlegen, also eine Regionalzeitung zu abonnieren,
kostet etwa 450 Euro im Jahr. Macht man das?
Das macht man nicht. Das macht man höchstens noch, weil man das vor 30 Jahren mal abgeschlossen hat.
Und selbst die Kinder oder die Enkel, die nach Hause kommen und die Zeitung
da liegen, die blättern da nicht rein. Also da gibt es nichts zu lesen.
Es ist alles ganz trostlos. Und nächstes Jahr haben wir drei Landtagswahlen in Ostdeutschland.
Landtagswahlen haben, wo in diesem Berichtsgebiet der Landtagswahl gar keine
Redaktion mehr tätig ist.
Dann auf der kommunalen Ebene erst recht nicht.
Also müsste eigentlich jetzt die große öffentlich-rechtliche Offensive kommen.
Und damit, also ich würde das ja sehr begrüßen schon deshalb,
weil man ja den Journalisten, den Hauptstadtjournalisten, denke ich auch zu
Recht, so eine Abgehobenheit oder Weltferne vorwirft.
Und wenn da jetzt eigentlich ein Regionaljournalismus entstehen würde,
wo tatsächlich mal geguckt wird und nicht nur wenn eine Flutkatastrophe an der
Ahr ist, dass man dann hinfährt, sondern
dass man sich tatsächlich in den Regionaljournalismus hinein bewegt.
Und möglicherweise auch ein bisschen mit Kooperation mit den privaten Zeitungen, die es noch gibt.
Also das muss ja auch gar nicht nur als Konkurrenz gedacht werden. Dann glaube ich,
könnte das ein sehr sehr sinnvolles Projekt sein, um generell auch dem Öffentlich-Rechtlichen
ein neues Ansehen zu verleihen, dass man tatsächlich nicht den Eindruck hat,
Berlin Mitte entscheidet, was Deutschland gut zu finden hat.
Ja, man muss jetzt auch diesen Schlussstrich mal ziehen, die...
Öffentlich-rechtlichen Fernsehsender vor allem und Radios haben das Verbot bekommen,
lokale Berichterstattung zu machen, damit die sich auf dem Markt zu bewährenden
privaten Presseorganisationen durchsetzen können.
Nur die sind alle tot. Also kann man jetzt einfach sagen, diese Sache ist entschieden.
Wir haben nur noch den Öffentlich-rechtlichen, wenn er sein Mandat dann nicht
ausgeweitet bekommt und das ist dann eben Entscheidung der Politik,
das zu wollen, dann passiert da genau gar keine Berichterstattung.
Also dann fährt nur das Tagesthemen-Team zwei Tage nach so einer Wahl mit dem
dritten Team mal dahin und sieht dann, dass der Goldene Löwe irgendwie von so
einem Neonazi, der da die ganze Zeit noch seine T-Shirts verkauft und so weiter gemacht wird.
So war es ja, ne? Karim Özgat ja genau diese Story jetzt gebracht hat.
Man kann das aber auch fast im Studio nachdrehen. Also man weiß schon,
was man antritt in gewisser Weise.
Das ist dann wirklich wie so ein Film in den 40ern, da baut man so eine Fasada
auf und geht dann da rein und dann steht halt ein Nazi da und sagt irgendwie
voll tätowiert, ja ich hab hier gar nichts gegen meine Nachbarn,
nur der eine soll halt nicht kommen und so.
Naja, also das ist alles schon, dieses Kind ist wirklich schon komplett in den Boden gefallen,
da müsste man jetzt alles ganz neu machen und ich frage mich so ein bisschen,
wenn die Tagesthemen und das Heute-Journal oder was auch immer,
ich will nicht zu viel Medienkritik jetzt machen, ich habe ja dafür auch andere
Podcasts, aber in diesem Fall ist es ja wirklich jetzt, ist ja eine Zäsur.
Wenn ein Landrat gewählt wird, kann uns irgendeiner der Journalisten mal erklären,
was das eigentlich bedeutet? Was ist denn ein Landrat?
Wir hatten ja von der Heescher, die im heutigen Journal Andreas Künast nacheifert,
in seiner Art Berichterstattung zu machen, mal einen Bericht vor Jahren vom Städtetag.
Also die Oberbürgermeister Deutschlands treffen sich und dann ist die Erklärung
für Oma Erna, da treffen sich die, Zitat, Mini-Merkels. Achso.
Weil das sind ja die Kanzler auf kleinem Gebiet. Man weiß was ein Kanzler ist,
also der Bürgermeister ist ungefähr dasselbe, nur kleiner.
Nur nicht mal so eine absurde Erklärung würde ja greifen bei einem Landrat.
Ein Landrat ist ja gerade kein Mini-Merkel, sondern ein Landrat ist einfach ein Behördenchef.
Während also Bundesminister, Bundeskanzler, Landesminister,
Ministerpräsidenten, parlamentarische Staatssekretäre keine Beamten sind und
selbst wenn sie Beamten sind, für die Zeit, die sie in diese Ämter kommen,
das Beamtenverhältnis ruht, ist das ja beim Landrat genau andersrum.
Der Sesselmann ist ja kein Beamter, aber er wird jetzt auf Zeit verbeamtet, um Landrat zu sein.
Und seine Funktion ist ja da nicht die eines politischen, oh ich hab so eine
Idee und setz die mal um, sondern nein, der Landrat fasst Beschlüsse,
der Kreistag in dem Fall in Thüringen, der Kreistag fasst einen Beschluss und
der Landrat muss den halt umsetzen.
Und wenn es neue EU-Regeln zu irgendwas gibt, dann muss der Landrat die halt umsetzen.
Und das Umfeld sind Verwaltungsbeamte.
Genau, der ist einfach nur der Chef der Verwaltung, der hat keine politische
Handhabe über irgendetwas und diese Aufklärung kriegen wir ja auch nicht.
Also wo da jetzt auch für die AfD vielleicht die eine oder andere Herausforderung liegt.
Stattdessen, und wir kommen echt nicht drum rum, so ein bisschen kleine Medienkritik
zu machen, aber wir beginnen mal mit dem Tagesthemenkommentar vom 25.06.,
also vom Wahltag am Sonntag.
Es ist eine Landratswahl, und wir wissen, wie viele Landräte es in Deutschland
gibt, also unendlich viele, ist Thema in den Tagesthemen.
Die geht natürlich schief, weil der AfD-Kandidat bekommt, obwohl sich alle,
und da fragt mich auch, ja, es war eine Stichwahl, also so gesehen,
eine Stichwahl, da gibt es halt nur noch zwei Lager.
Da muss man dann auch nichts zu tun, als hätte sich irgendwie das demokratische
Lager so krass zusammengeschlossen und so. Nein, das war halt eine Stichwahl,
die stattfand, die ging dann entsprechend aus.
Aus und wir bekommen diesen völlig inhaltsleeren Kommentar, von dem ich nochmal
sage, hört genau zu. Wir müssen jetzt dieses Wort fabulieren.
In unseren Wortschatz einbauen. Wir haben das jetzt gehört von OpenAI,
die selber davon sprachen, ja, JGPT gibt halt immer eine Antwort,
auch wenn sie eigentlich wissen, Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass das irgendwie ein
Volltreffer ist, so 25 Prozent, aber wir wollen trotzdem Text ausliefern,
also halluziniert die Maschine, wurde dann von Sam Ortman gesagt.
Und dann später kam so eine Fremdbeschreibung, die sagte, nee,
wir sagen da nicht mehr Halluzinieren dazu, sondern Fabulieren.
Es gibt Formulieren, man hat was zu sagen, also publiziert man, egal auf welchem Wege.
Aber selbst in Dissertationen ist es einfach so, es gibt diese kleine Forschungsfortentwicklung,
die man drin hat. Und die anderen 80 % des Textes sind halt Fabulierungen,
die halt so einfach Masse machen.
Damit man die 20 Seiten, um die es geht, noch mal umrahmt mit weiteren 200 Seiten.
Damit man auch ein Stück Buch in der Hand hat.
Und dieser Tagesthemen-Kommentar ist wirklich idealtypisch für Fabulation.
Demokratischen Parteien. Reist euch zusammen, entwickelt konstruktive Ideen, gebt Orientierung.
Den Menschen in Ost und West kann viel zugetraut werden, wenn man Politik erklärt und solide umsetzt.
Stattdessen wirken politische Entscheidungen zuletzt weit weg von Lebenswirklichkeiten
in Sonneberg und anderswo.
Zu viele Wählerinnen und Wähler fühlen sich nicht mehr zu Hause in unserer Demokratie.
Um sie zu erreichen, reicht es weder, sich heillos in Gesetzen zu verlieren,
noch über Gendern zu debattieren.
Wer rechte Rhetorik übernimmt, normalisiert sie.
Das derzeitige AfD-Hoch ist übrigens kein Ostproblem. Viele Menschen empfinden
die parallelen Krisen als Kontrollverlust.
Macht Angst und so ziehen einfache Antworten an vielen Orten.
Und was nun? Wir alle müssen konfliktfähiger werden, intensiv um die besten
politischen Lösungen ringen, ohne Scheuklappen, ohne Tabus, aber im Respekt
auch vor anderen Meinungen.
Sie hat nicht resilient gesagt, das finde ich schon mal gut.
Aber auch noch, wir müssen resilienter werden. Es ist heillos in Gesetzen verloren.
Wie ist man darin verloren? In den Gesetzen, sind die die ganze Zeit mit Gesetzesbüchern
unterwegs oder haben die Leute aus dem Blick verloren?
Was bedeutet das Konflikte? Keine Tabus, aber offenbar gibt es ja schon Tabus.
Sonst würde man ja sagen, das war gar kein Problem, dass wir eine AfD-Landrat haben.
Also das ist ja, das ist ja, ja, aber so war das ja bei Twitter.
Ich habe ja wirklich kurz reingeguckt. Also ich muss ja dann,
ich muss mal ganz kurz sagen, ich freue mich ja so, dass ich diesen blauen Haken habe.
Denn der blaue Hake bringt es ja mit sich, dass, wenn ich mich auslogge und
mich dann wieder einloggen will, meine E-Mail-Adresse, Passwort,
dann bekomme ich eine TAN geschickt, dann muss ich die eingeben.
Das heißt, es ist ein kleinerer Prozess. Das macht man nicht 50 Mal am Tag.
Und so, wenn ich mich ausgelockt habe, bin ich für sehr lange Zeit ausgelockt.
Das ist wunderbar. Ja, ja, damit ich nicht so viel mitbekomme.
Aber da habe ich mich dann eingeloggt und das gesehen. Und das war ja dann nur von Ricarda Lange.
Das ist ein entsetzlicher Dammbruch und was die dann so alles sagen.
Oder ich will meinen Kindern nicht später sagen, dass ich geschwiegen habe.
Oder meine Lieblingsformulierung ist ja, dann reißt mir wirklich die Hutschnur,
jetzt müssen sich die Demokraten unterhaken.
Also wenn ein Unterhaken kommt, überlege ich, ob die Gegenseit nicht doch recht
hat. Also das war mir schon eine Trotzreaktion.
Und das ist immer, also eigentlich könnten die auch da sich das programmieren
lassen, lasst noch mal einfach twittern, was wir 2016 gemacht haben oder retweetet
es doch einfach. Es ist immer dasselbe.
Und man glaubt doch nicht, dass es nur darum geht, dass man nochmal den Menschen besser erklärt.
Ich finde es interessant, hier wird ja eigentlich appelliert an den politisch
aufgeklärten Bürger, den man es jetzt aber doch erklären muss,
weil er es so ganz einfach dann doch nicht versteht.
Aber wird eigentlich in Deutschland Politik gemacht unter der Voraussetzung,
dass wir den aufgeklärten Bürger vor uns haben.
Wir haben Daniel Günther von der CDU, der jetzt glaubt, Laila singen zu müssen.
Wir haben Baerbock und Rikarda Lang, die uns ansprechen, als seien wir sieben
Jahre alt. Wir haben die FDP, die, wie du in schönster Klarheit herausgearbeitet
hast, Gaslighting betreibt.
Werden wir als aufgeklärte Subjekte von der Politik wahrgenommen und angesprochen?
Eigentlich nicht. Irgendwie sollen wir da so hingetriggert, gelotst werden, was auch immer.
Und jetzt möchte man aber, dass der AfD-Wähler ganz bewusst sich als politisches
Subjekt versteht und dann erkennt, wo er falsch handelt. Da würde ich sagen,
da muss die Vorarbeit schon woanders beginnen.
Ja, ich würde es sogar wirklich noch krass strapazieren, die Leute werden so
wenig ernst genommen und deren Themen komplett ignoriert.
Also das heißt dann irgendwie, ja, die Arbeitslosigkeit liegt unter der Deutschen.
Das war ja so monatlich, bis dann Dienstag, Mittwoch so kam,
aber die kriegen alle nur Mindestlohn und so weiter.
Und mittlerweile muss man ja wirklich sich die Frage stellen,
weil so wie sie hier rangeht, ja, da müssen ja die Politiker das noch mal ein
bisschen besser machen.
Die Thüringer scheinen so ein bisschen doof zu sein. Ich finde viele doof,
aber ich finde auch viele Hessen doof. Ich finde sowieso viele Menschen doof.
Manchmal bin ich auch selber doof und ärgere mich darüber.
Aber eine Sache muss man doch jetzt wirklich mal anerkennen, einsehen.
Hinter die kam man nicht mehr zurück.
Alle Menschen in Deutschland, insbesondere die Politiker, wissen, wer Björn Höcke ist.
Und dieses Terminus, ja, er ist gerichtlich als Faschist zulässig zu bezeichnen
und so weiter. Das macht doch auch jeder dritte Journalist, Georg Ressler und
so weiter, der sagt doch gar nicht mehr Björn Höcke, sondern für ihn ist nur
noch der Faschist Björn Höcke.
Dass die AfD jetzt als rechtsextrem gesichert in Thüringen gählt,
also diese eigentlich totale Behörden Formulierung des Bundesverfassungsschutzamts,
das weiß doch mittlerweile auch jeder.
Wenn in Sonneberg jetzt ein Landrat von der AfD gewählt wird,
mit zehn Prozent mehr Wahlbeteiligung als zu erwarten war.
Dann haben die Leute ganz bewusst dort...
Ein Rechtsextrem gewählt, der ja auch noch im Landesvorstand der Partei in Thüringen
an der Seite von Björn Höcke Beisitzer ist und auch noch thematisch da zuständig
für irgendwelche Sachen. Die machen das also bewusst.
Man kann dann immer noch klären, ja warum machen die das denn bewusst?
Aber dass sie es bewusst machen, da sollte man echt nicht mehr dahinter.
Und hier so ein, ich würde auch mal sagen, das ist so ein hakt euch mal unter
Kommentar, es geht einfach völlig am Thema vorbei.
Also sie machen das bewusst, dass sie eine rechtsextreme Partei wählen.
Was sie vielleicht nicht bewusst machen ist, zu durchschauen,
was eigentlich das Programm der AfD ist und was das bedeutet.
Weil natürlich, denn jetzt wird natürlich gleich jemand sagen,
die AfD macht ja nun wirklich keine soziale Politik.
Nee, selbstverständlich nicht. Und wir hatten ja damals wohl schon für alle
uns das Programm auch angesehen und haben uns ja gerade auf diese ökonomischen
Fragen konzentriert. Und dann muss man sagen, ja, das wäre natürlich für Deutschland
und für alle die Arbeiten ein Fiasko, wenn die AfD regieren würde.
Aber das wissen wiederum die gar nicht. Also da haben wir nicht den aufgeklärten
Bürger, das ist gar keine Auseinandersetzung.
Die haben aber das diffuse Gefühl, dass dann eben auch Fakten produziert oder
als Fakt wahrgenommen wird, dass etwas nicht stimmt und dass es finanziell eher
schlechter als besser wird.
Und sie finden da dann eine Partei, bei der sie glauben, dass sie den anderen
eins auswischen können, wenn sie das machen.
Bzw.
Gibt es auch Teile der Wählerschaft, das darf man ja auch nicht vergessen,
die sicherlich Nazi-Gedanken gut gut findet. Also die gibt es auch.
Also die gibt es in Thüringen auch.
Das sind nicht wahrscheinlich diese 20 Prozent, die da jetzt gewählt haben.
Man muss ja feststellen, die AfD war die ganze lange Zeit auch bei 10, 12 Prozent.
Also im Kreistag, dem ja der Sesselmann jetzt ausgeliefert ist,
der sind Beschlüsse muss er umsetzen, sitzt die AfD mit 24 Prozent.
Ich würde sagen, das ist so die realistische Einschätzung, das sind dann so Überzeugungstäter.
Da müssen sich dann die anderen 76 Prozent mehr überlegen, wie sie das so demokratisch
organisieren. Den 24 Prozent ist man erst mal ausgeliefert.
Ich würde dann auch sagen, ja, also man muss sich dann wirklich vor Ort dafür
interessieren, was da los ist. Also man muss dann aus überzeugten Menschenhassern
eben irgendwie Erklärungen und pädagogische Programme finden.
Es muss eben aber selber irgendwie wichtig sein. Also man kann das nicht verordnen
über wir funken da mal Tweets rüber. Und man muss mir echt sagen,
alle Tweets, die ich gesehen habe, waren wirklich ganz vergiftete.
So geogressle-style, liebe Sonneberger AfD-Wähler, erklärt mir mal und so weiter
und so fort. Und die wissen dort alle sehr genau, dass sie jetzt sehr unattraktiv
für irgendwelche Investoren sind und so weiter. Nur die machen es eben trotzdem.
Und da würde ich sagen, da darf man nicht mehr hinter zurückgehen.
Es ist wie damals Stupid White Men, der Filmmacher, wie heißt er nochmal?
Michael Moore.
Michael Moore hat damals vor der Donald Trump-Wahl 2016 gesagt,
Diese Menschen wissen, dass sie mit der Wahl Donald Trumps einen Molotow-Cocktail
nach Washington werfen und sie machen es trotzdem.
Und dahinter kann man nicht mehr zurück. Die machen es einfach trotzdem.
Man sollte jetzt nicht in so eine Psychoanalyse verfallen und dann,
sind das jetzt alle Nazis oder so. Das ist völlig egal. Die haben jetzt so gewählt,
wie sie gewählt haben und damit muss man arbeiten. Wir haben jetzt hier bei
ihr gesehen, also die ARD hat keine Antwort für uns.
Das ist die Augenhöhe der ganzen Berichterstattung gewesen bis gestern,
mal gucken was die nächsten Tage so kommt, aber wenn es überhaupt noch Thema
ist, das ist ja auch eines dieser Probleme.
Ich will zu ihr nur noch sagen und wir bleiben hier namenlos,
ich weiß nicht wie sie heißt, aber sie ist jetzt sozusagen stellvertretend für
die ARD, für das öffentlich-rechtliche System, das sich um die Angelegenheit
der Sesselmannwahl kümmert.
In diesem Kommentar war null Selbstreflektion oder gar Selbstkritik zum Thema Medienarbeit.
Dass es Journalisten braucht, damit Politiker mit der Wahlbevölkerung kommunizieren
können, wird da einfach ausgeblendet.
Sondern Merz soll halt irgendwas erklären. Oder Scholz hat irgendwas nicht richtig erklärt und so weiter.
Dass es da noch diese sehr wichtige Funktion der Medien dazwischen gibt,
die natürlich ihrerseits diese ganzen Konfliktkämpfe und so weiter,
wer hat denn jetzt gewonnen, Habeck oder Lindner und so, das wird hier einfach ausgeblendet.
Aber gut, das ist wie immer, als zweiten Clip, wir hören Mario Voigt,
der Clip ließ sich leider nicht besonders gut kürzen, der ist eine Minute 46,
aber damit auch allumfassend.
Das ist der CDU-Chef.
Das ist der neue CDU-Chef in Thüringen, der also jetzt auch nächstes Jahr antritt,
oder dieses Jahr, nee nächstes Jahr dann zur Wahl gegen Ramelow und so weiter,
wo sich alle gucken müssen, wo sie bleiben jetzt, wo die Höcke-AfD dort ja die stärkste Kraft ist.
Und er ist im Gespräch mit Karim Yozgar und wir hören mal so ein bisschen,
okay, wenn die ARD, also der Kommentar stellvertretend für die ARD,
stellvertretend für das Mediensystem, komplett blank ist, was kann eigentlich
die organisierte Politik in Thüringen noch uns dazu sagen?
Für mich ist aber wichtig, dass ich das Problem der Leute erkenne.
Da geht's um Energiepolitik, die vielen Leuten die Sorgesfalten auf die Stirn
treibt. Da geht's um die Frage, dass jeden Tag 1.000 Anträge für Flüchtlinge,
für Migration vorliegen.
Da geht's um die Frage auch, dass in unserem Gesundheitssystem was schiefläuft.
Und das beschäftigt die Sorgen, die Menschen fühlen sich abgehangen.
Die haben das Gefühl, dass man ihnen nicht zuhört, ihre Alltagssorgen nicht löst.
Politik auch ansprechbar sein und nur weil die AfD Themen anspricht,
dürfen wir als demokratische Parteien nicht ausweichen, sondern müssen ganz
klipp und klar sagen, was Sache ist, weil die Leute haben das Gefühl,
wir diskutieren Kleinthemen, aber nicht die großen Fragen und Sorgen, die sie gerade haben.
Aber jetzt ist ja die CDU in Thüringen nicht schuld an dieser ganzen Warum finden
die Menschen bei Ihnen, bei der CDU, kein Zuhause?
Nicht, um missverstanden zu werden, ich bleibe dabei. Wir haben im Verhältnis
zur Wahl vor 5 Jahren 4 Prozentpunkte im 1. Wahlgang dazugewonnen.
Und dann noch mal 11 Prozentpunkte. Die CDU ist die einzige Kraft im demokratischen
Spektrum, der es noch gelungen ist, gegenzuhalten.
Ich glaube, die Ampelparteien sollten sich schon die Frage stellen,
was sie falsch gemacht haben.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass wir nicht auch als CDU demütig sein müssen.
Für uns bedeutet das auch, klare Abgrenzungen und Unterscheidbarkeit zu machen,
sowohl in Thüringen, wo ich Verantwortung trage, wie auch letztlich in Berlin.
Weil das ist das, was die Bürgerinnen und Bürger ausdrücken wollen.
Sie fühlen sich nicht verstanden und mitgenommen.
Und das, was uns unterscheidet als CDU und zur AfD, ist, wir wollen den Zukunftsoptimismus ausdrücken.
Wir sind Mutmacher, wir wollen Probleme lösen. Die AfD ist groß in Probleme
beschreiben, aber klein in Probleme angehen. Und das ist, glaube ich,
der Unterschied. Das ist ein Miesmacher. Und diesen Unterschied,
den werden wir in den nächsten Wochen auch deutlich machen.
Finde ich ganz witzig, dass er die AfD als die Miesmacherpartei und Scholz bei
Anne Will sitzt und genau dasselbe sagt. So, das ist die Partei der schlechten
Laune und so, was ja stimmt, nur diese ganze Herangehensweise...
Nur die meisten Leute haben ja auch schlechte Laune.
Ja, genau.
Also in der Sicht liegen die ja auch richtig.
Wir gucken uns doch die ganze Zeit selbst die Linksliberalen bei der heute Show
immer diesen alten Mann an, der ausflippt.
Wir gucken uns die ganze Zeit gerne Rants an,
Leute die schimpfen und dann wundert man sich,
dass man damit eher gut ankommt und ja, man kann natürlich sagen,
ich bin Mutmacher, aber wenn sich das nicht in meinem Portemonnaie dann irgendwo
auch niederschlägt, dann ist die Frage, wo ist da der Mut?
Genau, also ich kann das, ich will es nur ganz kurz einfügen,
wo seine CDU regiert, nämlich jetzt in Berlin.
Das Bezirksamt Neukölln hat ja gestern bekannt gegeben aufgrund Budgetkürzungen,
wofür man kein Geld mehr hat. Und da haben die eine ganze Liste.
Also Wachschutz an zwölf Neuköllner Schulen entfällt, Tagesreinigung an Neuköllner
Schulen entfällt, Obdachlosenhilfe wird reduziert, Wegfall der aufsuchenden
Suchthilfe, Wasserspielplätze werden geschlossen, Kaputte Spielgeräte auf Spielplätzen
werden nicht mehr erneuert.
Müllentsorgung in Grünanlagen wird halbiert.
Schließung von drei Jugendfreizeit- und Familieneinrichtungen,
Reduzierung von Stadtteilkoordinaten ab 2025.
Jugendreisen für besonders betroffene Jugendliche werden nicht mehr finanziert.
Freie Stellen im Bezirksamtes werden temporär nicht nachbesetzt.
Der Altrigsdorfer Weihnachtsmarkt fällt weg. Aber er heißt immerhin auch Weihnachtsmarkt
und nicht Wintermarkt, kann sich die CDU stolz darauf verstanden haben.
Ich habe diese Liste bei Twitter gesehen als Bild Und hab gedacht, ah ja, guter Move.
Keine Ahnung. Bis ich gesehen habe, ach nee, das ist das Bezirksamt selber, das so kommuniziert.
Das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie die Linkspartei, die auch nochmal eine Punktlandung
machen will oder so, sondern nee, das Bezirksamt selber hat das so kommuniziert,
dass das jetzt die Streichliste ist.
Und wir erinnern uns ja damals in Berlin, und das ist jetzt Berlin,
das ist den Leuten in Sonneberg nicht zu vermitteln, dass selbst im urbansten
Megazentrum Deutschlands und dort noch mal im Melting Pot solche Kürzungen stattfinden.
Und denen dann gesagt, wir müssen selbst in Berlin zu sparen,
überlegt mal, was das für euch bedeutet.
Ihr interessiert uns wirklich gar nicht mehr. Das steckt da so dahinter.
Während dann Olaf Scholz irgendwie bei Anne Will sitzt und irgendwas vom Respekt wieder erzählt.
Also, dass man ja ganz viel Respekt haben soll. Denn hier könnte man sich ja
auch fragen, ja, wenn die Berliner Kommune das nicht bezahlen kann,
könnte dann einfach das Land oder der Bund automatisch einspringen.
Und sagen, ey, wir können nicht über Zusammenhalt auf der einen Seite reden
und dann das zulassen, weil wir es zum Beispiel nicht hinkriegen,
die Kommunen zu entschulden.
Das hat ja alles mit Finanzierungsproblemen zu tun.
Um nicht missverstanden zu werden, die AfD würde nichts besser machen,
sondern würde noch mehr schließen und würde noch alles, was irgendwie Migranten
oder Transpersonen zugute käme, natürlich restlos streichen und würde da die
Hölle auf Erden verbreiten.
Nur die AfD erscheint in dem Moment dann als fundamentale Opposition,
weil unsere Mutmacher der Nation, unsere Muntermacher der Nation ja nur Politik
machen, die in diese Richtung geht.
Keinen höheren Mindestlohn, da und da wird alles geschlossen Und dadurch hat
man natürlich, wenn man dann noch signalisiert, wir haken uns alle unter,
gezeigt, wir stehen auf dieser einen Seite.
Mit uns gibt es Kürzungen, höhere Zinsen, Inflation und alles.
Dann erscheint eine Alternative, die in Wahrheit keine ist. Aber die Frage ist,
es wird immer gesagt, die sind Antidemokraten, die die AfD gewählt haben.
Das stimmt auf lange Sicht, weil die AfD eine Partei wäre, die die Demokratie
arg beschneiden würde. nachvollziehen. Aber die Tatsache, dass diese Leute wählen
gehen, zeigt ja nächstes mal, dass sie sich am demokratischen Akt beteiligen.
Nun ist es ja so, dass man sich fragen kann, wenn man in diesem demokratischen Rahmen denkt und,
sieht es gibt allen grund dazu schlechte laune zu haben vielleicht nicht nur
weil es einem selbst schlechter geht sondern weil man generell um sich rum nur
leute sieht denen es schlechter geht wen soll man denn wählen.
Ja genau.
Also das würde ich gerne wissen. Also ich habe in meinem Bekanntenkreis Leute,
wenn ich die anspreche auf entsprechende Themen hier, Lohnentwicklung und so
weiter, dann drehen die vollkommen am Rad.
Die sind alle davor, völlig gefeiert die AfD zu wählen. Das würde nie passieren,
aber die Tatsache ist auch, dass die dann sagen, ja, ich wähle dann gar nicht mehr oder so.
Und die sind auch nicht mehr am Ende damit zu locken, so wir verhindern das
kleinere Übel oder so, also beziehungsweise da ist nicht, das muss man denen
nur noch mal gut erklären, sondern da ist kein Verständnis mehr.
Und wenn ich das hier von dem Bezirksamt sehe, da kann man nicht mehr den Bürgern
das mal gut erklären. Es ist einfach schändlich, dass so etwas geschieht.
Ja, und man muss noch mal dazu sagen, Oliver Decker hat gestern in Berlin noch
eine Studie zum politischen Denken, insbesondere der Ostdeutschen vorgestellt.
Wir hören nachher noch einen Clip und meinte da auch noch mal,
wenn man jetzt irgendwie glaubt, naja, da müssen halt alle Demokraten mal aufstehen
und zur Wahl gehen. Das kann ja nicht so sein, dass so viele Nichtwähler und so.
Diese Nichtwähler, die wir auch in Sonneberg dann noch haben,
40 Prozent sind nicht zu dieser Wahl jetzt gegangen am Sonntag,
die gehen dann tendenziell alle zur AfD.
Also das ist unmobilisiertes Potenzial der AfD, das sind Leute,
die sind schon abgemeldet und wir müssen auch dazu sagen, in Ostsachsen und
so weiter, da gibt es Ultranationalisten, denen ist die AfD zu links.
Also die wählen einfach die AfD nicht, weil die die in derselben Soße sehen und so.
Also die Potenziale sind dann noch sehr viel größer als das,
was wir jetzt so manifestiert sehen bei den Wahlen.
Zu diesem Berliner Sachverhalt, der steckt ja anders als der Sonneberger häufiger
in den Medien, wie zum Beispiel durch die Silvesterkrawalle.
Dann, weil diese Neuwahl da drohte, hat ja Giffey dieses große Programm gemacht
und irgendwie Talkshows veranstaltet und so weiter und alle durften mal hin
und ihre Sorgen. Dann wurde sogar groß von Geldern gesprochen.
Und dann kam diese Neuwahl und das betrifft nun auch,
es ist auch interessant, dass jetzt gerade Juni ist, also wir liegen genau zwischen
zwei Silvesterpartys und überlegen uns,
okay, wenn das die letzte Silvesterparty da so abging, wie wird eigentlich die
nächste Silvesterparty in Berlin werden, wenn wir im Juni genau dazwischen so
eine Nachrichtenlage haben?
Berlins Antwort Anfang des Jahres auf die Krawalle in der Stadt.
90 Mio. Euro für Maßnahmen gegen Jugendgewalt.
Allein 60 neue Sozialarbeiter sollen in armen Kiezen eingestellt werden.
Das verspricht die damalige regierende Bürgermeisterin bei zwei eilig einberufenen Jugendgipfeln.
Wir waren sehr beeindruckt von der Politik, dass die so schnell gehandelt haben.
Und dass es auch so rassismussensibel alles war. Dass die Frau Giffey z.B.
Gesagt hat, das sind alles unsere Kinder.
Und dann bis heute nichts. Der Regierungswechsel in Berlin kommt dazwischen.
Noch verhandeln CDU und SPD über den neuen Haushalt. Bislang ist kein Geld nach Neukölln geflossen.
Ein Problem auch für Martin Hiekel, den Bürgermeister des Bezirks.
Wir sind mit viel Euphorie Anfang des Jahres gestartet. Es gab einen guten Schwung.
Momentan bin ich ernüchtert, weil wir noch nichts auf die Straße bekommen haben.
Ich sehe die reale Gefahr, dass wir uns in nächster Gelegenheit wieder anschauen
und sagen, wie wir so weit gekommen sind.
Wir hören den Clip nicht, den Spiegel-TV-Ausschnitt von vor der Wahl in Sonneberg.
Letzte Woche im Ohr, wie dieser eine übergewichtige Boomer da sitzt.
Weil er so meinte, die NSDAP würde ich noch wählen. Und dann gefragt wird,
aber die haben 6 Mio. Juden getötet. Und er so, ja, pff, was soll's.
Und auf die Nachfrage dann sagt, ja, die palabern ja alle nur da oben.
Und wenn man so eine Nachrichtenlage hat, dass da irgendwie die regierende Bürgermeisterin
dir in der Veranstaltung vor dir stehend 90 Mio.
Euro verspricht, und 3 Monate später ist genau alles davon Makulatur,
dann ist das wirklich nur Gelaber.
Ja, also dann ist es sehr schwer, den Leuten in Sonneberg auszureden,
dass sie jetzt aber ganz wichtig sind, weil da muss man einfach liefern oder
dazu schweigen. Also einfach gar nichts machen.
Gut, ich will einen spezifischen Kritikpunkt machen.
Wir hatten nämlich den Verfassungsschutzpräsidenten Haldewang,
der sein Bericht vorgelegt hat, wie es um den Extremismus und die Spionage und
so weiter war natürlich riesiges Thema, dass die Chinesen und die Russen uns alle ausspionieren.
Also so weit, so klar.
Und dann ging's natürlich auch noch mal um sein Lieblingsthema,
weil er es ja tatsächlich nach dieser Maaßen-Szenerie da im Amt ein bisschen
wichtiger genommen hat, der Rechtsextremismus, und erklärt uns, wie folgt darüber auf.
Aber Herr Haldemann, wenn eine Partei, die in Ihrem Extremismusbericht vorkommt,
in Ostdeutschland in Umfragen schon mal knapp 30 Prozent bekäme und stärkste
Kraft würde, was heißt das für Ihren Bericht? Und für dieses Land?
Das ist ja dann keine Randerscheinung mehr.
Umso wichtiger ist es, dass wir eben über diese Partei und ihre Bestrebungen
eben aufklären, über das, was die Gefahr dieser Partei für unsere Demokratie,
für unsere freiheitliche Grundordnung ausmacht.
Und natürlich soll das auch die gesellschaftlichen Kräfte mobilisieren,
sich diesem Trend stärker entgegenzustellen.
Denn nicht allein der Verfassungsschutz ist dafür zuständig,
die Umfragewerte der AfD zu senken.
Dazu haben wir keinerlei Möglichkeiten.
Aber wir können die Bevölkerung wachrütteln, wir können Politiker wachrütteln
und der Kampf für unsere Demokratie muss in der Gesamtgesellschaft geführt werden.
So, ganz zarte Anmerkung von ihm. Es ist eine gesamtgesellschaftliche Aufgabe.
Jetzt haben wir hier schon an diesem AD-Kommentar und so weiter.
Also die Medien sehen ja keine Schuld bei sich selber, sondern die sagen,
ja, die Regierung, die Regierung irgendwie. Dann müssten wir uns ja überlegen,
Regierung, was jetzt genau Regierung?
Verwechseln die irgendwie Regierung mit Politik? Also klammern die dann die
Opposition aus oder meinen die eigentlich Regierung und Opposition?
Wer genau ist denn dann der Verantwortung?
Die Altparteien, wie die AfD dann selbst sagen würde.
Die machen ja die Unterscheidung nicht. Die ist einfach alles egal.
Alles Altpartei und wir sind die Alternative.
Ob die jetzt Regieren oder Opposition machen, ist ja halt, die plabern halt alle da oben.
Und jetzt sagt er, naja, selbst wenn man nochmal ganz filigran,
auch Regierung und Opposition hier, Nein, wir müssten die Politik selbst mal
auf die Plätze ein bisschen verweisen, auch in den Medien, und sagen,
es ist eine gesamtgesellschaftliche Aufgabe.
Christian Sievers versucht, die Regierung und die mit ihrem Heizungsgesetz und
so weiter festzunageln.
Heidewangen sagt aber noch mal, nein, vielleicht ist es doch eine größere Aufgabe.
Politiker wachrütteln, sagen Sie gerade, das ist ja interessant.
Wie problematisch ist es denn aus Ihrer Sicht, wenn die Problemlösungskompetenz
viele Bürger im Moment Opposition.
Immerhin informieren wir die Bundesregierung. Die Bundesregierung muss selber
ihre Schlüsse aus den Informationen ziehen, die sie von uns bekommt.
Aber es ist eben auch nicht nur die Regierung aufgefordert, sondern alle gesellschaftlichen
Gruppierungen, die den Kampf gegen den Rechtsextremismus und für unsere Demokratie
führen müssen. Das ist auch nicht allein eine Angelegenheit der Regierung.
Ja, also angeklammert ist damit auf jeden Fall schon mal der Medienbetrieb.
Und darüber hinaus aber alles.
Und auch dann jeder Twitter-Diskurs, im Prinzip diese ganzen Dinge.
Ich würde noch mal kurz sprechen wollen.
Wir hatten ja über Weltshorn-Precht im Salon ausführlich gesprochen.
Aber ist es doch ganz erstaunlich, dass wir so merkwürdige Diskursverschiebungen
haben. Also wir haben sicherlich so eine Normalisierungstendenz der AfD jetzt.
Das glaube ich, können viele Leute bestätigen, dass es nicht mehr so stark tabuisiert
ist, AfD-Positionen gut zu finden.
Das merkt man immer mehr, auch wie das medial berichtet wird.
Die Partei ist jetzt lang genug da, dass sich das einsetzen kann.
Dann gibt es sicherlich eine Diskursverschiebung, die damit einhergeht,
dass wir härtere Ausfälle haben.
Aber nicht nur von Seiten der AfD.
Also da kennen wir das ja schon sehr lange, Alice Weidel von Storch und so,
da war das ja auch im Extrem kaum noch steigerbar.
Aber dieses Sagbare wird natürlich jetzt auch so von der Opposition,
also von der CDU immer so weiter verschoben.
Dass man jetzt plötzlich auch mit queerfeindlichen Positionen noch mal einen
Blumentopf gewinnen kann. Oder man denkt an diese merkwürdige Rede von Pechstein.
Das heißt, da haben wir diese Diskursverschiebung in diese Richtung.
Zugleich haben wir aber.
Diskursverengungen, die wir auch beobachten. Die kommen dann wiederum sowohl
von Ampelkoalition, als auch von CDU, als auch von Linkspartei,
würde ich da auch mal sogar mit reinnehmen.
Wenn ich daran denke, man ist kein Querdenker, hat sich impfen lassen und sagt
im Herbst 2022, ich würde jetzt ungern weiter Maske im ICE tragen.
O ist jetzt auch in der Schwurplerecke angekommen.
Man sagt, im Frühjahr, im Sommer, als der Krieg begonnen hat,
vielleicht muss man darüber nachdenken, dass wir auf so einer Zuschauerloge sind.
Wir sind eigentlich nicht Kriegspartei und sollten auch vielleicht mehr über
Verhandlungen nachdenken.
Und dieser Satz, die Ukraine muss diesen Krieg gewinnen, ist in gewisser Weise
eine leere Formel, weil es sicherlich auf irgendeinen Kompromiss hinauslaufen wird.
Wenn das Leute wie, und das sind alles Leute aus der Mitte, Precht,
Belser, Juli C., Habermas, so was sagen Flasspöhler, Schwurplerecke,
Putin-Knechte und so weiter.
Und dieser Diskurs führt dazu, dass man sagt, ja, man kann ja,
und das wird aber dann vermixt mit, ja, man kann ja nicht mehr das N-Wort sagen.
Und das ist aber, das muss man voneinander separieren, ja.
Also wir haben zum einen haben wir eine Eskalation im Diskurs und zum anderen
haben wir im bürgerlich-liberalen und gerade medial geprägten Spektrum eine
wahnsinnige Diskursverengung, was das anbelangt.
Also das führt dann dazu, dass dann Mariam Lau sagt, wir haben uns so schön
ergänzt bei Anne Will, ja, weil man keine andere Position mehr zugelassen hat, ja.
Und da kommt auch wieder das Vakuum, wo ist dann jetzt eine Partei, Die.
Doch noch diesen Diskurs in dieser Weise auch offen hält und sagt,
ja, das ist aber auch eine probante Sache, über Frieden zu reden.
Wir haben eine Margot Kaesmann, die nicht zum evangelischen Kirchentag geht,
weil sie nur angefeindet wird von ihrer eigenen Kirche.
Diese ganzen Sachen muss man doch wahrnehmen.
Und dass man das so ausklammert und ich würde auch mal unterstreichen,
es gibt medial zwar, was das Wirtschaftliche anbelangt, einen sehr konservativen,
neoliberalen Diskurs nach wie vor. Das sieht man dann auch, wie es über Mindestlohn berichtet wird.
Gerade in diesen anderen Fragen des Krieges hat man eine sehr starke grüne Hegemonie.
Auch in der Außenpolitik.
Es ist interessant, dass die Leute sehr verloren sind, die Links sind und die
sich immer stark gemacht haben für die Rechte von Flüchtlingen.
Die wollten mehr Flüchtlinge aufnehmen.
Die werden auch nicht von der Ampel repräsentiert.
Bei den Linken haben sie das Problem, haben und wen würden sie eigentlich wählen,
wenn sie die jetzt gerade wählen, eher das Wagenknechtlager oder eher das Kippinglager
und die stehen völlig verloren, bei denen ist keine Gefahr, dass sie zur AfD gehen.
Aber ich will mal aufzeigen, dass diese Position nicht mehr vertreten ist und
man konnte es sogar so gut sehen an diesem Asylkompromiss.
Das ist das, was eigentlich Seehofer einmal wollte, jetzt durchgesetzt von Baerbock.
Und Baerbock hat sich jetzt auch nicht mehr vertreten, weil er sich nicht mehr vertreten hat.
Ist aber im Kreis der der risos der
jan böhmermanns der und und und ja wir müssen die
nicht alle aufzählen also der der linksliberalen medienbubble
mit Millionen gehalt im jahr Ist diese grüne hegemonie da und deswegen haben
wir keinen shitstorm erlebt stellt euch bitte einmal vor was gewesen wäre wenn
Dieser Asylkompromiss wäre unter einer schwarz-roten Regierung gekommen.
Da wäre noch ein Seehofer oder so mit dran beteiligt gewesen.
Es hätte große Demonstrationen auf der Straße gegeben.
100 Rezo-Videos und 50 Influencer und so weiter. Da hätte man alles miteinander vernetzt.
Es gab ein paar Proteste, aber eigentlich geht das so durch.
Diese Position wird auch gar nicht mehr von denen abgedeckt.
Das große demokratische Feld, das alles integriert.
Also diese Fehlspezifikationen im Diskursgefüge sind ja eigentlich die Antwort
auf die Frage, wenn mir die Heizungsgesetzgebung der Ampel nicht gefällt.
Oder ist ja auch nur eine Chiffre, für das, was halt die sechs Monate vor so
einer Wahl diskutiert wird.
Warum wähle ich dann eigentlich die AfD?
Und zwar noch besonders, weil ich dann weiß, die sind sogar gesichert rechtsextrem
und der Chef ist ein Faschist.
Also kann ich damit mein Anliegen, das ich habe, besonders deutlich machen.
Und nicht jemand anderen. Warum wähle ich nicht jemand anderen?
Warum fällt diese Art von Opposition gegen dieses Gesamtgefüge Diskursfehlspezifikation
spitzifikation ja eigentlich so radikal aus,
Kann man das nicht wieder ein bisschen einhegen? Und dazu gehört,
würde ich auch sagen, alle Unterscheidungen mal klar zu ziehen.
Zum Beispiel die zwischen Regierung und Opposition und Politik,
und da ist nämlich eingeklammert Regierung und Opposition und der Rest.
Dann von Halderwang so Hinweise wie, ja, das ist gesamtgesellschaftliche Aufgabe.
Ah ja, damit meint er ja eigentlich, dass er der Christan sie was sagen müssen oder sagen können.
Ah ja, wenn sie sagen, es ist nicht nur eine politische Aufgabe,
meinen sie damit, es gibt Aufgaben, die die Politik gar nicht lösen kann?
Womit wir sie überfordern würden, wenn wir jetzt immer nur vehement sagen,
aber die muss hier mal und so weiter, die Leute sind arm, die Leute sind zu
wenig gebildet und so weiter, die Politik hat versagt.
Sind wir damit vielleicht auf dem falschen Weg? Oder hätte man sagen können,
ah, medial stellt man jetzt also fest, okay, wir machen zwar eine Nachrichtensendung
und da spielt auch Politik eine große Rolle Und natürlich in der Politik die
Regierung und Oppositionsunterscheidung und so weiter.
Man kann sich da so ganz in diesem ganz kleinen Spielfeld, das es da gibt,
so austoben. Aber es gibt ja noch so ein Kosmos drumherum.
Und man könnte auch mal über politische Themen, ohne sie gleich an politisches
Personal zu knüpfen und so weiter, um auch bei den Menschen mal eine Aufmerksamkeit darauf zu lenken.
Ein Landrat, der kann euch jetzt plakatieren, dass er gegen den Heizungshammer
ist, aber der hat da gar keine Handhabe. Also das ist wirklich völlig ausgeschlossen.
Der macht auch keine Migrationspolitik oder Sonstiges. Also das ist halt einfach Landrat.
Diese Art von Aufklärung, wo einfach klare Unterscheidungen gezogen werden.
Was ist jetzt die Verantwortung der Regierung? Was ist die Verantwortung der
Politik? Und wo hat beides leider, auch wenn wir es uns wünschen, wünschen.
Gar nichts verloren, weil die Verantwortung müssen wir dann selber tragen.
Wozu, finde ich, auch gehört den Thüringern, wir haben es ja auch an dem Ostenbuch
von Oschmann besprochen, irgendwo gibt es auch Verantwortlichkeiten für die
eigene Lebenszufriedenheit.
Und wenn man feststellt, hier ist ja gar kein Schwimmbad für mich,
in dem ich schwimmen kann, also auch keine Schwimmbereine, also auch nicht,
ja, dann muss hier vielleicht mal irgendjemand gründen, statt immer nur darauf
zu warten, dass jetzt irgendwer hier
dir einen Mitgliedschaftsbeitrag abbucht und dir den Vertrag hinhält.
Vielleicht muss man derjenige sein, der den Mitgliedschaftsvertrag aushändigt
und dieses Denken ist ja bei sehr vielen Leuten, das ist dann gar keine Aussie-Kritik,
sozusagen sehr weit entfernt.
Dieses etwas ältere Bild, dass man die Politik so mit so einem Pizza-Lieferservice
verwechselt und einfach anruft und sagt, ja, ich hätte jetzt gern das und das
und das, liefert mir das mal und 20 Minuten später klingelt es und dann muss
man nur Geld dafür bezahlen und alles ist erledigt.
Nee, irgendwo gibt es vielleicht noch andere Aufgaben.
Und wir wollen ja auch gar nicht in diesen essenzialistischen Diskurs,
das haben wir auch bei unserer Besprechung des Oschmann Buchs nochmal sehr deutlich gemacht,
dass man jetzt sagt, ja die Thüringer, diese gequälten Seelen und da müssen
wir jetzt das so essenzialisieren,
dass wir die jetzt als, also wir, also sei das so eine eigene Spezies Mensch
nochmal und da muss man dann vielleicht nochmal ein besonderes Verständnis,
nein ich habe überhaupt gar kein Verständnis dafür, wenn jemand sich entscheidet, die AfD zu wählen.
Ich kann Erklärungen für gewisse Diskursverschiebungen oder für Wählerwechsel und so was herleiten.
Aber die Leute, die die AfD wählen, vollziehen einen bewussten Akt.
Und dies ist ein Akt, der eine rechte Partei stark macht. Und da gibt es auch
nichts dran zu deuteln. Und wir brauchen nicht diese essenzialistische Frage
zu stellen, sind es Nazis?
Aber sie verhalten sich in dem Moment so, kann ich sagen. Und das reicht mir
ja. Das ist ja so die Frage so, bist du ein Dieb? Gerade nicht,
aber wenn ich nachher was klaue, dann habe ich was gestohlen so.
Also Florian Schröder war ja sehr deutlich in seinem Podcast, der hat immer gesagt.
Die AfD-Wähler, die Sesselmann gewählt haben, sind Nazis, weil sie Nazis gewählt haben.
Und da habe ich so ein bisschen zustimmend auf Twitter geschrieben,
ja, ich war auch 2017 schon der Meinung, wer im Bund AfD wählt, ist halt ein Nazi.
Dann kam natürlich viel Kritik, ja, aber du hast ja nicht in die Köpfe der Leute
reingeguckt. Da sage ich als Soziologe, nö, mache ich auch nicht.
Ich treffe meine Urteile, was das angeht, eben anders. Ich gucke denen nicht,
also ob die jetzt überzeugte Nazis sind, kann von mir nicht irgendein Psychologe
oder irgendein Hobby-Bastler oder so klären.
Aber wir haben ja erst mal sozusagen soziale Effekte in der echten Welt,
die nun mal politisch geprägt ist. Und wenn da sehr viele AfDler in den Parlamenten
sitzen, dann ist ja auch egal, was der Wähler dabei dachte.
Luhmann hat schon von Anfang an gesagt, wir wählen so ein bisschen motivlos.
Es geht uns nicht so ganz konkret um unser Programm, sondern man wählt halt einfach so.
Also sonst sind ja auch viele andere Wahlergebnisse nicht zu erklären. Ja, genau.
Deswegen ja auch immer wieder diese große Diskussion, wann ist eigentlich der
Wahltermin? Weil das viel entscheidender ist, als was der Wähler jetzt so durchdenkt.
Leute wie Wolfgang Schäuble oder so, die jahrzehntelang Karriere machen können,
das ist ja auch nicht mit Ratio begründbar, also das ist ja nur völliger Unsinn.
Und ich will das noch sagen, das bedeutet aber nicht, wenn man sagt,
die sind rechts oder die sind jetzt Nazis oder Rechtsextreme oder was auch immer,
wie man die Werte titulieren will.
Die Sache ist, diese Essentialität, die man dann so formuliert,
bedeutet aber nicht eine dauerhafte Essentialität.
Das ist jetzt nicht so wie, ich habe eine Hautfarbe oder ich habe Schuhgröße
43, sondern es bedeutet, dass man,
hier durch den Akt etwas manifestiert, was aber durch den nächsten Akt wieder
weggenommen werden kann.
Man kann ja dann wieder eine andere Partei wählen. Ich würde sagen,
es gibt sicherlich eine Gruppe, wenn man auf Deutschland blickt,
die konstant rechts ist.
Das wird wahrscheinlich eine Herkules-Aufgabe sein, die von was anderem zu überzeugen.
Dann gibt es aber ein Potenzial, was man daran sieht, dass die Umfragen mal
steigen, mal fallen. Und jetzt sind sie gerade sehr hoch für die AfD,
die jetzt sagen, ich würde auch mal die AfD wählen, aus verschiedenen Gründen.
Das will ich mal strapazieren.
Das sollte man unterscheiden. Aber man sollte die, die die Wahl dann getroffen
haben, und die dann sagen, aus Trotz wähle ich die jetzt, die sollte man nicht
durchkommen lassen mit, eigentlich habe ich gar nichts mit der AfD zu tun.
Nee, die hast du dann schon gewählt.
Das ist ja Demokratie.
Wir ermächtigen ja niemand auf Lebenszeit, vor allem nicht auf unsere Lebenszeit,
dass wir den Rest unseres Lebens von irgendwem regiert werden,
sondern wir können ja alle vier Jahre neu entscheiden. Die Italiener übertreiben es ja komplett.
Die verteilen ja gar nicht Verantwortung, sondern nur so, ja dann versuch's
halt mal. Wenn es nicht klappt, putschen wir dich in drei Monaten wieder weg.
Und dann haben sie einfach 60 Nachwuchsregierung in 60 Jahren.
Nur die Herausforderung, finde ich, ist ja folgende. Klingt jetzt sehr groß,
aber ist eigentlich gar nicht so groß.
Wenn wir der Meinung sind, dass in Thüringen sehr viele nicht überzeugte Faschisten,
Nazis, was auch immer, AfD gewählt haben, weil sie Protest wählen wollten,
weil ihnen irgendwas auf den Geist geht, weil sie irgendwer hat sie in die Falle
gelockt zu glauben, die Politik kann über dein ganzes Schicksal entscheiden
und der, der dir das beste Angebot macht, der ist es dann irgendwie.
Dann sollten wir uns auch die Herausforderung stellen zu sagen, ja,
aber dann schaffen wir es vielleicht in den nächsten 20 Jahren,
dass sehr viele überzeugte Nazis und Menschenhasser, die es ja nun mal auch
gibt, Trotzdem vielleicht mal die SPD oder die CDU wählen, allein weil die ein
anderes politisches Angebot machen und vielleicht ein realistisches.
Das wäre ja die eigentliche Herausforderung, würde ich jetzt sagen,
dass man jetzt nicht so aktionistisch, naja, wir müssen jetzt ganz viel darüber
reden und das ist dann drei Tagen schon wieder vergessen, sondern man bräuchte
jetzt so ein Plan, Agenda 2045.
Wir wollen bis dahin klimaneutral sein, wir haben bis dahin die Boomer durch die Rente gebracht,
weil dann kommen sie an die Lebenserwartung und wir sollten uns noch politisch
entnazifizieren und wir sollten selbst diejenigen,
die überzeugte Menschenhasser sind, nochmal sagen, ja, du kannst gerne Menschen
hassen, aber wenn es straffatig relevant wird, kommen wir dich auch besuchen und sperren dich ein.
Aber selbst du wirst, glaube ich, Restintelligenz haben, um zu verstehen,
bei der einen oder anderen Wahlentscheidung wäre es vielleicht besser,
den oder den für deinen Sonneberg Heimatland zu wählen, weil dann kommt mehr
bei rum. So, das ist die Herausforderung, finde ich.
Das muss aber dann auch eingelöst werden, dass auch wirklich mehr bei rumkommt.
Also das ist natürlich auch für die Opposition oder für Regierung und die Opposition
ist es natürlich auch sehr leid.
Also die AfD ist natürlich so stümperhaft, dass natürlich alles,
was die in Berlin verbrocken, immer noch besser aussieht, als das,
was die AfD machen würde. Aber das kann ja nicht der Maßstab sein.
Jetzt kann man natürlich dieses große Entzauberungsargument machen irgendwie.
Keine Ahnung, die werden sich schon entzaubern.
Der Sesselmann, der muss ja irgendwann seinen Leuten schon erklären,
warum er jetzt hier irgendwie, es sind ja dann auch wirklich,
also wenn er sich an diese Gesetze, die nun mal gelten, nicht hält,
wenn er sie nicht umsetzt, wird er juristisch belangt.
Ja, also in der Rolle ist er nicht. Und er wird schon irgendeinen Schuldigen ausmachen.
Genau, er kann natürlich diese Donald Trump Schiene fahren und die ganze Zeit
im Amt mega Opposition gegen alle machen, aber wir müssen uns mal kurz hier
über Merz verständigen. Merz führt die Opposition.
Jetzt haben wir von Halterwagen und wir haben es auch besprochen.
Ja, vielleicht sollte die Politik auch mal erklären, was sie eigentlich kann.
Nicht nur Opposition ist Mist, sondern auch in der Regierung stellt man fest,
dass man gar nicht so mächtig ist, wie man immer dachte.
Es ist ja nun mal eine Demokratie, sehr viele Aufgaben, da hat man einfach,
also können wir nicht nur sagen, ja, der Sesselmann hat jetzt mit diesen politischen
Feldern gar nichts zu tun, sondern es gibt gar kein politisches Amt,
das irgendwie für lebenszufriedenheit oder was auch immer sorgen kann.
Und Friedrich Merz war vorgestern bei der Pressekonferenz nachdem...
Die CDU-Fraktionsvorsitzenden, die haben so eine eigene Konferenz,
also die im europäischen Parlament, die Landesfraktion, der Bundestag natürlich,
die haben so eine eigene, keine Ahnung, die tagen dann immer mal so zusammen
und stimmen sich so ein bisschen ab und da saß Merz bei der Pressekonferenz und sagte folgendes.
Wir sind die eigentliche Alternative zu dieser Bundesregierung.
Wir kritisieren nicht nur, sondern wir machen konkrete Vorschläge,
wie man es besser machen kann.
Wenn das stimmen würde, hätten wir schon ganz schön viel weniger Probleme,
wenn die Opposition wie im englischen Verständnis so Schattenminister,
die echte Schatten Gesetzesvorschläge schreiben, statt sich nur darüber aufzuregen,
dass er die Ampel des GEG noch gar nicht geschrieben hat und Bundestag ist aber schon terminiert.
Welches Angebot macht denn Merz jetzt? Welches Angebot hat denn die CDU gemacht,
außer halt diesen Sprech zu übernehmen? Ja, das ist der Heizhammer,
das kommen wir ja gar nicht. Und dann kommt diese Heizungsstasi zu dir nach
Hause, ja, das war ja Thüringer CDU und so.
Also da liegt ja wirklich nur diese Kritik drin. Diese Kritik,
das können die Leute auch selber machen. Also das ist dann auch Kabarett.
In Sonneberg kann man das auf der Bühne nochmal aufführen für diese Art.
Nur für die Opposition einfach zu markieren, was liegt denn im eigenen Handlungsbereich
und wie könnten wir das Leben der Leute besser machen und zwar realistisch.
Also wir werden morgen gewählt und dann wäre das unser Gesetzesvorschlag.
Da sind ja auch die Medien nicht hinterher, sowas zu reportieren.
Das setzt ja voraus, dass die das Leben von uns auch besser machen wollen.
Zum Beispiel. Das setzt ein ehrliches und vernünftiges Verständnis von Politik hin.
Genau, also da muss die CDU sehr viel an sich selber arbeiten.
Ein anderer Spruch von Merz.
Man kann auf Dauer nicht Politik über die Köpfe der Menschen hinweg machen.
Jedenfalls in einer Demokratie brauchen sie Zustimmung. Die muss man nicht jeden Tag haben.
Man kann auch nicht nur nach Umfragen entscheiden. Aber wenn Sie die Bevölkerung
verlieren auf dem Weg, den Sie mit einer solchen Transformation gehen wollen,
und genau das ist jetzt eingetreten, dann dürfen Sie sich über solche Wahlergebnisse
nicht wundern. Das ist eine Herausforderung für uns alle.
Wir müssen alle dafür sorgen, dass das wieder anders wird. Aber das ist ein
mühsamer Weg. Das ist ein langer Weg.
Und wir fühlen uns da auch als Union, als CDU und CSU gleichermaßen mit in der
Verpflichtung, dafür zu sorgen, dass solche Wahlergebnisse sich nicht verfestigen.
Mit der Union wären der Mindestlohn vielleicht dann noch gesunken.
Wir haben kein einziges Angebot von der Union, wie die ökonomische Lage besser wird.
Von der Ampel bekommen wir es jetzt auch nicht. Aber von der Union auch nicht.
D.h. alle beteiligen sich daran, irgendwelche Partikular- und Kapitalinteressen zu vertreten.
Insofern, ja, ist schon gesagt, schon gesagt, aber hat natürlich nichts mit der Realität zu tun.
Man kann nicht gegen die Bevölkerung regieren. Man kann aber auch nicht gegen
die Bevölkerung Opposition machen, indem man einfach nur seiner partikularistischen
Klientel irgendwie klar macht.
Ja, also wenn wir, wenn ihr uns wählt, und das ist ja dann das Berliner Beispiel,
dann schaffen wir alle Radwege ab.
So ist das, ist das dann Opposition gegen die Bevölkerung? Ich würde sagen ja.
Und so könnte sich auch Scholz hinsetzen und sagen, ja, ist ja schön und gut.
Ich meine, den Sonneberg ist eh egal, wer hier regiert und wer Opposition ist.
Gegen die Bevölkerung Opposition machen ist schwierig,
wenn man inhaltlich nichts in petto hat oder lügen muss, um für die Gesamtbevölkerung,
von der man Stimme haben will, zu
verschleiern, dass man eigentlich nur partikularistische Interessen hat.
Und dann kommt man eben diese Zwickmühle, dass man sich dann irgendwann verfängt.
Also da könnte man ja auch wieder so beziehungsgestalterisch sich irgend so
ein Konzept nehmen von irgendeinem Hochstab oder so, der die ganze Zeit ja immer
so diese großen Versprechungen macht, aber sie dann immer nicht einlöst.
Wie weit kann das eigentlich treiben und mit welchen Prinzipien versucht er
das zu verschleiern, dass er vielleicht doch weniger Geld hat.
Also verspricht immer einen großen Urlaub, aber der wird irgendwie nie angetreten,
weil immer ruft der Chef an und sagt, nee, wir können doch nicht in Urlaub fahren.
Also da geht es drunter und drüber. März nächster Spruch.
Sie können vor allem, nicht nur, aber vor allem in der Regierungsverantwortung
so arbeiten, dass politische Extrema keinen Erfolg haben.
Das ist jetzt bei dieser Koalition anders. Wenn die Regierungsarbeit so ist,
wie sie ist und damit ein solches Wahlergebnis erzielt wird,
dann ist die Opposition nur begrenzt in der Lage, das in die andere Richtung zu korrigieren.
Genau das Gegenteil ist wahr.
Jaja, das ist doch gerade die Möglichkeit für die Opposition,
sich von der besten Seite zu zeigen.
Es ist gerade Aufgabe der Politik, die Extremer einzufangen und sich geradezu
dankbar gegenüber der Regierung zu zeigen, wenn die das provozieren.
Und das ist ja das Problem, dass Merz mit der Linken gemeinsam hat.
Eigentlich können die sich mal zusammensetzen, mal überlegen,
was eigentlich da bei uns los.
Wo kletzt eigentlich, genau.
Die Ampel ist verhasst jetzt so richtig, auch von vielen, die sie gewählt haben.
Die Leute drehen durch und jetzt könnten die die einsammeln.
Aber das gelingt nur der AfD momentan.
Genau. Und wenn sie ehrlich kommunizieren würden, also wenn das jetzt in der,
geht wahrscheinlich nur in dem Film oder so, auch kein Journalist würde es hinbekommen.
Aber wir können uns ungefähr vorstellen, wie nach dieser Sonnebergwahl diese
Fraktionsvorsitzenden Konferenz ablief,
Dass sich nämlich alle CDU-Leute schockiert in die Augen geguckt haben und meinten,
Scheiße, wir können hier gar nichts machen.
Selbst wenn die Ampel regiert und die Bild-Zeitung sagt, Das ist wirklich der
Untergang des Abendslandes.
Können wir hier nicht, also haben wir keine Raumgewinne, sondern es fließt alles an die AfD.
Ja, ich würde ja so weit gehen und sagen, ja, die CDU arbeitet der AfD zu.
Also die Sache ist doch, wenn die jetzt diesen Kulturkampf machen,
und das ist ja eigentlich abgekupfert von allen Kulturkämpfen,
die wir sonst schon so aus anderen Ländern miterlebt haben.
Wenn die den machen und wenn es Leute gibt, die sich davon angesprochen fühlen,
Lanz hat ja toll jetzt Spahn gegrillt und Spahn hat auch gar keine Möglichkeit
mehr gehabt zu antworten, was ich auch gut finde.
Also ich finde, man sollte einfach die Politiker da haben, die zureden und sagen,
jetzt ist die Sendung auch leider aus.
Und wenn aber sich Leute davon angesprochen fühlen und sagen,
ich stimme dieser Rede von Pechstein zu.
Pechstein hatte ja diese Rede gehalten da beim Parteitag der CDU und sagte,
sie will auch noch Zigeunerschnitzel sagen. Und sie möchte auch noch,
dass die Kinder, nee, die Kinder sollen Mama und Papa sagen.
Und nicht irgendein anderes Familienmodell. Und wenn man sich davon angesprochen
fühlt, von einem solchen Stuss, dann wählt man doch das Original.
Dann wählt man doch die AfD. Dann sagt man doch nicht, mit der CDU vielleicht,
sondern die auch in drei Bundesländern mit Grünen regiert.
Sondern dann würde man noch sagen, ich wähle das Original.
Eigentlich Wahlwerbung für die AfD.
Genau, das ist der große, wie soll man sagen, es gibt dieses große Wort der
Lebenslüge und so weiter, aber wenn die CDU sagt, Die Ampel macht scheiß Politik.
Dann stehen die AfD-Wähler da und sagen, ja, ja, das stimmt schon.
Aber wir vertrauen euch einfach nicht, dass ihr es besser macht.
Oder dass ihr, wenn ihr jetzt sagt, ja, ihr seid auch gegen das Gendern und
so weiter, wir wissen doch genau, am Ende kommt dann wieder,
ja, und dann 16 Jahre März, und was haben wir gekriegt?
Eine Sozialdemokratierung der CDU und so weiter.
Also diese Unglaubwürdigkeit, die da drinsteckt, die sich die CDU selbst eingebrockt
hat, die steht ihm hier im Wege.
Und er hat hier in diesem Falle Die Regierung muss die Extremer einhegen.
Genau das Gegenteil von dem gesagt, was er selbst weiß, was richtig ist.
Er hat sich selbst belogen und dann noch versucht, autosuggestiv, uns das ...
Es funktioniert aber nicht. Eigentlich haben die diese Lehre auch schon bekommen.
Es funktioniert einfach nicht. Und dieser, dann wählen wir das Original,
ist einfach der wahrhaftigste Satz in dieser ganzen Gemengelage,
der hier die CDU wirklich hammerhart trifft.
Und der auch, was wir eben gehört haben, Nur die Regierung kann die Extreme
einhegen. Diese Verlogenheit passt überhaupt nicht zu diesem Spruch.
Ich habe auch den Kolleginnen und Kollegen zugesagt, dass wir in den nächsten
Wochen und Monaten unsere Alternativen noch einmal sehr viel deutlicher herausstellen.
Und auch noch einmal sehr viel deutlicher sagen, dass wir nicht nur dagegen
sind, das ist noch keine Opposition.
Das reicht nicht. Wir müssen sehr viel präziser, sehr genauer sagen,
was unsere alternativen Vorstellungen denn sind.
Und unsere Vorstellungen, ich will es mal auf einen einfachen Nenner bringen,
lauten, marktwirtschaftlichen Instrumenten sehr viel mehr Erfolg erzielen.
Wir wollen das in einem freiheitlichen Rechtsstaat tun. Wir wollen die Menschen
nicht bevormunden, nicht neu erziehen, sondern wir wollen mit den Menschen,
mit den Privathaushalten, mit der Bevölkerung diesen Weg der Transformation gehen.
Es ist so schön, er sagt jetzt, will ich es mal auf den Punkt bringen und dann
kommt eine reine Chat-GP-Fabulierungsantwort.
Vor allem, das ist auf so vielen Ebenen. Also entweder wollen sie jetzt die
Transformation mit den Menschen gehen, aber dann passt einfach auch zum Beispiel
diese Berliner Politik mit, mal alle Radwege ab und so. Passt nicht dazu.
Oder er lügt und will doch nicht den Weg mit den Leuten gehen,
aber dann belügt er sie doppelt.
Also das ist einfach, die CDU ist absolut lost, was wir hier feststellen.
Sie ist hauptverantwortlich für den Umstand, dass Menschen, die mit der Ampel
unzufrieden sind, nur noch im Rechtsextremismus Alternativen sehen.
Diese Lücke hat die CDU hier einfach gerissen. Dass er dann diese noch eröffnete
die erste Frage aus dem Plenum war, ja, wollten Sie nicht die AfD halbieren?
Dann sagte er, Sie haben diesen Satz seit 2019 von mir nicht mehr gehört.
Und was heißt das jetzt? Ist einfach vorbei.
Es ist nicht mehr seine Aufgabe, die AfD zu halbieren. Und ich denke,
ne, bleib doch einfach bei dieser Aufgabe, aber finde andere Wege.
Aber jetzt zu sagen, wir werden die AfD nicht mehr halbieren.
Sie war damals bei zehn Prozent und wir erwarten oder zwölf und wir warten,
bei der nächsten wird sie wieder mit zwölf Prozent gewählt werden.
Also damit geben wir uns jetzt ab, damit finden wir uns ab.
Welche Aufgabe stellt sie denn noch? Also es ist doch wirklich...
Und er versucht es rein performativ über so ein vernünftiges Sprechen darzustellen.
Und da würde ich auch sagen, das kann die AfD mitunter jetzt auch.
Also wir haben diese Ausfälle noch alle im Ohr von verschiedenen.
Wir haben diese stümperhaften Auftritte auch im Blick.
Aber dann gibt es ein Tino Chrupalla, der wie Merz zu einer ganz großen Seriosität auftreten kann,
der Argumentationsketten aufmacht, die nicht auf nur Irr hinauslaufen,
sondern wo er dann versucht, auf Argumente einzugehen.
Das heißt, das ist eine Ansprache, die er schafft, für Leute,
die jetzt hier so von Merz sich angesprochen fühlen oder anderen CDU-Leuten,
wo das genauso gut funktionieren kann.
Und diese Erfahrung haben die seit Jahren, das war Frau Kepetri damals schon,
da musste ja im Tagesthemen sie noch, ja sie sind ja Bundesverdienstsbezirksträgerin
und haben diese und jene und was weiß ich für wirtschaftliche Erfolge als Unternehmerin
und dann noch Mutter von vier Kindern und so weiter und dann hat sie ja auch
da 1a Antworten geliefert.
Also in der Hinsicht, genau, diese Spielfelder stehen Merz einfach nicht zur Verfügung.
Und der größte Skandal war natürlich, dass Merz gefragt wird,
ja, jetzt ist der Sesselmann mit der AfD da irgendwie 52 Prozent,
der regiert jetzt einen Landkreis. Und dann sagt er...
Wir werden ganz gezielt und sehr bewusst uns auch auf die politischen Themen
stützen. Wir werden, ich habe den Kollegen ja auch zugesagt,
noch viel deutlicher die Alternativen herausarbeiten, die es zu dieser Bundesregierung gibt.
Das ist das Thema Umweltpolitik, das ist das Thema Energiepolitik.
Und deswegen werden für uns auf absehbare Zeit auch die Grünen die Hauptgegner
sein in dieser Bundesregierung.
Denn die Grünen sind dafür verantwortlich, dass diese Polarisierung um die Energiepolitik,
um die Umweltpolitik in Deutschland in dieser Weise entstanden ist.
Und deswegen werden wir uns ganz besonders mit dieser Politik und den Repräsentanten
der Grünen in der Bundesregierung auseinanderzusetzen haben.
Mein Gegenangebot wäre, Friedrich Merz, erklär nicht,
wer dein Hauptgegner in der Bundesregierung Klar, der Chaya wollte das ja dann
noch retten und hat gesagt, naja, die AfD kann man ja nicht zum Hauptgegner,
weil der hat gesagt, der Hauptgegner in der Bundesregierung und klar,
das wären dann die Grünen.
Aber das ist natürlich absolutes sozusagen Vermeidungskommunikation.
Ich will nicht über die CDU, ich will nicht über mich selber reden müssen.
Ich erkläre jetzt die Grünen zum Hauptgegner, denen müssen wir uns abarbeiten.
Und genau das Gegenteil wäre richtig. Wenn man einfach sagt,
es ist eine ganz selbstbewusste CDU, die genau weiß, was sie will,
die zu ihrem C und zu ihrem D steht und der egal ist, wer regiert.
Das wäre er eigentlich. Dann würde man auch sagen, okay, das ist ein echtes
Angebot, was hier stattfindet, aber einfach nur nicht die Grünen,
dann bist du immer in diesem Jahr, dann wären wir das Original.
Also die AfD hasst die Grünen viel besser als die CDU, wenn er diesen Konkurrenzkampf
weiter aufmachen will, dann ist es einfach verloren.
In Sonneberg selbst waren sie kurz, wir gucken uns das mal kurz an.
Wir sehen zum einen die AfD-Chefs, die mal kurz umrahmen, wie sie sich jetzt
Politik in Anführungszeichen, wir haben ja geklärt, was ein Landrat so macht, wie sich das vorstellt.
Es hat sich gezeigt, dass Interessen für die Bürger, und das ist genau das,
was Robert Sesselmann auch in seinem Wahlkampf hier zum Ausdruck gebracht hat,
dass sich das auszahlt. Denn wir machen Politik für den Bürger und für niemand anderen.
Vorangegangen waren zwei Wochen intensiver Wahlkampf. Die AfD setzte vor allem
auf bundespolitische Themen wie Migration, Heizungsstreit oder Finanzpolitik.
Bei vielen kam das offenbar an.
Bei vielen kam das offenbar an, wir haben hier O-Töne von Wählern.
Jetzt könnten wir uns ja alle mal überlegen, angenommen wir sind jetzt Politiker,
was würden wir diesen Menschen sagen?
Im Landkreis Sonneberg leben rund 57.000 Einwohner. Die Löhne sind hier unterdurchschnittlich.
Dass sich halt was ändert.
Egal in welche Richtung, aber es muss sich halt was ändern. Ich habe nix gegen Ausländer.
Aber das nimmt überhaupt, das ist viel zu viel.
Dieser Mann hat noch nie einen Ausländer gesehen. Der wohnt in Sonneberg,
da gibt es keine Ausländer. Da kommen nicht mal Touristen hin. Ja.
Man müsste den Mann mal fragen. Sieht so aus, als müsste er bald gepflegt werden.
Wer das eigentlich dann übernehmen wird, wie viele Kinder er dann selbst hat und so weiter.
Und dieser junge Frau, die sagt, es muss sich einfach irgendwas ändern in irgendeine
Richtung. da müsste man schon auch von ihr eine Konkretisierung abverlangen.
Was wäre denn wünschenswert? Sind es fünf Euro mehr Lohn? Sind es bessere Freizeitangebote?
Ist es die Infrastruktur? Also das müsste eigentlich, und das kann man ja auf
einer regionalen Ebene eigentlich noch ziemlich gut abfragen.
Klar, Spielräume gibt es immer. Man muss den Leuten ehrlich sagen,
wo enden die? Was ist hier unrealistisch?
Und das Angebot, was die AfD macht, wir kämpfen gegen den Heizungshammer.
Wenn ihr den Sesselmann ins Amt wählt, müsst ihr keine Heizung austauschen.
Also wenn das das Angebot ist, dann ist sozusagen Ende Gelände.
Besonders gefährlich finde ich das hier, die sind zu einer Spielzeugverkäuferin
gegangen und haben sich von ihr noch mal eine Meinung abgeholt.
Plüschtiere haben Tradition in Sonneberg. Der Ort in Südthüringen gilt auch
als Weltspielzeugstadt.
Für Sina Martin ein Teil der lokalen Identität. In 5.
Generation betreibt sie ein Geschäft für Teddybären. Das ausgerechnet ihr Landkreis
der erste unter AfD-Führung ist, habe sie schockiert, sagt sie.
Sie hatte gehofft, das würde nicht passieren.
Wir müssen weitermachen, wir müssen gucken, wie wir mit der Situation zurechtkommen
und wir müssen sehen, dass wir unsere Image, unsere Wirkung nach außen einfach
zeigen, was wir wirklich sind, dass wir eine Spielzeugstadt sind,
dass wir liebe Menschen sind und dass uns das alles ans Herz geht.
Kuscheln mit der AfD oder was soll das sein?
Das ist Hypernormalisierung. Also wenn jetzt, ich meine, Politiker lügen, okay, abgehakt.
Aber wenn jetzt die Bevölkerung kommt und sagt, naja, wir haben zwar Nazis gewählt,
von denen wir wissen, gerichtsfest, faschistisch und rechtsextrem.
Aber eigentlich sind wir doch ganz lieb.
Dann macht die Bevölkerung genau dasselbe, was die Politik macht.
Also das ist nur noch verlogen.
Das ist völlig Banane. Gut, wir wollen trotzdem eine kleine konstruktive Wende. Zwei Clips dazu.
Zum einen eine Einschätzung von Aileen O'Sullivan, die ist eine U30-Politikerin
und ist über das Volt-Ticket hier stattgetreten geworden in Frankfurt.
Hat kürzlich auch so ein paar demografische Zahlen vorgestellt,
also sie ist so für Digitalisierung und Bevölkerungszahlen und so ein Kram zuständig
und macht so eine ganz ad hocke Instagram Story Einschätzung.
Politische Parteien sind ja dafür da, dass dort der politische Diskurs in die
Auseinandersetzung stattfindet und dass sich dann für bestimmte Interessen und
Belange eingesetzt wird.
Aber was wir faktisch in Deutschland haben, ist ein Parteiensystem,
in dem Leute in Parteien beitreten und in der Regel erstmal sich beweisen müssen,
ewig lange, bis sie irgendwas mitbestimmen können.
Und ganz lange bleiben die gleichen Personen immer in den gleichen Funktionen,
in den gleichen Gremien.
Und das ist unglaublich zäh und so hat man auch nicht das Gefühl,
dass man wirklich in einer lebendigen Demokratie lebt.
Wenn dort, wo die Entscheidungen getroffen werden, wo der Wahlkampf stattfindet,
da streiten um die besten Forderungen.
Wenn man da nicht reinkommt und da nicht zugelassen wird, dann lässt man es halt.
Ich glaube, dass das auch vielleicht eine Folge ist dieser Strukturen.
Und ob das jemand zum AfD-Wähler macht, das weiß ich nicht. Aber ich glaube,
es hilft auf jeden Fall nicht, dass sich Menschen so fühlen,
als ob sie sich einbringen können und sollten.
Obwohl wir es jetzt gerade am allermeisten machen müssten.
So, also ausbleibende Selbstwirksamkeit als größter Treiber für AfD-Sympathisantentum.
Ja, das würde ich mal gerade noch mal herausarbeiten wollen.
Nämlich, ich hatte ja erzählt von dem Freund aus Berlin, den ich jetzt auch
trafe, als ich dort war, der zumindest lohnarbeitet.
Da muss ich sagen, der studiert, der hat von zu Hause aus kein Geld,
muss also sehen, wie er in Berlin, in dieser teuren Stadt, über die Runden kommt
und ist jetzt dort 30 Stunden im Callcenter in die Woche. Das heißt,
für das Studium ist wenig Zeit.
Welche Selbstwirksamkeit ist denn noch gegeben?
Also kann man jetzt, man kann natürlich noch individuell versuchen,
es für sich, sich besser einzurichten.
Also man kann gucken, findet man einen Job, wo es mehr gibt.
Das wäre eine Möglichkeit, ja.
Aber grundsätzlich sind die Jobs ja da und die werden dann halt von jemand anderem
gemacht und wo soll da ein demokratisches Empfinden da sein?
Also ich kann ja nicht sagen, ja Mensch, verdienst nur Mindestlohn,
aber freu dich doch, alle vier Jahre dürfen wir wählen.
Also so. Und dann wählst du halt jemand anderes, der dafür sorgt,
dass dein Mindestlohn bei 12 Euro ist.
Also es beginnt ja in den Institutionen, durch die alle mal durch müssen,
Schule zum Beispiel. Ja.
Hat man eine Schülervertretung, die tatsächlich in gewissen Teilen Hoheit übers
Budget hat oder nicht? Das haben wir in kaum einer Schule.
Die werden allenfalls noch mal konsultiert oder informiert und dürfen dann mal so dabei sitzen.
Aber dass Eltern und Schüler einfach pauschal über 20 Prozent des Budgets,
was dann eben auch freigeräumt wird für und so weiter, was dann nicht,
ja dann müssen wir noch die Ersatzlehrer bezahlen und so, da beginnt es ja.
Dann diese Frage, wenn man, keine Ahnung, Vereinssport und so weiter da irgendwie
macht, rutscht man dann irgendwann mal in so eine, ja ich mache auch mal eine
Übungsleiterstunde oder helfe mal mit beim Sommerfest organisieren oder so.
Oder so. Man braucht ja gar nicht diese große politische Teilhabe.
Aber wenn man erwachsen wird, sollte man so ein Gefühl dafür haben,
also wenn ich jetzt hier was ändern will, wenn ich einfach nur einen Zebrastreifen
vor meiner Haustür haben will oder so, dann muss ich ein Gefühl dafür haben,
wie lang der Weg ist und auch gegen wen ich so was durchsetzen muss.
Beispielsweise nicht gegen irgendwen in der Politik, sondern gegen die Nachbarn,
die da eben nicht immer anhalten wollen, nur weil ein Kind am Straßenrand steht und so.
Und dieses Gefühl wird halt überhaupt nicht mehr ausgeprägt.
Dass das das auch irgendwann in der Politik münden kann. Ja,
aber da würde ich sagen, wir sind ja eine arbeitsteilige Gesellschaft.
Umso mehr man versteht, was in der Politik los ist, auch wenn man nicht selbst
Politiker wird, umso leichter ist es ja, Zufriedenheit herzustellen mit dem,
was da passiert, weil man einfach sozusagen den Handlungskorridor kennt.
Ich verstehe, was du meinst, aber das ist ja vom Status ausgesprochen,
dass man einigermaßen gut leben kann ökonomisch und dann kann man sich umschauen,
was wäre zu tun und dann darf man nicht in dieser Lieferservice Attitüde einfach
nur irgendwo anrufen und dann wird es gebracht, sondern man muss es dann selbst machen.
Aber wir haben ja einen ganz, ganz großen Teil von der Bevölkerung, der...
Überhaupt gar nicht in diesem Status, dass ich überlege, ob wir einen C4-Streifen
brauchen, sondern eher die Frage stellt sich, naja, also wenn ich jetzt die
Wohnung gekündigt bekommen, dann muss ich eine neue suchen, dann bekomme ich
einen neuen Mietvertrag, dann kostet das 400 Euro mehr im Monat.
Also die kümmern, können sich ja nicht mehr oder wollen sich auch nicht mehr
darum kümmern, was passiert.
Oder die tun es vielleicht noch so ganz solidarisch, wo sie einander helfen
oder sind vielleicht in einer kleinen Organisation.
Aber ich glaube, dass die Selbstwirksamkeit, wenn der ein gewisser ökonomischer
Status nicht erreicht ist, einfach nicht gespürt werden kann.
Sondern höchstens noch im Freundeskreis, im Familienumfeld, da ist es möglich.
Aber darüber hinaus dann nicht mehr. Und dann geht man ja auch nicht mehr in
irgendein Gremium oder engagiert sich sonst wo.
Und das ist ein Problem, das glaube ich nur klassenkämpferisch lösbar ist.
Also anders ist es ja gar nicht denkbar.
Ja und selbst der Klassenkampf fällt dann aus. Gestern habe ich wieder so eine
Insta-Story gesehen, wie 100 Leute für eine Wohnung anstehen,
weil in Berlin 70 Quadratmeter mal für unter 1000 Euro vermietet werden.
Und am selben Tag kommt diese Pressekonferenz,
Deutschland Medien ist es, glaube ich, die jetzt nochmal zum Thema,
wie gehen wir jetzt denn um mit diesem, und dann der Weg noch mal,
wie er sagt, also ich halte da gar nichts von, dass wir die jetzt enteignen
und so, also wo es einfach nicht passt.
Und das ist aber so kompliziert, dass für alle Beteiligten, inklusive auch der
Medien und so weiter, die das vermitteln müssen, ist, das ist die größte Baustelle, die wir haben.
Wir hören mal kurz den Oliver Decker, der gestern da seine Auto-Dingsda-Bums,
also das zum politischen Denken in Ostdeutschland insbesondere Ergebnisse vorstellte.
Wer ist das? so ein Uni-Professor, der sich da beworben hat,
diese Studie zu verantworten.
Und was uns zu denken geben muss, ist, dass der Anteil derjenigen,
die mit dem Funktionieren der Alltagserfahrung von Demokratie zufrieden sind, denkbar gering ist.
Zwar über 50 Prozent, aber 40 Prozent sind tatsächlich nicht zufrieden mit der
Art und Weise, wie Demokratie funktioniert.
Und das findet ein entsprechendes Abbild in den Fragen, dann wiederum nach Vorstellungen
und Wünschen, nach Autoritärem.
Wir haben hier ein Konzept, das im Grunde genommen erstmal inhaltlich nicht bestimmt ist.
Das können linke Wünsche sein, also sozusagen mit Vorstellungen verbunden sein,
die auch auf andere Ziele gehen.
Das ist nicht ausdrücklich Rechtsextremismus, das muss man immer dazu sagen.
Das sind Aussagen wie zum Beispiel, wir sollten dankbar sein für führende Köpfe,
die uns sagen, was wir zu tun haben.
So, das ist also noch nicht festgelegt auf rechts oder links oder wie auch immer,
sondern nur um, Ich brauche irgendeine Orientierung und am besten halte ich
mich einfach an irgendjemandem, dem ich folge.
Und wenn immer ein Oppositionspolitiker kommt und sagt, die sind mit der Regierung
unzufrieden, dann muss man sagen, nee, die sind mit der Demokratie unzufrieden.
Da gehörst du mit dazu. Und wenn dann Journalisten sagen, die Leute sind mit
der Politik unzufrieden, dann muss man sagen, nein, die sind nicht mit der Politik
unzufrieden, die sind mit der Demokratie unzufrieden.
Und dazu gehörst du als Journalist dazu.
Gerade wenn du Bundesjournalismus da in Berlin machst und so weiter.
Also es geht, wenn immer die Regierung und die Ampel und so weiter kritisiert
wird, geht es um die Demokratie an sich, mit der man unzufrieden ist.
Und da sind alle inkludiert, die Regierung, die Opposition und der Journalismus.
Das ist die Lehre aus Sendeberg.
Wir springen, wo wir schon davon reden, dass es keine Opposition mehr gibt,
zum evangelischen Kirchentag.
Denn ich dachte mir jetzt genau ein Jahr, nachdem ich aus der Kirche ausgetreten bin,
sehe ich mir diese Veranstaltung, also zumindest das, was angeboten wird bei
YouTube, einmal an, viele, viele Interviews mit den üblichen Verdächtigen,
Eckart von Hirschhausen, alle möglichen Politiker waren da.
Eckart von Hirschhausen?
Ja, ja, jeder. Ich dachte, der macht Essen und Klima. Also ich glaube,
wir waren die einzigen beiden, die nicht eingeladen waren zum evangelischen Kirchentag.
Vielleicht kommen wir nächstes Jahr, aber ich will hier schon ausdrücklich sagen,
nur gegen ein sehr hohes Schmerzensgeld.
Dieses Jahr gehen wir zur Gamescon. Ich habe schon geguckt wann sie ist.
Dieses Jahr?
Die ist in der dritten Augustwoche.
Okay. Ja. Verspricht lustiger zu werden als der Kirchentag.
Es ist im Grunde so eine Art Kirchentag.
Ja, es ist bestimmt viel Spiritualität dort im Raum.
Jedenfalls war ich doch sehr verblüfft. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man es spielen
darf, aber ich spiele es dir jetzt vor. Sonst müssen die Leute das bei YouTube
suchen. Es gibt einen Kirchentags-Song, denn das Motto des Kirchentags ist, jetzt ist die Zeit.
Die Zeit ist jetzt so rum. Nun, ich füge hinzu, wir haben ja auch mal Bach hervorgebracht.
Ja, das stimmt. Ja, ist aber alles jetzt ein bisschen anders.
Die Zeit ist jetzt, man kann es, ist es ja drauf in der Live-Fassung vom Salon.
Das müssen wir jetzt gerade sagen für alle, die nicht in Frankfurt saßen.
Man kann es aber dann nachhören als Podcast. Und zwar haben wir unserem Publikum eine Minute geschenkt.
Und zwar war es so, dass beim Kirchentag während des Eröffnungsgottesdienstes
plötzlich die Pastorin sagte, dass nun ein besonderes Geschenk kommt,
dass jetzt alle eine Minute geschenkt bekommen.
Dann kann man eine Minute machen, was man will, kann sich umarmen,
was auch immer. Und das wurde dann auch da praktiziert und wir haben das dann
gleich, weil wir es für eine so tolle Idee hielten, übernommen.
Und danach, nach der Veranstaltung, sagte mir dann ein junger Mann,
der zu Gast war, dass dies die Idee des Kirchentagspräsidenten de Maizière gewesen ist.
Denn jeder Kirchentagspräsident kann sich etwas ausdenken, irgendwas Besonderes
machen. Und de Maizière hat sich diese Minute ausgedacht, weil sie nichts kostet.
Toll, oder? Also Austeritätspolitik, wohin man auch schaut. Nun,
dieser Kirchentagspräsident ist aufgefallen damit, dass er sagte,
Mensch, dann gebe ich doch schon mal Interviews im Vorfeld, wo es so hapert.
Und es ergibt sich dann, dass bei einer Veranstaltung,
bei der tausende junge Menschen ehrenamtlich nach Nürnberg reisen,
um zu helfen, sie sich eigentlich seine Standpauke anhören müssen von Misea
und generell die ganze junge Generation, dass eigentlich alle viel zu faul sind.
Bei Phönix hat er dann nochmal Stellung dazu genommen.
Die Losung dieses Kirchentages lautet, jetzt ist die Zeit. Wofür ist jetzt die Zeit aus ihrer Sicht?
Manche sagen, diese Losung ist banal.
Als Familieneltern wissen wir, dass wir den Kindern sagen, jetzt ist die Zeit,
ins Bett zu gehen. Ja, das ist jeden Abend.
Aber wir glauben schon, dass mit dieser Losung jetzt ist die Zeit.
Wir Hinweis darauf geben wollen, dass es besondere Zeiten sind.
Die Bündelung von Krisen, die Ungewissheiten, die damit verbunden sind,
auch eine Verunsicherung der Bevölkerung.
Und das zu analysieren und daraus Hoffnung zu schöpfen, wie wir es eben gesagt
haben. Und zwar nicht einfach nur durch Beten und Singen, so schön das ist,
sondern durch Hoffen und Machen.
Ja, dann würde ich sagen, jetzt ist die Zeit, dass die Generation abtritt,
die uns das alles eingebrockt hat.
Nein, demnächst sieht das so nicht.
Ich habe ein Interview mit Ihnen gelesen, wo Sie sagen, Sie ärgern sich über
die Anspruchshaltung der jungen Generation, insbesondere der Generation Z.
Und Ihnen wäre die teilweise zu egoistisch. Wie ist Ihr Blick auf die jungen
Menschen? Hier sind ganz viele junge Menschen, 4.000,
Ehrenamtliche, die sich großartig engagieren. Die meine ich natürlich nicht.
Ich meine aber diejenigen, die aus dem demografischen Vorteil glauben,
zu viel Vorteil schlagen zu wollen.
Und das geht, glaube ich, nicht.
Habe ich da dein Buch falsch verstanden? Aber ich dachte immer,
wir hätten jetzt so einen demografischen Nachteil. Welcher Vorteil ist es jetzt,
dass es zu viele Alte gibt und zu wenig Junge?
Das ist der Vorteil der Generation Z.
Also vielleicht muss ich mich doch nochmal, ich hab ja ein Sachbuch geschrieben,
vielleicht muss ich nochmal ein aktivistisches Buch hinterher schieben.
Der demografische Vorteil weniger zu sein.
Es ist doch unglaublich.
Ich finde keine Worte dafür. Das ist ja unglaublich.
Und in diesem Interview sagte er dann, dass er, auf das die Phönix-Journalistin
sich hier bezog, sagte er, dass wir arbeiten müssen.
Und das gehört ja auch zum christlichen Leben. Und Gott schuf die Welt.
Und er hat uns ja nur den Sonntag freigegeben.
Und deswegen können wir auch jetzt nicht anfangen mit einer Vier-Tage-Woche.
Also der demografische Vorteil, ne? Vielleicht sollten wir ja doch mal kurz spontan einfach...
Wir haben ja auch verschiedene Arbeitgeberpräsidenten und so weiter,
wir können dann nachher nochmal Clips zuspielen, die dann sowas sagen,
sagen wie, ja vielleicht wäre es auch ganz gut, wenn alle nochmal zwei Stunden
arbeiten, nur so vorübergehend.
Oder ja die 63, also Rente mit 63 hat uns zwei Millionen Arbeitnehmer gekostet und so.
Da ist ja so ein Bild drin, die Menschen als ökonomische Verfügungsmasse.
Das war so ganz frei raus. So. Die Politik sagt, ihr dürft alle frei haben,
dann fehlt uns sozusagen Kapitalverarbeitungskapazität.
Und wenn Thomas de Maizière sagt, der demografische Vorteil,
nämlich wenige zu sein, weil die jungen Leute sind uns ja eh ausgeliefert,
Aber jetzt müssen wir auch noch organisieren, wie wir die wenigen uns zunutze
machen und daraus ziehen die dann Vorteile.
Das ist ja wirklich eine totale Verdrehung.
Also der demografische Vorteil ist vielleicht bei ihm so gesehen,
dass wir aufgrund der demografischen Entwicklung auf keinen Fall eine hohe Arbeitslosigkeit bekommen.
Junge Leute wissen das und versuchen deshalb mehr für sich zu bekommen,
rauszuhandeln, wenn das auch ja gar nicht Realität momentan ist.
Also die Löhne steigen ja gar nicht entsprechend dieser Lage, die wir vorfinden.
Aber da steckt ja im Prinzip schon so eine Art Generationskampf drinnen,
bei dem die jetzt einen Vorteil haben auf dem Schlachtfeld.
Eine Generation ist natürlich im Recht, die haben ja dieses Land aufgebaut.
Das ist wirklich verrückt.
Und jetzt wird es noch verrückter, denn diesen Klassenunterschied,
der ist mir auch so nicht bewusst gewesen.
Aber noch wichtiger als die Generationsfrage ist mir ein anderer Punkt,
nämlich der Widerspruch zwischen denen, die Homeoffice machen können,
weil die Arbeitsbedingungen das erlauben und Denjenigen, die das nicht können.
Polizisten, Busfahrer, Krankenschwestern, Ärzte, Bäcker, Müllentsorgung,
die können das alles nicht.
Und die Anspruchshaltung, andere müssen arbeiten, damit wir Homeoffice machen
können. Wahrscheinlich in allen Generationen. Die wollte ich einmal thematisieren.
Wenn man kein Homeoffice macht und stattdessen ins Büro geht,
muss dann der Müllmann weniger arbeiten? Ich glaube nein.
Ich glaube auch nicht. Ich weiß auch nicht genau, was er uns hier sagen will.
Ja, ein Dienstleistungssektor, der auf den Menschen zum Beispiel sehr stark
ausgerichtet ist oder so, oder ein Handwerksbetrieb ist mit Homeoffice nicht
gut bedient, aber es macht für den Handwerksbetrieb keinen Unterschied,
ob jemand im Homeoffice ist oder nicht.
Also ich bin ja letztens mal, habe ich kurz schon mal angemerkt,
aus Versehen erste Klasse gefahren, ohne Zuschuss zu bezahlen.
Ich habe 3,90 Euro unterschlagen.
Ich hatte ja nur ein 40-Euro-Ticket, um Regionalbahn zu fahren,
aber wir kennen ja alle die Regionalbahn, erste Klasse und so weiter,
das ist ja so ein bisschen ab, also genau wie die zweite Klasse,
nur eine Tür dazwischen.
Und da ist ja auch, man muss halt so eine Prozedur ablaufen irgendwie,
so im Sinne von, naja, du kriegst es gerne wieder, geh zu deinen Reihenmeinverkehrsbetrieben,
also gehe ich da hin und sage, nee, das ist ja Deutsche Bahn,
also gehe ich zur Deutschen Bahn und sage, ja, da haben wir eine extra Stelle,
die ist hier, Gutleutstraße, musst du um die Ecke gehen und so weiter.
Und dann bist du schon eine Stunde unterwegs.
Also ich muss da 60 Euro zahlen und habe aber eigentlich, was jetzt mein,
ich bin ja freiberuflich, also es ist ja Stundenlohn im Grunde,
sind ja Opportunitätskosten so. Also ich habe eigentlich meine 60 Euro schon
abgeleistet außerhalb meines Homeoffice für diesen Fall, muss dann trotzdem
nochmal 60 Euro extra zahlen und so weiter.
Und dann, nachdem man das alles absolviert, also dann beim dritten Mal Schlangestehen
endlich am richtigen Schalter steht, kommt er ja und sagt,
Nee, wenn ich Ihnen das jetzt erlasse, wäre das ja total unfair für alle anderen,
die kontrolliert wurden und auch falsch gefahren sind.
Da waren bestimmt viele dabei, die ohne Ticket sich eine Fahrleistung erschlichen
haben, aber ich hatte ja ein Ticket, ich saß nur einen Meter zu weit falsch und so.
Und da meinte er, nee, das wäre unfair. Das wäre unfair, wenn er mir jetzt einfach
nur sagt, sieben Euro Überarbeitungsgebühr plus, Sie haben ja genug hin und her und so.
60 Euro Strafe zahlen dafür.
Ich kann mich da nicht rausreden. Und sein Argument war, das ist ja sonst unfair.
Wo ich sage, das bekommt gar niemand mit.
Hier stehen nicht die anderen. Wir sind hier ganz alleine gerade.
Niemand sucht diese Dings hier auf, sondern alle bekommen Post und überweisen
60 Euro und ich versuche mich hier noch nicht rauszureden.
Aber der große andere bekommt es mit.
Genau, also da hat er so ein Unfairheitsargument gemacht, das ich total dumm
fand, weil es total dämlich ist. Und jetzt höre ich ja plötzlich vom Kirchentagspräsidenten dasselbe.
Nee, du darfst in deinem Homeoffice sein, du musst durch die Stadt pendeln,
du musst deine Mittagspause irgendwo außerhalb deines Zuhauses,
auch wenn du es nicht willst, weil das wäre unfair denen gegenüber,
die halt nun mal für ihre Arbeit auf die Straße gehen müssen.
Allen soll es ein bisschen schlecht gehen.
Genau, allen soll es ein bisschen schlecht gehen. Sie können sich hier nicht
rausreden, bezahlen Sie 60 Euro, pendeln Sie durch die Stadt.
Eigentlich müsste man das noch ein bisschen ausführen, aber dann verstopfe ich
ja die Pendelwege für diejenigen, die zur Arbeit müssen. Ich muss ja gar nicht.
Und da sind doch schon die Klimakleber, die das machen.
Also diese Art von Gerechtigkeitsbild und Generationenkampf,
die der Monsieur uns hier offenbart, ist wirklich… Ich weiß sowieso nicht,
warum muss ein Kirchentag von einem Politiker geleitet werden?
Und das hat sich halt durch diese ganzen Beiträge, die ich mir da angesehen
habe, gezogen, dass man eigentlich die Ampelkoalition plus CDU für die ein Festival
ausrichtet und hin und wieder wird auch noch ein Lied gesungen.
Und das war schon immer das, was mich eigentlich an der evangelischen Kirche
gestört hat, diese merkwürdige Nähe, die da immer aufgebaut wird.
Und naja, deswegen müssen natürlich auch die Reden, die Predigten,
Entschuldigung, politisch ausfallen.
Wir hören jetzt Bedford Strom.
Und in der Ukraine, wo Russland seit jetzt fast seit weit über einem Jahr einen
illegalen und unmoralischen Angriffskrieg führt.
Und es steht schon jetzt fest, dass alle verlieren werden.
Der schreckliche Dammbruch hat es jetzt noch mal allen vor Augen geführt.
Ja, man könnte wirklich denken, dass die Welt den Bach runtergeht.
Wenn dann nicht der wäre, der die Welt geschaffen hat.
Mhm.
Wenn da nicht diese Geistkraft wäre.
Die die Welt immer wieder aufrichtet, immer wieder ihr neues Leben einhaucht.
Äh ...
Richte sich das an.
Methodische Manöverkritik, als er so sagte. Und dann glaubt man ja,
die Welt geht dem Bach runter, wenn nur nicht, dass er, denke ich,
vor Vorstellung nicht die Dürre wäre.
Denn wer ... Also, das will ich jetzt mal sehen, ja? Wenn er den Leuten verspricht,
okay, alles geht dem Bach runter.
Aber er richtet uns ja immer wieder auf. So, wir haben jetzt mitbekommen,
die Meere sind irgendwie heißer als sonst und die nehmen auch das CO2 nicht
mehr auf und damit haben wir jetzt zusätzlich noch zu tun und so weiter.
Also alles geht in die falsche Richtung. Ich bin mal sehr gespannt,
wie wir in zehn Jahren Bilanz ziehen können, wie uns der Herrgott da aufgerichtet hat.
Ja gut, das ist natürlich die Glaubenskomponente, die da sein muss beim Kirchendorf.
Wir haben hier den EKD-Chef, der interessanterweise sagt und wir sehen, dass da alle verlieren.
Und zugleich ist er aber derjenige, der ganz klar auf diesem grünen Waffendeskurs
ist und auch keine Meinung nebenher gelten lässt. Also ich habe diese,
ich habe es geklippt und habe es dann alles daheim gelassen.
Es gibt dann eine Auseinandersetzung mit so einem friedenspolitischen Sprecher
und es ist wirklich unter aller Kanone, wie Bedford-Strohm argumentiert.
Es ist also eigentlich, hätte er auch Strackzimmermann hinschicken können,
hätte gar nicht selbst kommen müssen.
Und da hat es sich nochmal für mich auch gezeigt, als ich das so gesehen habe.
Es war für mich die richtige Entscheidung. Nachdem ich jetzt diese Sachen gesehen
habe, würde ich sagen, schade, dass man nicht noch ein zweites Mal austreten kann.
Und das richtet sich nicht gegen die Basis, wo sicherlich einiges Gutes passiert.
Aber diese ganze EKD-Spitze und diese ganze Leute, die sowas da organisieren,
ist es wirklich grauenhaft.
Dann natürlich der Bundespräsident darf dabei nicht fehlen.
Wir alle wollen ein Ende des Schreckens, wir wollen ein Ende des Krieges, wir wollen Frieden.
Aber es muss doch, liebe Schwestern und Brüder, ein gerechter Friede sein.
Und klar ist doch, wenn Russland seine Soldaten zurückzieht,
dann ist der Krieg zu Ende.
Wenn die Ukraine ihre Verteidigung einstellt, dann ist das das Ende der Ukraine,
liebe Schwestern und Brüder.
Ein paar Zwischentöne hört man ja, dass manche Leute damit nicht einverstanden sind.
Diese Opposition, die er hier auftut, ist natürlich vollkommener Schwachsinn.
Es geht ja niemandem, der ernsthaft für Verhandlungen plädiert,
auch gerade nicht den Friedenspolitikern oder Friedenstheologen in der Kirche
darum, zu sagen, die sollen einfach mal die Kämpfe einstellen und dann kann
sich Russland holen, was es will.
Sondern es geht natürlich darum, dass man an einen Verhandlungstisch kommt und
dann wird man Kompromisse machen müssen.
Und dann hat Bertford Strom, ohne dass das Weißrecht in der Weise,
dass dann es zwei Verlierer geben wird.
Die Frage ist, bei wem ist der Verlust größer? Aber zu tun, als sei das die
Frage gerechter Friede. Und dann glaubt man jetzt, man wird Putin noch besiegen
können. Das ist einfach ...
Wenn man das im März 2022 gesagt hätte, okay.
Aber wenn man das jetzt im Juni 2023 sagt, finde ich es schon wahnsinnig absurd.
Und auch ein ganz unehrliches Sprechen. Also jeder, der so halbwegs bei Verstand
ist, wird merken, dass hier nicht klar argumentiert wird.
Die Gegenseite, die ja dann noch vor Ort war, um so Diskussionen zu führen.
Oder es gab ja so Diskussionen.
Ja, es gab so ein paar, ja.
Ich meine, wir haben jetzt, Bachmuth liegt jetzt in Schutt und Asche.
Also alle sind geflüchtet und 90 Prozent der Gebäude sind zerstört.
Und das ja nur rückblickend, weil wir gesagt haben,
nee, wenn wir das nicht mit Waffen machen, Nee, wenn wir das nicht mit den Waffen machen,
haben wir keinen anderen Weg, weil der globale Süden ist uns ja verloren gegangen
und in China gibt es auch keine Einsicht und so weiter,
also weil wir auf politischer Ebene einmal so komplett versagt haben und diese Isolation Putins,
dass es ihn mehr kostet, Bachmuth zwar irgendwie besetzt zu halten,
was auch immer wie die Verlautbarung dann ist, also die Gräte unterschreiben,
Bachmuth gehört jetzt mir oder so.
Ich setze den obersten Beamten da ein, weil die Zerstörung Bachmuths billiger
ist als alle anderen politischen Folgekosten, die man auf diplomatischen Parketten und so weiter.
Diese Einsicht, finde ich, die sollte ja so langsam mal ...
Spruchfähig werden, um auch vorzubeugen, wie man das demnächst macht.
Also um zum Beispiel den Preis für Taiwan so hoch zu halten,
dass es niemals da zu einem Waffengang kommt. Und noch ist ja der Preis entsprechend
hoch, aber man muss halt ein bisschen was dafür machen.
Und diese Diskussion, die fehlt mir irgendwie überall. Ich habe sie noch nirgendwo
gesehen, aber ich nehme an, der Kirchentag ist auch keine Adresse dafür.
Und noch einmal Steinmeier beim Eröffnungsgottesdienst.
Auch ich hätte mir nicht vorstellen können, dass ich einmal sagen würde,
neben all den anderen Anstrengungen, es ist auch Zeit für Waffen.
Ist das so eine Unfehlbarkeitsdoktrin?
Auch ich hätte mir nicht vorstellen können, aber jetzt, wo ich es trotz meiner
Unvorstellbarkeit so sehen muss, müsst ihr es auch so sehen?
Ja, auf ganz geschickte Weise. Es ist ja im Protestantismus nicht so,
dass es unfehlbare Äußerungen gibt.
Eigentlich nicht.
Und deswegen kommt man natürlich jetzt mit der großen Läuterung oder man hat
es gesehen, man hat es mit eigenen Augen gesehen.
Das war dann auch bei Bertford Strohm immer diese Argumentation,
ich war in der Ukraine und habe gesehen.
Ja, ich habe auch ein Vorstellungsvermögen, dass ich weiß, wie grauenhaft Krieg
ist und ich muss jetzt nicht nochmal irgendwo durchgelotst werden von drei Kamerateams,
um zu sehen, ach tatsächlich, hier ist ja alles zu Bruch gegangen und da liegen tote Menschen.
Aber das ist also keine aufrechte Argumentation, die da mal stattfindet.
Es ging aber auch um Thema Klimawandel, auch wieder Generationen,
nochmal Bedford-Strumm.
Mein Enkel Amos ist jetzt vier Jahre alt und ich bin 63.
Im Jahr 2082 wird mein Enkel Amos so alt sein, wie ich jetzt.
Und ich werde dafür kämpfen.
Dass er ein mindestens genauso gutes Leben hat, wie ich es jetzt habe. Und bitte ...
Und bitte kämpft alle mit. Ihr Mütter und Väter, ihr Großmütter und Großväter,
alle, die ihr für Kinder sorgt, kämpft mit für unsere Kinder.
Sie sollen leben. Sie sollen gut leben,
sie sollen reine Luft atmen, sie sollen klares Wasser trinken,
sie sollen sich an Schmetterlingen freuen und sie sollen immer wieder Sonne
und dann auch Regen genießen können.
Und dann hat er bestimmt über die Zertrümmerung des Renatonierungsgesetzes von
Franz Timmermans gesprochen, der ja damals auch im deutschen Fernsehen in deutscher
Sprache sagte, wir versuchen hier den Bürgerkrieg zu vermeiden.
Den Bürgerkrieg um Wasser, ja, nee, das kam da nicht, es ging so weiter.
Wir werden, so soll es sein, wir werden unser Glück nicht mehr am Wachstum des
materiellen Wohlstands festmachen, sondern am Wachstum des Beziehungswohlstandes.
Was soll das jetzt dann, Beziehungswohlstand, wenn man eine Freundin hat?
Seid zufrieden, du hast eine Freundin.
Ja, nicht mehr Geld, Mindestlohn ist ja, also kann ich eigentlich auch den Mindestlohnempfängern
jetzt schon mal zurufen, richtet euch nicht allzu sehr am materialen Wohlstand
aus, Beziehungswohlstand, darauf kommen wir an.
Alle Strecke reisen ist die Beziehung zu Gott.
Ja. Applaus Großer Applaus. Wir werden unsere Freiheit nicht mehr daran beurteilen,
wie hoch der Tachometer gehen darf, sondern danach, ob wir uns schöpfungsverträglich fortbewegen.
Applaus Das war jetzt gegen die FDP gerichtet, wir haben das gemerkt.
Wir werden Gerechtigkeit nicht mehr daran messen, ob das Gehalt der vermeintlichen
Leistungsträger hoch genug ist, sondern daran, ob alle Menschen,
auch die Schwächsten, in Würde leben können.
Nicht in Würde, die sollen auch einen materiellen Wohlstand genießen.
Die Würde, das kommt dann danach. Also das kommt da schon mit.
Man kann nicht sagen, du bist arm, aber hier, ich geb dir ein bisschen Würde aus der Kollekte.
Aber ist doch eigentlich gut heutzutage, dass du, wenn du so eine Predigt schreibst,
dadurch, dass der ja immer so Orakelmäßig sein muss, GPT einfach kurz sagst,
was du haben willst und dann sagst wirklich viel fabulieren.
Ich habe es tatsächlich ausprobiert. Ich habe es tatsächlich ausprobiert und
habe verschiedene Themen, die hier so aufgeworfen sind, mal einfach bei Chat-GPT
angeguckt. Und dann konnte ich sagen, ich habe jetzt viel gelästert über Chat-GPT,
was alles nicht funktioniert. Dafür super. Das hat spitze funktioniert.
Für sowas ist super. Für Steinmeier und Bedford Strom reden,
das ist einfach perfekt.
Aber Chachabiti kommt nicht auf solch tolle Ideen und ich habe schon gesagt,
ich habe immer auch das Problem gehabt bei manchen protestantischen Gottesdiensten,
dass es so ein Fremdschelme-Element gibt, dass man glaubt, wir müssen jetzt
mal so noch ein bisschen was Verrücktes, was Unkonventionelles machen.
Und das hat man auch hier getan. Man war in Nürnberg, hat sich gedacht,
man könnte irgendwie noch vielleicht eine Gauklerin auf die Bühne stellen,
die ein bisschen tanzt, ein bisschen neckisch ist und so dann auch während dieser
Ansprache von Bedford-Strohm.
Und jetzt ist die Zeit.
Oder, Gauklerin, die Zeit ist noch nicht um, hast du gesagt.
Kehrt um, kehrt um, kehrt um, hast du gesagt. Ja, ich glaube,
das große Problem ist, dass wir ja gar nicht genau wissen, wohin.
Das ist ja die Frage. Ja, was die konkreten Lösungen angeht,
wissen wir nicht. Geht's dahin, geht's dahin oder geht's dahin?
Aber deswegen sind wir ja zusammen.
Deswegen ist ja jetzt Kirchentag. Deswegen wollen wir genau darüber diskutieren,
wohin es gehen soll. Jetzt ist genau dazu die Zeit.
Aber so kann man auch eine Polonaise mit Andi Borg ankündigen.
Vor allem wie er sie in die Rede einladen wollte und sie traute sich aber nicht
und dann waren sie erkennbar nicht.
Es sind ganz gruselige Momente und wir verstärken das jetzt noch.
Abschluss Gottesdienst. Wir springen jetzt tolle Tage erlebt.
Und jetzt muss ich erst so einen kleinen Disclaimer machen. Also diese Predigt
wurde natürlich ausgesetzt einem Kulturkampf von rechts.
Das werden wir jetzt hier nicht noch einmal aufführen. Dieser Kulturkampf von
rechts sah natürlich aus.
Hier sieht man den Woken Wahnsinn. Also wir haben jetzt hier den aus Südafrika
stammenden Pfarrer, der in, ich glaube, irgendwo im Norden tätig ist und jetzt so eine Rede hält.
Wir wollen uns aber mal auf das Inhaltliche und vielleicht auch ein bisschen
auf die Form konzentrieren, aber nicht in dieser Rezeptionsweise,
die wir schon kennengelernt haben.
Ich und Menschen wie ich, wie mich, wir kennen die Grenzen und die Schwächen
des Satzes. Liebe, deine Nächsten.
Deshalb tanze ich lieber zu Tina Sternes, What's love got to do,
got to do with it? Denn was hat denn der Liebe überhaupt damit zu tun?
Ohne Gerechtigkeit gibt es keine Liebe. There can be no love without justice.
Alles hat seine Zeit.
And all you need is love. Er erinnert mich an einen Happyland Zustand.
Happyland, das ist ein Wort von Topoca Oguete. Und damit beschreibt sie,
wie sich Menschen fühlen, die keine Diskriminierungen erfahren und auch nicht
sehen, dass andere sie erfahren.
Gut, da hätte Chachibiti auch nochmal ein bisschen Struktur reinbringen können.
Also worauf es wohl hinauslaufen soll ist, Gerechtigkeit und Liebe müssen zusammen gedacht werden,
ist die Voraussetzung für Liebe und nun gibt es aber Diskriminierte,
die von diesem Happyland oder von denen, die sich im Happyland wähnen,
ausgeschlossen sind. Wir hören mal weiter.
Und trotzdem meine Geschwister und mich diskriminiert wegen Einkommen,
Hautfarbe, Behinderung, queere Identität, dann sagen wir Mutti Lichi.
Meine Geschwister und ich, wir sind Kirche.
Wir sind kein Gegenüber und wir brauchen keine Nächstenliebe und zur Wendung von oben herab.
Wir sind Kirche. Und meine Geschwister und ich, wir sagen, jetzt ist die Zeit.
Wir vertrauen eurer Liebe nicht. Wir haben keinen sicheren Ort in euren Kirchen.
Also es geht wohl darum, dass es Diskriminierung innerhalb der Kirche gibt.
Aber ich finde, es ist so unklar alles artikuliert. Was er nicht unartikuliert,
sondern unklar strukturiert, was er eigentlich da sagen möchte.
Geht es um strukturellen Rassismus innerhalb der evangelischen Kirche?
Dann müsste man das ja konkret machen können. Oder geht es allgemein um so was,
was wir mal empfinden sollen?
Was ich ein bisschen verräterisch finde, ist, wenn er sagt, die Diskriminierten
und zählt dann auf Menschen mit Behinderung genauso wie Menschen,
die kein Geld haben. Und da sind wir ja eigentlich so in diesem Ferder-Attermann-Diskurs.
Wir müssen jetzt auch mal alle diskriminierten Gruppen sehen,
dass wir gut mit denen umgehen. Nein, also ein Mensch mit Behinderung ist ein
Mensch mit Behinderung und mit dem muss entsprechend umgegangen werden,
also nicht diskriminiert.
Aber ein Mensch, der wenig Geld hat, dem muss man mehr Geld geben.
Also das ist nicht was Essentielles, dass man kein Geld hat.
Und dann wird das dann dieses eigenartige Finale.
Jetzt ist die Zeit zu sagen, wir sind alle die letzte Generation.
Jetzt ist die Zeit zu sagen, Black Lives Always Matter.
Jetzt ist die Zeit zu sagen, Gott ist queer.
Jetzt ist die Zeit zu sagen, we leave no one to die.
Und jetzt ist wieder die Zeit zu sagen, wir schicken ein Schiff und noch viel mehr.
Wir empfangen Menschen an griechischen sicheren Häfen.
Safer spaces for all.
Also es sind alle Insta-Kacheln, glaube ich, die mir in den letzten Monaten
aufgefallen sind, vorgelesen worden. wurden und natürlich wurde sich von rechts
sehr darüber aufgeregt, dass gesagt wird, Gott ist queer.
Er hätte nicht sagen müssen, Göttin ist queer.
Und ich finde, auch hier sollte man mal, wenn man nicht rechts ist,
mal von einer vernünftigen linken oder linksliberalen Perspektive drauf blicken
und einfach sagen, dieser Satz ist unsinnig.
Dieser Satz ist unsinnig, weil Gott nicht ist.
Irgendwie mit einem menschlichen Geschlecht oder einer menschlichen Sexualform
identifiziert werden kann. Das ist einfach unsinnig.
Gott ist ja genau darüber hinaus.
Und deswegen könnte man diesen Satz noch retten, indem man gesagt hätte,
Gott ist nichts, aber er ist für alle auch da, für die Queeren genauso.
Das wäre die richtige Aussage, aber zu sagen Gott ist queer, was sagt das jetzt?
Also dann sind die Heterosexuellen im Nachteil gegenüber Gott oder wie äußert
sich das Queersein Gottes?
Das heißt, das ist dann wirklich nur dieses, ja, ich mache jetzt mal alles.
Also ich habe mir diese Predigte angesehen und gerade dieses Finale und habe
gedacht, gut, eigentlich muss man schon von der Verschwörungstheorie ausgehen.
Wenn ich jetzt einen Kulturkampf anzetteln wollte, dann würde ich jemanden so
installieren, den ich engagiere dafür, dass er mir so eine Rede hält.
Und dann sag auf jeden Fall, Gott ist queer. Dann haben wir so einen richtig
schönen Shitstorm produziert und da haben die Rechten wieder nochmal Zulauf.
Also ich finde einfach, das ist einfach Stuss.
Und ich weiß nicht, warum so was nicht von einer linken Seite kritisiert werden kann.
Nur weil irgendwie ein Julian Reichelt sich über Quintenzelser,
heißt ja der Pastor, aufregt, muss man jetzt aber nicht sagen,
nee, es war alles super, was da gesagt wurde, sondern man kann auch einfach
sagen, es ist ziemlicher Unsinn, es war auch eine sehr sehr dürftige Predigt
wie fast alles, was ich da gehört habe.
Ich meine diese Vereinnahmung von Gott finden wir ja eh eigentlich immer blöd.
Das sind ja eigentlich immer die Orthodoxen, die das dann so für sich in Anspruch nehmen.
Was wird hier eigentlich gesagt? Hier wird dann nochmal so, Gott ist das alles
und wir sind letzte Generation und es ist aber so.
Völlig beliebig ausgewählt, was jetzt gerade so zeitgeistig ist und was so in
so ein linksliberales Spektrum passt, das rufen wir noch mal auf.
Und dann habe ich kurz danach zufällig bei YouTube angezeigt bekommen,
ein Poetry-Slam, der in der Elbphilharmonie stattfand, kürzlich unter war,
Abdul Kader Shahin, der ja zusammen mit unserem Freund Philipp Kindler ein Podcast macht.
Dann habe ich mir gedacht, ach, die sechs Minuten Predigt höre ich mir jetzt auch noch an.
Und da geht es nämlich auch darum, dass man nicht zur Mehrheitsgesellschaft gehört in Deutschland.
Dass man diskriminiert wird, dass man in einem Haus wohnt, wo 200 Namen stehen
und die haben in der Regel keine deutschen Vor- und Nachnamen und all das.
Also das ist das Thema dieser Rede, dieses Slams von Abdul Qadir Shahin.
Wir hören uns jetzt mal den Schluss
an und fragen uns mal, ob nicht da der bessere Kirchentag stattfand.
Wünschen sich das Leute wie ich, auch wenn man das ist, in den Konzernvorständen
sitzen, in den Konzernvorständen, denen die Häuser mit den Klingelschildern
gehören. Sie wollen so lange und so intensiv ihre Privilegien checken,
bis alle wirklich alle die Chance bekommen haben, ausgebeutet zu werden.
Ein Problem, eine Lösung, sechs Minuten. Realitätsschaftssprache.
Ich stehe hier vor dem Haus, in dem sich ein Junkie die letzte Spritze in den
Arm rammt. Du findest, das ist Pathos. Ich finde, das ist Dienstag.
Ich stehe vor dem Schrank mit den Sachen von der Caritas. Ich stehe neben meiner
Mutter, der die Hände immer zittern, wenn sie mit der Ausländerbehörde telefonieren
muss. Ich stehe auf der Bühne und sage, Realitätsschaftssprache.
Ich will meine Geschichte nicht erzählen. Ich bin ein Name mit 200 Klingelschilder.
Mein Name tut überhaupt gar nichts zur Sache. Die Sache ist die,
sie tun so, als wäre Sprache die Lösung.
Als ging es darum, dass der scheiß Faschio-Opa mich gestern als Mlucken bezeichnet hat.
Der Fascho-Opa lebt in einem System, welches Rassismus produziert.
Denn für ein Haus mit 200 Klingelschildern braucht es eine Erklärung.
Und die Erklärung ist meistens, die haben nichts, weil die schmarotzen,
weil die faul sind. Ihr holt die Leute nicht hinter den Klingelschildern hervor,
wenn ihr den einen Namen zuhört. Ihr holt sie aus dem Haus, wenn ihr versteht,
dass die Geschichten keine Geschichten, sondern System sind.
Ein Problem, eine Lösung.
Und die Lösung heißt Klassenkampf. Dankeschön.
Ach, das ist doch alles Werbung für das Buch von Flip.
Ja, sehr, sehr gut. So muss man es angehen und bei Quintenzelser habe ich eher den Eindruck gehabt,
hier geht es darum, dass der Vorstand ein bisschen diverser gestaltet wird und
man so ein bisschen die Antivoten gegen sich aufbringt.
Aber eigentlich keine progressive politische Agenda verfolgt,
nämlich das Ökonomische ausgeklammert lässt. Und das war das bei diesen offiziellen
Veranstaltungen, was mir durch die Bank aufgefallen ist.
Jeder wird jetzt sicherlich, der dort war, sagen, ja, aber es gibt auch anderes,
das glaube ich. Aber dann muss man sich vielleicht als Kirchentag auch mal Gedanken
machen, warum werden eigentlich diese Stimmen abgebildet medial?
Warum wählt man dann einen Kirchentagspräsidenten, von dem man weiß,
dass er für eine ziemlich unsäckige Politik stand und steht und glaubt,
das hätte jetzt irgendwas mit Kirche zu tun.
Also wie gesagt, solange man den Kirchentag als eine Veranstaltung sieht,
wo Moderatoren und Politiker sich noch was dazu verdienen können,
dann ist das einfach falsch.
Schließen wir das Kapitel.
Lass mich kurz sagen, ich bin ja aus der Kirche ausgetreten und dann merkt man
ja plötzlich, was fehlt.
Nein, was man bekommt. Man zahlt ja dann keine Kirchensteuer mehr.
Mir war ja gar nicht klar, wie hoch die Kirchensteuer so ist.
Das ist ja doch ganz erheblich. Und das ist aber jetzt, ich bin ja Materialist,
wie du weißt, so ein Problem bei mir schon fast geworden. wenn ich mir,
unsicher bin, ob ich mir was kaufen soll. Also brauche ich das Parfum?
Soll ich das wirklich kaufen? Dann habe ich jetzt immer so diese unglaublich
tolle Rechtfertigung, dass ich zu mir sage, aber du hast doch Geld gespart,
du bist doch aus der Kirche ausgetreten.
Ja, sehr gut.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das ein bisschen überstrapaziere.
Schreib doch mal eine Predigt aus diesem Ding und.
Bei der nächsten Vortragsgelegenheit. Steuern sparen und Materialist bleiben.
Ne, du musst es so wie Abdul machen. Du sagst einfach, mach mal kurz Kirchentag hier.
Achso.
Ich beanspruche nicht Unfehlbarkeit, sondern Kirchentag.
Ich glaube, wenn muss man es schon beim Kirchentag machen, oder?
Ja.
Welche steuerlichen Vorteile hat mein Kirchenaustritt gebracht?
Ich glaube, die ziehen da recht hohe Schranken. Wie wir gesehen haben,
darf da nicht jeder sprechen.
Wir schließen das Kapitel Kirche mit einem kleinen Ausflug in die katholische.
Die hatten ja den synodalen Weg, bei dem, keine Ahnung, so Ansprüche wie Maria
2.0, dürfen auch Frauen hier mal was oder so.
Mehr als nur die lieben Kolleginnen seien, die auch noch die Fraktion unterstützen,
wie wir das ja von Amthor so gehört haben.
Dieser synodale Weg, ich hatte ja auch meinen ganzen Fernsehpodcast dazu,
Das war ein Abschluss dieses Jahr vorläufig mit der ein oder anderen Reformbemühungen.
Klar, vorne wurde geredet, hinten saßen die Bischöfe, hinten drinnen haben Veto,
Veto, Veto gerufen. Und jetzt wurde das ganz große Veto gerufen.
27 katholische Bischöfen haben gegen die Finanzierung eines Nachfolgeformats
des Synodalen Wegs gestimmt.
Nun muss eine alternative Finanzierung gefunden werden, damit das katholische
Reformvorhaben fortgesetzt werden kann.
Unter den vier Bischöfen ist auch der Kölner Kardinal Woelki.
Als Grund nannten sie Vorbehalte von Papst Franziskus gegenüber dem geplanten Gremium.
Die versuchen gerade, sich aus den Fängen ihrer eigenen Geschichte zu befreien.
Aber bei Woelki hat es ja auch morgens um 8 geklingelt.
Das war nicht die Sternsinge.
Es ist so banane, dass man das jetzt nicht mehr finanziert aus der Kirche heraus,
sondern denen noch so mitgibt, Ihr müsst jetzt mal neue Wege der Finanzierung
finden, während die gleichzeitig, du hast ja das Geld angesprochen, Wofür eigentlich?
Man kriegt das alles nicht mehr zusammen. Das ist wirklich irre.
Nun kommen wir nochmal auf die Threadwives zu sprechen. Das haben wir schon
auf der Bühne in Frankfurt getan. Wir müssen nochmal für die,
die das jetzt noch nicht gehört haben, kurz sagen, was die Threadwives sind.
Also das sind Frauen, die sich als traditionelle Hausfrauen verstehen, inszenieren.
Naja, es ist dann die große Frage, inwieweit man es nur mit Inszenierung zu
tun hat und die Wirklichkeit sieht dann sehr anders aus.
Jedenfalls gibt es erfolgreiche TikTokerinnen und YouTuberinnen,
die auf diesem Treadwife Trend surfen und wahnsinnigen Erfolg damit haben und
natürlich dadurch selbst Unternehmerinnen geworden sind.
Inzwischen mehr verdienen sicherlich als die Husbands. Aber das Konzept da ist,
bleib du doch zu Hause, mach dich schön, mach das Nest hübsch und der Mann geht
raus ins feindliche Leben wie in Schillers Glocke und arbeitet dort und verdient
so viel, dass es für euch beide reicht.
Was natürlich bedeutet, dass man eine hohe ökonomische Abhängigkeit vom Partner
hat und es geht da nicht nur um Ehen,
die geschlossen werden, die ja dann auch rechtlich gewisse Dinge mit sich bringen,
wenn man sich scheiden lässt, man nicht ganz ohne Geld dasteht,
sondern es geht auch um Beziehungen, die außerehelich sind und das bedeutet
natürlich, dass wenn diese Beziehung dann endet, man einfach gar kein Geld mehr
hat, wenn der Mann als Einkommensquelle dann wegkriegt.
Das darf da nicht scheitern und in deren Sicht hat das eine ganz hohe politische
Dimension, auch wenn die Frauen immer behaupten.
Ich showcase hier nur mein Lebensstil, ich missioniere damit nicht,
ihr könnt euch entscheiden wie ihr wollt und ja, sehr viele verbinden hier mit
irgendwie so ein altes Mutterbild, das hat ja gar nichts damit zu tun, wir sind modern.
Die man bei den Influencern immer findet. Wir hatten das auch bei Bibi,
die großes Tamtam machte um ihre Schönheitsoperationen und da natürlich alles genau erklärte,
warum und wie einfach das inzwischen ist, um dann am Ende immer zu sagen,
ja, aber ich will euch jetzt nicht das hier offerieren, also das ist jetzt keine Werbung dafür.
Ich sag euch, wie die Klinik und der Arzt in der Türkei heißen und wie teuer
das ist und so, So, dann könnt ihr überlegen.
Aber alles keine Werbung für irgendetwas.
Genau, also die Threat-Vibes ...
Haben wir uns erst mal als ganz vorsichtig vorstellen lassen.
Dann hatte ich ja einige Clips, wo so Kommentatoren im Internet sagen,
ja, das ist irgendwie, keine Ahnung, was kann man denn da dagegen haben?
Und bevor wir uns diese sehr kluge Kritik von Ash Sarkar anschauen,
müssen wir auch noch über den Threat-Husband reden. Mhm. Hier geht ja ein ganz neues Gefüge einher.
Esty Williams, also die Vorreiterin dieser Threadwives im Internet,
vor allem bei TikTok, sagt ja so, das hatte ich auch als diesen einen Clip im
ersten Konglomerat von ihr mit drin auf ihrer YouTube-Seite,
die Zeit, zu der man seinen Ehemann hinterfragt, ist nicht während der Ehe,
sondern während des Datings.
Man muss also sehr viel besser, kontrollierter Und auch anspruchsvoller daten
kann ja dann auch mehr Zeit kosten.
In der Zeit geht ja dann auch, also die biologische Uhr tickt ja,
also man darf sich auch nicht zu viel Zeit lassen. Aber es wird sehr viel Verantwortung
auf einen selbst genommen, weil während des Datings hat man es noch unter Kontrolle,
danach nicht mehr. Bis hin zu...
...kommt prüfe, wer sich ewig bindet.
Genau, man liefert sich dann aus. die Ehe ist, natürlich auf Lebenszeit und so weiter.
Und jetzt ist die Frage, Thread Husband, wie geht man als Mann an die Sache ran?
Und ich habe in diesem ganzen Gesuche ein Clip von, also ein längeres Video
von Hamza Ahmed gefunden, den ich nicht weiter kenne und der uns eher auch egal sein sollte.
Es ist halt, wie man das, also auch einer dieser mit Millionenreichweite und
so weiter. Und der erklärt uns mal die Prinzipien dieses neuen Datings,
aber aus männlicher Sicht, wenn man eine Thread Wife sucht. Wir können ja eh
nochmal die Frage mitlaufen lassen.
Keine Ahnung, wie viel potenzielle Threat Vibes gibt es denn?
Oder auch, wie viele Männer sind denn in der Lage, für zwei zu verdienen?
Die Frauen haben ja Ansprüche und so.
Ja, also es geht schon, das muss man vielleicht auch noch mal betonen,
darum, dass man ein sehr angenehmes Leben dann als Third Life hat.
Es ist also nicht so, dass man dort auf eine Zwei-Zimmer-Wohnung reduziert wohnt,
sondern man lebt so, wie man das aus vielleicht noch Familienerzählungen 50er,
60er, 70er Jahre kennt, da war das ja durchaus noch möglich.
Mitunter gibt es das auch, heute wird man das auch noch finden,
aber es ist viel seltener anzutreffen.
Aber es geht schon darum, dass man ein angenehmes oder fast luxuriöses Leben führen kann.
Das Treadwife-Dasein geht einher mit dem Anspruch dann auch Trophywife zu sein.
Trophywife, was ist das wieder?
Naja, Trophy Wife sind, es gibt ja auf der einen Seite dieses Sugar Daddy Ding,
also junge Frauen versuchen sich noch Geld dazu zu verdienen,
indem sie einmal die Woche bei Egon zu Hause sind, der dann sein Boomer Vermögen
nochmal verwendet, um dafür finanzielle Unterstützung, das läuft dann schon fast unter Sexarbeit.
Aber ist das Sugar Daddy? Ich dachte Sugar Daddy ist jetzt schon eher so,
also man hat schon eine Beziehung mit dem Sugar Daddy, glaube ich.
Ja, aber es ist so eine Situation. Man verabredet sich für einmal in der Woche,
einmal im Monat. In der Zeit ist man dann auch sozusagen sehr eng,
aber man lässt sich das eben sehr gut bezahlen und verwendet das Geld dann in
den anderen sechs Tagen auch.
Gut durchs Studium zu kommen, wie auch immer. Das ist sozusagen temporär.
Und die Trophy Wife sind diese Frauen, die sich Donald Trumps Kumpels auf dem
Golfplatz, also die da einfach präsentiert werden, 30 Jahre jünger.
Sie wissen dann, wahrscheinlich geht sehr viel des Erbes auf mich über und dann
bleibt ja noch für mich Restleben übrig.
Und ich muss mich dann mit ihm nicht mehr. Aber solange er lebt,
bin ich sozusagen die Frau an seiner Seite.
Hübsches Beiwerk.
Genau, hübsches Beiwerk. Also die Deko-Frau, die Trophy-Wife,
die man noch mal als Trophäe, Krönung der eigenen finanziellen Karriere,
die man gemacht hat, sich noch mal gönnt.
Und jetzt gucken wir uns das alles aus männlicher Sicht an. Wir gehen mal weiterhin
davon aus, dass das politisch extrem aufgeladen ist, auch wenn wir es erst gleich
mit Esch-Sarka durchformulieren.
Hamza Ahmed.
Soll man jetzt eigentlich heiraten oder nicht? Sehr viele junge Männer sind
ja ganz durch den Wind, weil Redpill, Bluepill, Yellowpill, wie auch immer.
Also, man weiß ja jetzt gar nicht, sollte man sich eine suchen,
der mal ein bester Freund ist oder hasst man eigentlich alle Frauen und versucht
nur durch Gamification irgendwie so viele wie möglich ins Bett zu kriegen.
Also, junge Männer sind ja total durch den Wind.
Und vertraut man ihr den Zugang zur Wallet an?
Genau, solche Sachen. Soll man eigentlich heiraten?
Also wir sind ja wieder mitten in der Erweckungsgemeinschaft,
sehr viele laden ihre Dating-Apps runter und gucken dann auf YouTube. So, how to...
Dating-App-Benutzung danach und
dann stolpert natürlich gleich in dieses Ganze, wie geht's jetzt und so.
Es gibt auch unglaublich viele Paare, die als YouTuber ihren Alltag zeigen,
wie man so lebt, also wie sie dann auch mit Konflikten umgehen oder wie sie
den Hausputz organisieren.
Das heißt, man bekommt dort zum einen praktische Tipps, aber es gab auch sehr
viel mit, ja, welchen Weg gehe ich?
Also früher hat die Kirche ja auch nicht nur sonntags mal einen Gottesdienst angeboten,
sondern die gehörte zum täglichen Leben mit dazu, mit ganz vielen Hochfesten,
mit den verschiedenen Andachten und hat dadurch eine Struktur gegeben,
die jetzt hier wiederkehrte.
Und die Ansprache ist eine sehr ähnliche. Also man kann noch so ein bisschen
diesen Sound von Bedford Strom, wie er dann sagt. Und dann ist aber jemand da
und da ist die Hoffnung. Das kann man jetzt hier gleich übertragen.
Genau und das wird auch gleich, der geht wirklich all in, der Typ,
jetzt wo du es angesprochen hast.
Genau, die Kirche hat zum Beispiel damals Alltag strukturiert.
Wir hatten ja über die, also selbst als damals schon die Kirche ein Gewicht
verlor, hat man eben dann doch regional die Organisation von Tanzthee über Vereine,
Angebote, was auch immer.
Man musste so, ja, das ist das Stadtteilhaus, da geht man so hin, da findet so was statt.
Jetzt haben wir natürlich diese hochgradig durchlöcherten Erwerbsbiografien,
den man natürlich nicht einfach eine...
Ehe nebenan stellen kann, also so wie man nicht seinem Arbeitgeber mit 25 kennenlernt
und dann bleibt man für 45 Pflichtjahre Berufstätigkeit an seiner Seite.
Na, co-evaluiert natürlich die ganze Beziehungsgestaltung so ein bisschen mit
und wird genauso luckenhaft und sprunghaft und so weiter.
Und darauf steigt er ein. Er hat natürlich die ganzen Videos gesehen,
wie man sich von einer Beziehung zur nächsten und so weiter,
wie man, ja, ich würde sagen Gamification ist das Wort. dieser ganzen Dating-Strategie-Findung.
Er sagt jetzt, nein, halt, stopp, Gegentrend.
So you may be watching this and thinking, wait, how to get a wife?
This guy's blue pill. Trust me when I say, bro, I have fully ingrained like
the red pill into my personality. I have some of the most top-written posts
of like red pill. I have some of the most popular red pill videos.
I know what the fuck I'm talking about with this.
Er hat ganz viele dieser Videos gesehen, weiß, wovon er redet und sagt,
das ist nicht die richtige Angehensweise. Wir brauchen was Neues.
Und jetzt wird dieses große Bild aufgemacht, die Anastasia. Wir hatten ja auf
der Bühne diesen einen Clip, die Anastasia-Bewegung in Sachsen-Anhalt oder wo.
Diese Neurechte Anastasia-Kult von einem feinen Mädchen, das kommt und so eine Heizgestalt ist.
Das ultra-traditionelle Familienbild wird jetzt mit dem ultra-nationalen politischen
Bild vermengt und dann macht man so seine eigenen No-Go-Areas,
in denen man sich da auslebt.
Wir waren falsch mit dem, wenn du denkst, dass jede Frau dich verarschen wird,
dass du nicht verheiratet wirst, dann wirst du deine Beziehungen in einen unglaublich
falschen Weg verändern.
Und es wird eine selbstverfüllende Prophezei, in der du literal mehr Jessicas
mehr triffst, weil die Anastasien der Welt nicht mit dir sein werden,
wenn du nicht verheiratet wirst.
Und das sind feste Termini, Jessicas und Anastasias.
Genau, die Anastasias auf der einen Seite, die haben wir schon gehört.
Im nächsten Clip hören wir die Jessicas.
Die Jessicas sind also die, gegen die man spielt die ganze Zeit.
Bei denen dann die Frage ist, wie viele Minuten oder Tage oder Stunden sollen
vergehen, bis ich ihr schreibe?
Wann findet welches Date statt? Weil und so weiter. Sie datet ja auch mehrere.
Wie bringt man sich da, also wie kommt man sozusagen als cooler Typ rüber?
Aber nicht zu needy und so.
Wie baut man diese Strategie zusammen? Nur, man will ja gar keine Jessica.
Neu ist jetzt, man will ja eine Anastasia, eine Treadwife. Eine,
die einem treu an der Seite steht.
Und er stellt erst mal fest, er ist selber so ein Jessica-Loser bisher gewesen.
If you have a woman who has nothing but you in mind, that is fantastic for your
ego and your sense of security.
With the life that I personally wanna live, with a certain level of like ...
Hmm, ich muss ein bisschen Journalismus machen, Bro. Hör' nicht auf mich,
Bro. Ich bin total klug, wenn es um Beziehungen geht. Ich bleib' einfach fucking Jessicas.
Wenn es Anastasia gibt, die das hier sehen, dann schreibt sie mir.
Ihm unterstellten, dem Publikum. Ihr seid ja alle Jessica-Loser.
Ich weiß einfach nicht, wie mir geschah und so.
Also er möchte eine Frau haben, die nur ihn sieht.
Die nur noch wie ihn da...
Also das ist ja das Cosima-Wagner-Prinzip. Richard Wagner hat ja mit Cosima
dann eine gefunden, die ihn anhimmelte.
Und als er starb, er war ja sehr viel älter, hat dann Cosima an dem Grab von
Richard Wagner sich die Haare abgeschnitten, um damit auch zu signalisieren,
von nun an kein Mann mehr in meinem Leben, da war nur Richard.
Aber da sind wir im 19. Jahrhundert, muss ich dazu sagen.
Über den Tod hinaus. Er will nicht länger ein Jessica-Loser sein,
er sucht die Anastasia und jetzt definiert er sie sich.
Das ist natürlich nicht so aufgeladen im Sinne von da gab es ja irgendwo eine
Feen-Literatur weit weg im Slawischen oder so, sondern was ist das eigentlich
für eine Anastasia, die man sich sucht?
Als ich älter werde und speziell als ich mehr erfolgreich werde,
denke ich mehr an Kinder in der effektivsten Weise.
Ich will meinen Kindern das beste Leben möglich machen.
Frag dich diese Frage, es ist jetzt schon ein bisschen offensichtlich,
aber frage dich diese Frage.
Was ist die eine, einzige, wichtigste Entscheidung in deinem Leben?
Die Frau, mit der du Kinder hast.
Das ist die wichtigste Entscheidung, die du jemals machen wirst.
Die Frau, mit der du Kinder haben wirst. Deshalb ist es so wichtig,
als junger Mann schon über die Art von Frau zu denken, mit der du Kinder haben willst.
Und es muss eine Frau sein. Du musst dafür verheiratet werden.
Du willst ja dein Erbe und so weiter.
Und es soll auch effektiv sein.
Genau. Ich mein, das Kind, dieses Bild von Kindern, das ist noch mal so Sub-Exkurs, ne?
Dieses Bild von Kindern im Sinne von, da lebt ein Stück von dir selbst weiter.
Also, das ist so dein Erbe für die Welt.
Ist ja auch völlig, ähm ...
Gerade wenn's dann so ausgebreitet wird oder sich verbreitert hinsichtlich,
nicht nur das Kind kann sich nicht anders entscheiden als das ist mein Vater.
Ja, so, sondern auch die Frau wird jetzt da noch so rein importiert in dieses
völlig Banane Bild, denn am Ende stellt man ja fest irgendwie,
ich erlebe das ja auch gerade jetzt, meine große Tochter ist jetzt 13.
Und wenn ich mir überlege, wie viel Kontakt ich mit meinen Eltern habe,
na ja, nicht mehr als notwendig ist. Ich brauche jetzt nicht meine Eltern irgendwie als und so weiter.
Also hat man halt diesen, ja, diese Ehrlichkeit irgendwie und so.
Aber diese Art von Abhängigkeit, wie er das hier von vornherein so rein interpretiert,
überbewertet, das ist ja gar nicht gegeben. Und wir haben ja auch eine politische Strömung.
Beispielsweise Grüne und FDP haben jetzt in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag und damals
auch in den Wahlprogramm schon die Verantwortungsgemeinschaft mit reingeschrieben,
wo es heißt, naja, wenn du Kinder großziehen willst, muss gar nicht Liebe und
Leidenschaft als Grundlage da sein,
sondern nur so eine Übereinkunft, dass man ökonomisch sich darauf einigt und dann,
ja, könnten es auch drei Leute sein, die in so eine Art von Verantwortungsgemeinschaft
reingehen und wenn einer ein Kind mitbringt und die anderen wollen auch für
dieses Kind Verantwortung übernehmen, ja, dann geben wir halt Auskunftsrechte
im Krankenhaus und Abholrechte im Kindergarten und wie auch immer.
Das sind nur auch die Realität widerspiegelt. Das ist ja gar nicht,
weil das mitunter dann so kritisiert wurde, als hätten FDP und Grüne sich das ausgedacht.
So wünschen sie sich eine Utopie. Nee, das ist eine Reaktion auf bestehende Realitäten.
Genau.
Also dass sehr viele Familien so längst organisiert werden oder Menschen mit
Kindern das so aus ökonomischen Zwängen oder aus Zwängen, weil sie nicht mehr zusammen sind.
Aus Gründen, weil sie nicht mehr zusammen sind, müssen sie es so machen.
Und was aber das hier ist, also der könnte ja auch so mitspielen,
das ist Fast & Furious. Also da ist genau diese Idee, wo Vin Diesel nochmal sagt, it's family.
Und dann wird auch dem Sohn schon deutlich gemacht, du bist der Erbe,
du trittst in meine Fußstapfen, komm mal mit hier in die Werkstatt,
ich zeig dir jetzt mal, wie man in einem Auto schraubt und das gebe ich mit
und das geben wir alle, wir Torettos geben das unserer nächsten Generation mit.
Und das ist so aufgeladen und die haben natürlich auch die idealen Frauen dann
immer zur Seite, die auch nichts anderes wollen, als für die Familie da sein.
Ja, wir hatten letztens auch diese Clangewalt in Hessen,
auf die komme ich bestimmt im Fernsehpodcast mal zurück, aber da gab es im Fernsehen
Ralf Gatban, ein Islamwissenschaftler, der selbst einen muslimischen Hintergrund
hat, der dann nochmal erklärt hat, wie es dazu kam.
Naja, wir haben Familien hier, also einzelne Menschen hierher geholt,
weil irgendwann gab es diese Gastarbeiteranwerbungsprogramme und so weiter.
Dann kam natürlich die normale globale Migration und so.
Und jetzt haben wir eben Familien und Clans in Nordrhein-Westfalen,
aber auch woanders, aber da eben besonders.
Und dann meint er so, ja man muss sich das so vorstellen, wir in Deutschland
haben natürlich so eine Idee von Sozialstaat, die kommen aber aus Regionen,
wo es keinen Sozialstaat gibt.
Also entweder die Familie bringt dich durch oder nicht und da wird für alles
gesorgt. Also jemand muss dich zum Arzt bringen, okay, das kennen wir auch, Fahrgemeinschaft.
Der Bruder fährt mich. Jemand muss den Arzt bezahlen. Na ja,
macht man halt dieses Crowdfunding innerhalb des Clans. Man steht ja füreinander
ein, man merkt sich das dann auch. Und wenn der nächste Hilfe braucht,
muss man's zurückzahlen.
Und diese Art von Clan-Struktur hat sich so verfestigt, dass die sich gegenseitig
die Kinder da irgendwie rächen.
Wenn da irgendwas passiert oder eine Frau oder keine Ahnung.
Dann bricht genau so was aus.
Und das sind ja diese überholten Familienmodelle, die wir genau nicht wollen,
weil wir die auch nicht als modern ansehen weil wir eben sagen,
die brauchen wir ja eigentlich aus ökonomischen Gründen auch nicht,
weil wir haben ja einen Sozialstaat.
Weil wir auf eine freie Wählbarkeit setzen. Das Problem ist ja,
eine Familie wird man hineingeworfen.
War es Friedrich Nietzsche, der sagte, den Nachteil, dass man aus einer Familie
stammt, kann man nur dadurch wettmachen, dass man keine hinterlässt.
Könnte auch Karl Kraus gewesen sein, ich weiß es nicht.
Jedenfalls ist die freie Wahl, also die Wahlverwandtschaft, auch wenn sie bei
Goethe dann im Roman eher scheitert,
Das präferierte Modell, was
nicht Entsolidarisierung mit Familienmitgliedern notwendig meinen muss,
aber es kann auch bedeuten, wenn der Onkel in Sonneberg einem erklärt,
dass das absolut richtig ist, jetzt die AfD zu wählen, dann kann man auch sagen,
gut, mit dir feiere ich halt nicht mehr Weihnachten.
Genau. Und das haben wir ja auf ganz vielen Ebenen. Also wir sagen zum Beispiel,
nee, der Bildungsbiografie der Eltern sollte sich nicht vererben.
Wir brauchen eine Parallelstruktur zur Familie, die den Kindern auch Chancen
ermöglicht, wenn es mit dem Elternhaus nicht mitgegeben ist.
Wir sagen dann irgendwie, nee, die Grenze, dass man für die Pflegeleistung seiner
Eltern mitbezahlen muss, erst ab 100.000 Euro Einkommen. Das ist nicht die eigene Biografie.
Übrigens die SPD ja ganz stark. Das war wirklich Hubertus Heil Erfolg.
Mir war das gar nicht so klar. Jetzt hätte mir ein auch Hörer dieses Podcasts,
der in der SPD ist und da habe ich auch gedacht, Mensch, also wir regen uns
jetzt über den Heizhammer auf und was das kostet.
Aber was diese Gesetzesänderung an finanziellem Spielraum geschaffen hat,
also wie sehr sich dadurch das Leben verbessert hat, das hat die SPD nicht geschafft.
Oder auch die Medien hatten kein Interesse daran, das entsprechend zu machen.
Also da könnte man, man müsste wirklich sagen, wir haben ihnen 100.000 Euro geschenkt.
Im Grunde sollte Hubertus Heil jeden Tag tausende Briefe verschicken,
in denen er den Leuten sagt, und das habe ich dir erspart, dass du die nächsten
sieben Jahre jeden Monat 1.500 Euro für Vater zahlen musst. Ja.
Also genau, das kann dann nicht eigenheims werden.
Das ist ja wirklich das Ding, das wäre ja die, das ist ja die Maßnahme,
die die Mitte der Gesellschaft trifft.
Genau, also wir haben eigentlich überall diese Befreiung von Familie.
Es ist ja kein, die CDU würde jetzt sagen, nee, wir wollen das die Familie und so weiter.
Die machen das auch gern.
Genau, ja, genau, das hört man da wieder. Das war in dem Fall auch die SPD, muss man dazu sagen.
Die pflegen ja alle gern. Also wir
haben eine Befreiung und damit eine Modernisierung des Familienmodells,
das nämlich dann ein bisschen mehr auf Freiheit und Freiwilligkeit vor allem
abzielt, so dass man wieder gerne zusammen Weihnachten feiert und auch sagen kann,
Ja, liebe Mutter, lieber Vater, danke, es war eine große Aufgabe,
mich durchs Studium zu bringen und ihr müsst jetzt Mietbürgschaften für mich
unterschreiben und so weiter und fort,
aber jetzt stehe ich auf eigenen Füßen, es reicht,
wenn wir uns jetzt im Sommer eine Woche sehen oder sowas,
also diese Art von Befreiung steckt ja da eigentlich drin und jetzt kommt er
hier und sagt, nee, die Entscheidung, Kinder, du bist dein Leben lang dem Kind
ausgeliefert und deiner Ehefrau, entscheideweise.
Ja, diese Idee von, nee, wir kaufen zwar jetzt ein Haus und so,
aber wir brauchen das echt nur 20 Jahre. Danach sind die Kinderzimmer für uns
nicht mehr zu gebrauchen, wir ziehen dann aus.
Das steckt ja hier gar nicht drin, sondern du gründest ja mit der Familie Heimathof,
alles, es muss dann fürs Leben lang und du bist dann festgezort.
Also das ist sowieso so ein extrem unmodernes Bild, dass hier irgendwie von ihm hofiert wird.
Und man könnte ja auch selbst einmal bei sich anfangen und fragen,
kenne ich mich eigentlich selbst so gut, dass ich weiß, wo ich in 50 Jahren
stehen will und dann will ich noch von jemand anders so genau beschreit wissen,
dass der auch in 50 Jahren dort stehen wird.
Ja, muss das überhaupt sein? Also man entwickelt sich ja nun wirklich mal weiter,
gerade in dieser Welt, die sich ja auch so rasant entwickelt.
Wir leben ja nicht in so einer Stagnationswelt.
Nun gut, also, es stehen besondere Ansprüche an die Menschen an,
mit denen man lebt, nämlich die Mutter der eigenen Kinder und damit wachsen
auch die Ansprüche an einen selbst.
Man muss also erstmal auf sich gucken und sagen, ich muss einer der Top 1% der Männer
werden und wie er das hier beschreibt, finde ich amüsant,
denn ehrlicherweise, es ist ja nicht alles verkehrt, wenn man sich die Männer
so anschaut, die auf der Straße, Mir ist aufgefallen, als ich durch Italien
gelaufen bin, wo ja die Männer so ein anderes Bild von sich selber haben als hier in Deutschland.
Angefangen bei der Mode, aber auch bei Körperformen und so.
Ja, aber das ist primär die Mode. Auch die sehr alten Italiener und so,
die wissen schon, dass es mitunter vernünftig ist, einfach mal ein weißes Hemd
zu tragen und nicht nur ein rundes T-Shirt.
Rennst du bei mir oft in die Türen ein, wo ich hier im T-Shirt und kurzer Hose vor dir sitze?
In Flip-Flops? Also, dieser erste Anspruch von ihm würde ich sagen, warum nicht?
Gehen die Top 1% der Männer ist nicht schwierig. Jeder der dir das sagt,
ist verdammt lügend. Gehen die Top 1% der Männer ist nicht so schwierig.
Es gibt 100 Männer, gewinn 99 von ihnen.
90% der Männer trainieren nicht einmal. Es gibt 100 Männer, das Beste ist nicht
so schwierig. Okay, wenn wir sagen, es gibt 10.000 Männer, 100.000 Männer,
1.000.000 Männer, dann wird es schwierig. Aber aus 100, geh über 100 Männer
in deiner Straße. Geh über 100 Männer. Visualisiere 100 Männer, die du überlebst.
Du sagst mir, dass du nicht das Beste bist.
Also, geh über die Straße und werde zum Besten. Also gehöre zum Top 1 Prozent der Männer.
Und ich würde sagen, ja, wenn man so über die Straße geht und sich mal 100 Männer anschaut.
Die Latte legt dich sehr hoch, liebe Bella. Also lassen wir ihm das mal durchgehen.
Das Problem ist natürlich, wenn das alle machen, dann sind alle ein bisschen nach oben gegangen.
Aber dann, wenn man von dem Verhältnis, also das Problem ist dann nach wie vor vorhanden.
Aber noch schafft man das, glaube ich, sehr gut.
Ausgangslage ist entsprechend. Nächstes Baustellending. Dating.
Bitte nicht mehr toxisch daten.
Aber es ist ein modernes Thema. Frauen sind schlecht, man sollte sie so behandeln,
sie sollten nicht ernsthaft verlieren und sie sollten nie verheiratet werden.
Und Frauen denken das auch. Frauen denken, Männer sind scheiße.
Wir brauchen keine Männer, ich brauche keine Männer.
Bruder, beide Seiten sind verdammt deprimiert. Warum willst du Teil dieser Gruppen
sein? Beide Seiten kämpfen gegen einander, machen schreckliche TikToks über
den Gegensex. Während die 1%
der gesundheitlichen Menschen verheiratet werden und ihr Leben genießen.
So, Dating, insbesondere über Dating-Apps da dran, an Social-Media-Prinzipien
und so weiter, haben alles zerstört.
Ja. Gibt's ja viele, die sagen, das stimmt.
Aber ein Prozent der Leute kommen ja irgendwie doch durch, bleiben dabei gesund,
finden den anderen ein Prozent der Gesunden und dann findet ein Mating auf Augenhöhe
statt und dann kann man schön in den Hafen der Ehe einsegeln.
Das ist sein Bild. So, wie macht man das nun? Und jetzt würde ich sagen,
jetzt wird es ein bisschen übertrieben, denn.
Werde dir klar über dich selbst und über die Wunschkandidatin Ehefrau.
Das geht nur noch darum, welches Profil brauche ich, wenn ich jemanden neu einstelle.
Das ist ja einfach eine Unternehmerin, die sich die Dinge. Ja,
aber es gibt halt Fachkräftemangel und dann sind alle enttäuscht,
wenn es den nicht mehr gibt.
Hier nicht mehr gibt. Ich empfehle sehr das Buch von Sven Hildenkamp Das Ende der Liebe,
wo er genau das beschreibt, dass unsere Moderne sehr stark daraus besteht,
dass wir eine Vorstellung haben von der ganz großen Liebe und der Person,
die alles dann so erfüllen wird, wie wir es uns gedacht haben.
Und eigentlich tritt es aber dann doch nie ein. Oder wir sehen dann irgendeine
Personen sind fasziniert und glauben, das ist jetzt die Person und dann geht
sie weiter und dann haben wir sie schon wieder vergessen und dann kommt die nächste.
Also es ist interessant, dass hier eigentlich jetzt jemand gesucht wird für
das Profil und dann muss man das so abhaken.
Im Prinzip macht das auch Christian Grey so in Fifty Shades of Grey,
wo dann auch abgehakt wird, also wie sie so ist und dann wird noch mal im Detail
der Vertrag besprochen, was dann noch so sexuell alles laufen soll.
Genau, also wir haben sowieso schon, er hat es ja beschrieben,
ein toxisches Dating, weil dadurch, dass die Fluktuation so hoch ist,
man einfach weiterswipen kann, rangeln immer 80% um 10% des anderen Geschlechts.
Da findet kein ordentliches Matching statt. Ich war da ja auf das Buch von Scott
Galloway über Mating in Equality,
das ist auf jeden Fall eine interessante Themensetzung und seine Empfehlung
ist jetzt, ja, guck dir gar keine Profile an, sondern erfinde noch neben den
ohnehin schon idealisierten Profilen, hyperidealisiere nochmal eins, was nur für dich passt.
Schreib 40 Seiten lang auf, das ist jetzt so sein Vorbild.
Pygmalion ist der Bildhauer, der eine Traumfrau als Statue errichtet und dann
wird die aber lebendig und dann hat er sie und das ist jetzt der Wunsch,
der hier eintreten soll.
So soll es funktionieren und mit einem Spezialauftrag noch.
Du willst ja nicht die ganze Zeit abgelenkt werden. Die anderen Frauen verhüllen
sich ja nicht plötzlich, nur weil du jemanden geheiratet hast.
Deswegen muss die Frau auf 40 Seiten deinen Ansprüchen genügen,
wie sie sich da verhält, wie sie da drauf ist, welchen Humor sie hat und dann
noch super sexy aussehen.
Das ist jetzt ein Weg zum Glück, das er missionarisch an ein Millionenpublikum ausspielt.
Also wie viel Unglück hier gesät wird, können wir ungefähr schätzen.
Und jetzt kommt der Kniff.
Dann, wenn du diese Liste hast, frage dich, du hast eine fantastische Foto dieser Frau.
Was will sie? Worauf ist sie interessiert? Vorstell dir diese Frau,
die du geschrieben hast.
Vorstell dir, dass sie die gleiche Praxis macht, aber für ihren Mann.
Was schreibt sie? Weil wenn diese Frau so groß ist, wie du denkst,
dass sie ist, würde sie hohe Standards haben.
Und Chachibity das Profil, das Dating-Profil deiner Wunsch-Ehefrau hochladen
und Frauen sollten das dann sehen und sagen, ah, dem entspreche ich.
Oder man lässt ein Bild generieren, also wie man ja jetzt auch schon sagen kann,
mal mal zwei Leute, die so aussehen, kann man das auch machen.
Und dann muss man nur noch mit dem Bild durch die Welt ziehen und gucken,
ob es irgendwo zutrifft.
Genau. Und jetzt sind wir hier, das ist schon fast Person of Interest,
zwei Maschinen, die allwissend sind, kämpfen gegeneinander, aber nicht direkt,
sondern sie simulieren sich gegenseitig, um dann den einen möglichst realistischen
Angriffspfad zu finden.
Also du imaginierst dir eine Frau und ihr imaginiert dann,
was sie sich von dir wünscht, um dann diesen Bilde zu entsprechen und dich dann
komplett selbst aufzulösen, sondern nur noch diesem über zwei Wanden von dir
selbst hergestellten Fremdbild nachzukommen.
Every single person will tell you the exact same thing. Which is like,
no, don't do anything for women. Don't do anything for women.
Do it all for yourself, King. I fucking hate that advice, bro. Do it all for yourself.
Don't think about girls at all. I don't do it for girls. I do it for myself.
Everyone will say that to you. Bro, I'm like, I feel like I'm the one person
who says, no, I do it for girls. Of course I do.
Of course I do. Of course I'm improving myself to like, to attract my future.
Of course I am. What's wrong with saying that?
Aber da würde ich sagen, dem würde ja Ja, aber du sollst ja zwischendurch noch
diese Schleife der Hyperidealisierung fahren.
Dass du es dann nur für diese eine Frau...
Ja, das ist natürlich Unsinn, aber dass Leute ins Fitnessstudio gehen,
um attraktiv zu sein, sein. Für die Partnerwahl ist, glaube ich...
Sehr, sehr. Oder dass auch, selbst wenn man in Beziehungen ist,
man natürlich aufs äußere Wert legt.
Nicht nur für die eigene Beziehung, sondern auch generell, wie man wahrgenommen
wird. Also man macht sehr viel für andere Leute. Also das ist nicht so,
dass man alleine in der Höhle leben würde, vielleicht dann auch so wäre.
Also bei manchen habe ich da nicht so den Eindruck.
Da kommt ein ehrliches Eingeständnis rein.
Und das ist ja schon noch häufig bei diesen Sachen anzutreffen,
dass so anthropologische Konstanten, die vielleicht auch von vielen immer so
im aktuellen Diskurs ausgeklammert werden, dass die ja da noch zu Worte kommen.
Also dass man sagt, ja klar, man will doch attraktiv sein.
Und wenn sich jetzt jeder selbst befragt, jetzt können wir über Normschönheiten
diskutieren, wir können die dekonstruieren, wir können ganz viel darüber reden.
Aber dennoch würde so intuitiv erst einmal jeder sagen, oder hat so eine Ahnung
davon, was gemeint ist oder wie das einen selbst betrifft.
Wenn gleich dann das, was man als schön empfindet, nochmal abweichen kann von
dem, was ihm vielleicht da vor Augen fühlt.
Aber was mich jetzt eigentlich so schockiert daran ist, wie sehr das durchkalkuliert
ist, also fast so eine Algorithmisierung von Beziehungen, die da stattfindet.
Und eigentlich müsste man dann doch sagen, dass dieser romantische Liebesentwurf,
also der Begegnung mit einer Person und plötzlich ist die Verliebtheit so groß,
dass sich alle Fragen in dem Sinne gar nicht mehr stellen oder sich dann sowieso
beantworten. Das ist ja genau das Gegenzukonzept.
Also ich würde nicht sagen, dass wir jetzt die Romantik loswerden müssen,
weil wir jetzt da ganz viele Bücher gibt es ja so in diese Richtung jetzt mal
die Romantik loswerden, sondern ich würde sagen, eigentlich hat die Romantik
immer noch den wirklich radikalen Ansatz von Liebe und hier das ist ja eine Kalkulation.
Also so kann ich auch jemanden einstellen nach den Prinzipien.
Also die Romantik kommt ja auch aus diesem, also der Begriff aus diesem literarischen
Genre erstmal ganz bewundert die Welt.
Und zwar nicht nur die Beziehungswelt, sondern grundsätzlich so ein bisschen
staunend auf die Welt zu blicken. Nur hier haben wir ja so eine pervertierte
Romantik, in der alle Jessicas aussortiert werden.
In der man eben sich nicht mehr überraschen lässt und so, sondern nur noch seiner
einen Anastasia hinterher folgt,
in deren Sicht, ja, es ist dieses Eigengeständnis, wir haben es ja immer nur
für die Frauen gemacht, Aber eben die neue Ideologie, 99 Prozent,
sortieren wir da schon mal aus. Also die interessieren uns gar nicht.
Abonniere unseren Kanal, wenn du willst. Willkommen in der Kult,
mach das Arbeitende, besonders wenn du es nicht fühlst.
Do the hard work. Welcome to the cult.
Also das ist jetzt die neue Arbeit an sich, dass man der ideale Husband für
das ideale Treadwile führt.
Und das ist, ich würde sagen, das ist, ich weiß nicht genau,
welche von beiden, rote oder blaue Pille, im Extrem.
Nämlich alle zu ignorieren und sozusagen alle Welt zur Jessica zu erklären und
damit auch zu diffamieren und ihnen sozusagen vorwegzukommen.
Ja, das ist ja ein Alpha-Kult, wie wir den hatten. Es gibt halt nur wenige Alphas,
der jetzt übertragen wird auf so eine Beziehungskonstellation.
Frauen, die einem Korb geben, waren ja eh nur Jessicas. Ja, so ungefähr.
Also sich so im Vorfeld schon mal zu immunisieren.
Was ja auch interessant ist, dass gar nicht mehr das andere Geschlecht,
sowohl bei den Treadwives als jetzt auch bei den Treadhusbands oder bei diesen
Coaches, auch so ganz normal als Mensch wahrgenommen wird.
Also es geht ja immer nur darum, ist es die Frau fürs Leben,
der Mann fürs Leben oder nicht?
Ist es sexuelle Attraktivität oder nicht? Und alle anderen zwischenmenschlichen
Fragen spielen keine Rolle mehr. Also die Frauen bleiben unter sich dann.
Also das ist dann wie ganz, ganz früher.
Die können sich, die Threadrives untereinander tauschen sich aus und wahrscheinlich
sprechen sie über die Männer und die Männer tauschen sich auch aus unter sich
und sprechen über die Threadrives.
Aber dass Männer und Frauen miteinander agieren können in nicht sexueller Weise
oder nicht mit dem Blick auf wir gründen morgen eine Familie,
ist ja gar nicht mehr vorgesehen.
Das ist ja Zeitverschwendung auf dem Weg die Threadwife zu finden.
Also hier geht es drunter und drüber, weshalb wir uns Ash Sarkars Kritik angucken.
Ich empfehle sehr, ihr sowieso zu folgen. Sie ist bei diesem Newdingsdabums
Media Konglomerat mit dabei in England.
Die während Brexit war und so, war da sehr viel so alternative mediale Besprechung
dieser ganzen Vorgänge.
Also so wie Tribune oder Jacobin, so in diese Richtung?
Ja, so ein bisschen, genau. Die machen einfach so ihren YouTube-Programmpunkt,
wo sie so ein bisschen die Sachen diskutieren.
Und da ist sie mir aufgefallen, da war sie immer sehr witzig in diesem Podcast.
Ich werde es nochmal raussuchen und verlinken.
Sie steigt mal ins Thema Threadvive ein.
Einige jüngere Millennials und Zoomers haben entschieden, das lebende La Vida
Kasserole zu empfangen. Sie vermitteln sich an das Kochen, das Reinigen und
das Kindereien, während ihre Ehefrauen oder Freunde, ich weiß es nicht,
Feuerwerfer oder Menschenrechte arbeiten.
Und schau, ich sage nicht, dass es etwas unbequemes gibt, als Mutter zu sein
oder gute Essen zu machen.
Ich mag elaborate Essen. Für diese Frage macht auch mein Freund.
Aber der Tradwife-Trend ist nicht nur ein Weg, um über die Erfahrung eines Frauen
zu sprechen und macht arbeitende Arbeit.
Ihr Freund aber auch. Und dass sie erstmal diese Unterscheidung infrage stellt, die da gemacht wird.
Genau, sie hinterfragt von Grund auf und bringt das jetzt auch mal im Kontext
dieser politischen Großwetterlage.
Die Tradwife-Trendin existiert nicht in Isolation. Sie ist verbunden mit tiefenregressiven
politischen und sozialen Bewegungen, wie dem christlichen und weißen Nationalismus
und dem Antifeminismus.
Feminismus ist eine Ideologie, die nicht von Feministen verteidigt werden kann.
Es ist Teil einer breiteren Veränderung der jungen Menschen,
die von Neoliberalismus unzufrieden sind und sozialen Veränderungen wollen.
Wir waren jetzt gerade Andrew Tate und Jordan Peterson zu sehen.
Ja, das sind natürlich die Vorreiter dieser rote Pille, blaue Pille Diskussion,
die ja, wie gesagt, ihrerseits Reaktionen auf diese Gesamtwetterlage sind.
Ich würde eben auch sagen, wenn wir diese, also wir können es ja nicht ohne Ökonomie denken.
Das ist ja immer ganz wichtig. Und die Ökonomie ist nun mal,
dass man selber sich als Arbeitnehmer und Verdiener irgendwo verortet und sich
dann fragt, welche Beziehung habe ich denn zu meinem Arbeitgeber?
Und dann ist ja die ganz große, wir haben es ja bei Thomas de Maizière gehört,
die Leute sind ja gar nicht mehr treu.
Es ist ja fast so eine Art Compliance, die da eingefordert sind von Therapietreue.
Wir haben euch gesagt, ihr wollt hier Geld verdienen, also jetzt seid doch mal treu.
Während gleichzeitig von der anderen Seite, ja wir stellen dich leider nur befristet ein,
wir sind auch gerade in Deutschland doppelt über dem OECD Durchschnitt,
was Befristung angeht, der 25-Jährigen und dann nützt da auch nichts zu sagen,
ja die sind ja alle in Ausbildung oder so, nee, damit kann man es nicht erklären.
Und selbst wenn du dann irgendwie mal unbefristet reinrutschst,
reicht dein Geld einfach nicht. Also hast dann eh diese Lücken.
Dann sind wir schon in Senneberg. 44 Prozent der Leute teilen sich die Schicksalsgemeinschaft,
hier vom Mindestlohn abhängig zu sein. Also wo eh schon gesagt wird,
eigentlich würde der Lehrer am liebsten gar nichts zahlen.
Wir müssen aber. Und dann kriegst du halt genau den Pflichtanteil irgendwie
und das ist die Gesamtwetterlage, in der natürlich Beziehungen anders funktionieren.
Ist ja völlig klar. Also so viel Leidenschaft kann man ja gar nicht erwarten,
dass alles andere ausgeblendet wird. Ein Leben lang womöglich noch. Das ist ja absurd.
Und in der Hinsicht weist sie auch darauf hin, diese Art der finanziellen Abhängigkeit,
während alles andere total flexibel ist, da sollte man mal nicht davon ausgehen,
dass das irgendwie funktioniert.
I'm not saying that every relationship where men are in charge of the finances is abusive.
Just that giving up your financial autonomy and placing it in the hands of your
partner is highly risky if things do indeed go wrong.
Also die Esther Perel, die ich ja sehr schätze, die jetzt auch wieder ihren
Podcast beginnt, habe ich gehört, in Werbeeinblendungen, kommt ja auch mit so
einer Argumentation, die Ehe hat sich verändert.
Das heißt aber noch nicht, dass man die Ehe gleich abschreiben muss,
wie man auch der CDU sagen muss. Niemand kämpft hier gegen Familien.
Man guckt sich nur genau an, was ist das Gefüge, was will man und was nicht.
Ister Perel sagt zum Beispiel, man kann bei der Ehe bei allem bleiben,
was so ist, nur mit der Losung, bis dass der Tod euch scheidet. Das sollte man halt.
Aber diese Art von Treueerwartung, die man hat, diese Art von sich ökonomisch
in dieser Zugewinngemeinschaft, sich ausliefern usw., das kann man alles machen, bis zur Trennung.
Und dann kommt dann einfach die nächste Ehe, das ist die einzige Modifikation,
dann ist es schon modern.
Das ist wie Elisabeth Taylor 8 mal heiraten oder Zsa Zsa Gabor. Nur die Frage ist ja...
Retrospektiv stimmt das ja exakt so. Man hat dann die zweite oder dritte Ehe,
aber grundsätzlich, wenn die erste Ehe geschlossen wird oder wenn man,
man muss ja noch gar nicht bis zur Ehe gehen, sondern ich glaube,
wenn man jetzt mit jemandem zusammenzieht und gemeinsam etwas aufbaut,
ob das jetzt ein Haus ist oder sich reproduziert, was auch immer,
sich fünf Haustiere anschafft, dann geht das ja schon, also ist der Horizont schon Ewigkeit.
Also niemand sagt ja zum Beispiel, also ich kann sagen, ich wohne jetzt mal
drei Jahre in Frankfurt, weil das gut passt, also das wäre das eine,
aber es würde jetzt niemand eine Beziehung beginnen und sagen,
ja, das mache ich jetzt so bis zum 37.
Lebensjahr und dann gucke ich nochmal neu. Also das heißt, das wird ja nur retrospektiv,
geht etwas auseinander aus irgendwelchen Kunden.
Deshalb hat die politische Anstrengung da ist, eine Verantwortungsgemeinschaft
schon mal als Idee vorzustellen und dann, würde ich sagen, über die nächsten
Jahrzehnte auch der Ehe anzugleichen.
Die CDU sperrt sich natürlich noch dagegen, dass dann auch irgendeine ökonomische
Komponente drin ist und die FDP sagt schon, ja, ja, da wird es keine ökonomische Komponente geben.
Aber ich würde mal sagen, es sickert ja ein über die Alten, also über die Älteren,
die am Lebensabend nochmal sagen, nee, macht schon Sinn, dass ich jetzt nochmal
in eine WG ziehe. Und dass wir dann auch klären, in welchem Verantwortungsverhältnis
wir drei, vier, fünf eigentlich zusammenwohnen.
Unbestritten ist das so, aber wie ist das mit der Ehe? Also weil du jetzt eben
sagtest, die Ehe an sich stirbt nicht aus, aber die Ehe für die Ewigkeit ist nicht mehr das Konzept.
Aber eine Ehe wird ja zunächst einmal geschlossen, schon ob mit oder ohne Gott,
mit der Perspektive, man bleibt zusammen. Also es sagt ja, würde ja zumindest
niemand am Anfang sagen,
Ich denke mal für 15 Jahre funktioniert das hier. Während ich ja bei einem Haus,
wo ich zwei, drei Kinder beherbergen muss, sagen kann, dieses Haus ist jetzt
ideal für fünft, aber in 20 Jahren nicht mehr, dann ziehen wir in eine Stadtwohnung.
Aber bei einer Ehe sage ich ja nicht, gerade ideale Partnerin,
aber in 20 Jahren nochmal neu, sondern das ergibt sich ja aus der Lebensführung dann.
Jemand lernt jemanden kennen, was weiß ich.
Also es liegt noch nahe, das so zu beschreiben. Die Realität ist aber,
dass die Verantwortungsgemeinschaft als rechtliches Prinzip auch kam für Leute,
die sagen, Ehe, wieso soll ich denn heiraten?
Klar liebe ich dich, aber müssen wir echt heiraten? Das kommt mir irgendwie
so ein bisschen altbacken vor.
Und ich kenne sehr viele Ehen, inklusive meiner, die einfach gesagt haben,
jetzt wo die Kinder auf dem Weg sind, komm, wir machen lieber die eine Ehe,
Bevor du da 15 verschiedene und du weißt gar nicht, an was muss ich jetzt eigentlich
alles so denken, sondern die Ehe erledigt halt einfach alles.
Plus sie wird noch finanziell gefördert vom Staat. Ich würde sagen,
da schwingt gar nichts mit Ablauf drin. Da steckt einfach nur drin,
ah ja stimmt, jetzt Kinder, also machen wir das einfach.
Ja, aber es hat sozusagen gar keine zeitliche Dimension.
Rein auf Sachebene wird es einfach entschieden, dass man dann,
und dann wird ja auch ganz häufig in ganz kleinem Rahmen, einfach nur die Ehe vollzogen.
Es wird ja gar nicht mehr groß. Also es gibt die großen Feier- Also Stefan,
jetzt musst du ja mal- Warte, warte, warte, stopp. Dieses Fass will ich nicht
aufmachen. Jetzt sind wir wieder genau wie bei dem Fitnessstudio,
dass ich sagen muss, ja, Menschen filmen sich auf YouTube im Fitnessstudio.
Aber das machen nicht alle Leute, die ins Fitnessstudio gehen.
Und ich sage dir, unter diesen ökonomischen Zwängen, in denen wir leben,
gibt es sehr wenige, die ausladend heiraten.
Und die sind super sichtbar. Das gilt aber nicht für die jungen Menschen in
Berlin, die 10 Stunden in der Schlange stehen, um sich eine Wohnung anzugucken.
Heiraten nicht so und die machen aber mehr als 90 Prozent der Hochzeiten aus.
Es wird in sehr kleinem Rahmen geheiratet gerade in Deutschland.
Und es wird auch weniger geheiratet. Es wird wahnsinnig viel geheiratet.
Also ich weiß jetzt nicht, ich hab nicht die Zahlen, aber es ist ja so,
dass Leute, die heiraten wollen, mindestens 14 Monate vorher schon Locations
mieten müssen, weil alles ausgebucht ist.
Ja, Monate vorher.
Für horrende, genau, 14 Monate vorher müssen sie das dann machen.
Also ich kenne aus dem, gar nicht mein enger Freundeskreis, aber ich kenne aus
allen Leuten, die ich kenne, die geheiratet haben, da fallen mir vielleicht
zwei Fälle ein von wir gehen zum Standesamt, haben geheiratet und waren danach
mal mit den Eltern essen.
Die meisten machen relativ große Feste daraus.
Ich will nur eine Empirie, es werden zunehmend Kinder außerehelich geboren.
Das stimmt.
Das ist das einzige.
Das stimmt und das kenne ich auch aus meinem Bekanntenkreis und manchmal wird
die Ehe nachgelagert oder wird ganz weggelassen.
Und das stimmt, aber dass die Hochzeit nicht ganz entscheidend wichtig ist,
dafür sind ja hier Social Media geradezu prädestiniert und wenn wir die Gender-Reveal-Partys
und so die Kinder ansehen und all das.
Das heißt also, und das sind nicht nur die Kardashians oder irgendwelche deutschen
Influencer, sondern die Branche von guckt dir diese Hochzeitsmessen und alles
an, das hat es vor 30 Jahren überhaupt nicht gegeben.
Ja man will das ja auch ausbeuten, da ist halt Geld. Also bei sehr vielen,
also bei wenigen Menschen ist sehr viel Geld und das wird einfach rausgezogen.
Wenn die da sagen sie heiraten, werden schon drei dieser Freundinnen bezahlt
von deren Heiratsmanager.
Du bringst mich aber dann ins Spiel, wenn die einen Wedding Planner brauchen
und so weiter und so fort.
Das ist definitiv so. Ich habe nur den Eindruck, dass sehr viele Leute,
also gerade in Berlin mag das anders sein, aber gerade im ländlichen Raum ist
die Hochzeit ein Höhepunkt des Lebens und wird auch so begangen.
Also die Deutschen unter 35-Jährigen haben im Schnitt 70.000 Euro Vermögen.
Jetzt fragt sich jeder, ich bin doch unter 35, ich habe nicht 70.000.
Ja genau, es ist sehr ungleich verteilt.
Einige haben eine ganze Million und dann haben 14 nichts. Das ist so ungefähr die Verteilung.
Und ja, diese einen, also wenn du jetzt die 20 Millionen unter 20-Jährigen in
Deutschland nimmst und davon jeder 14. Das ist viel.
Ich meine nicht nur mit teuer, also ich meine jetzt nicht, dass alle Leute irgendeine
Riesenburg mieten und da dann drei Tage feiern oder nach Mallorca fliegen.
Diese Hochzeiten gibt es ja auch vermehrt, dass man irgendwo hinfliegen soll.
Also mir kann man einen Gefallen tun, wenn man mich auf keine Hochzeit einlädt,
aber was ich aber feststelle, auch bei Leuten, die jetzt kein großes Einkommen
haben oder wo nur ein bisschen Geld in der Familie ist, dass die trotzdem mit
ihren Möglichkeiten ein ziemlich großes Fest veranstalten und so viele Leute einladen.
Also da sind wir schnell bei 70, 90, 120 Personen.
Das sind Zahlen, die ich laufend wahrnehme, wo ich mich immer frage,
wenn ich 120 Personen aus meinem Umfeld einladen müsste, müsste ich das Publikum
hier, das Podcast bitten zu kommen, aber ich weiß gar nicht,
wie ich auf die Zahl komme.
Es ist bei jedem Thema, mir begegnet das auch immer wieder. Leute sprechen mich
nach Vorträgen darauf an und so und dann kommt so gefühlte Empirie.
Und ich sag dann immer, Deutschland ist wirklich wahnsinnig groß.
Ja, hier in Frankfurt zum Beispiel wird jedes Jahr neu die teuerste Wohnung
Deutschlands verkauft.
Jetzt ist man irgendwie bei 25 Millionen Euro für 300 Quadratmeter und so weiter.
Hier gibt's die teuersten Cocktails, es gibt die größten Schauspiel- und Operveranstaltungen,
die es gibt. Alles. Hier kann man sein Geld rausschmeißen, wie man will. Abba.
Unsichtbar bleibt, dass die Hälfte der Stadt, die Hälfte seines monatlichen
Einkommens einfach, und diese Menschen leben auch und heiraten, aber ganz im Stillen.
Das kriegt niemand mit. Die laden kein YouTube-Video hoch, die laden niemanden
ein, die heiraten einfach. Also diese dunkle Materie unserer ökonomischen Schieflage
darf man einfach nicht unterschätzen, nur weil man so Trends auf YouTube sieht oder so.
Ich würde aber sagen, es ist mehr als ein Trend auf YouTube.
Ich würde schon sagen, dass ein Großteil sich danach sehnt und das auch mit
Ehe noch nach wie vor assoziiert.
Also darum ging es mir ja vor allem, dass deutlich zu machen,
dass es jetzt gar nicht die Frage gibt, wie man 10 oder 20.000 Euro für die
Hochzeit auszahlt, sondern wird mit Ehe noch assoziiert das große Fest einer
Verschmelzung, die auf Ewigkeit angelegt ist.
Und da würde ich sagen, dass wenn du eine Umfrage machen würdest,
egal in welcher Einkommensgruppe, eine überwiegende Mehrheit das noch unter
Ehe versteht, dass sich das dann in der Praxis oft sehr schnell anders gestaltet.
Und man auch dann interessanterweise sehr flexiblen Umgang damit findet,
dass es dann doch nicht ist.
Und dass man dann vielleicht beim zweiten Mal ein bisschen, also wenn man dann
wieder heiratet, ein bisschen nüchterner an die Sache rangeht.
Und das nicht so vollstopft mit irgendwelchen Erwartungen. Das glaube ich schon.
Ich glaube aber, diese Anfangserwartung ist immer noch sehr,
sehr stark vorhanden. Und nicht nur bei Followern von Heiratsinfluencern.
Ja, ich finde es immer wieder beeindruckend. Also man kann sich ja mal in dem
Phasen seinen sozialen Umfeld so aussuchen und mal nicht.
Und wenn man so Schüler ist zum Beispiel, ist man einfach seiner Schulklasse ausgeliefert.
Danach kommt man so ins Studium und hat zum Beispiel, wenn man so wie wir so
diese Abiturientenjahrgänge und so weiter, man sieht danach keine Realschüler mehr.
Die verschwinden einfach. Die sind nicht mehr da, wo man nachmittags ist,
wo man nachts ist, wo man abends ist, wo man morgens ist. Also man sieht nirgendwo
mehr diejenigen, die einem, als man zehn Jahre alt war, aussortiert wurden. So ungefähr.
Und die tauchen dann aber plötzlich wieder auf, wenn man selber Kinder bekommt.
Weil für Kindergarten und Schule, Grundschule gilt ja, Wohnortprinzip,
du kommst da gar nicht drum rum, da werden alle zusammengestopft.
Und dann sitzt man da und denkt sich, ah ja, hm, okay, da müssen wir noch einen Ranzen kaufen und hier.
Oder am Anfang eben, ah ja, da müssen wir einen Kinderwagen kaufen,
denkt sich so, krass, Kinderwagen sind aber teuer, wieso kosten die 800 Euro?
Und dann stellt man plötzlich fest, man kommt im Kindergarten an,
die Gruppe besteht aus 20 Kindern, 18 davon konnten sich kein Kinderwagen neu gekauft leisten.
Da gibt es keine neue Wagenmodelle, Kinderwagen zum Beispiel.
Das läuft über diese ganzen Flohmärkte, die irgendwann sechs Uhr morgens eröffnen
und in der Tiefgarage stattfinden und so weiter und so fort.
Und dann kriegt man immer so mit, wie es wirklich zugeht in Deutschland,
was man einfach sonst so ausblendet.
Und das ist eben, da darf man sich nicht so einfach verirren lassen.
Also wenn Ash Sarkar hier sagt.
Das Problem in diesem Threat-Wife-Movement ist die finanzielle Abhängigkeit,
weil was ist, wenn die Beziehung nicht klappt?
Ich würde jetzt sagen, wir können mal ganz hart davon ausgehen,
dass die Beziehung nicht klappen wird.
Also eine Beziehung, die heute noch mit 21, 22 Jahren eingegangen und dann über
60 Lebensjahre gezogen wird, ist wirklich so selten wie so ein Berufsleben,
das genau so straight durchläuft.
Also wird es einfach kaum noch geben, weshalb diese finanzielle Abhängigkeit,
die da drin steckt, einfach immer ein Problem ist. Also wer sich so ausliefert...
Die darf man nicht übersehen und du hast völlig recht. Das ist, denke ich,
auch ganz, weil wir eben über die AfD und alles gesprochen haben,
es ist medial nicht repräsentiert, dass 60 Prozent der Bevölkerung jeden Monat
merkt, es wird knapp oder es ist knapp oder man ist überschuldet.
Ich war in einem Supermarkt, wo auch so ein Italiener an der Seite ist,
eine Pizza essen, und das war aber um 16 Uhr.
Da saßen dann schon Senioren, und ich wette, sie sind alle mit einem relativ
großen Auto vorgefahren, mit sehr viel Gold behangen.
In diesen üblichen Kleidungsstücken saßen sie da, hatten schon den zweiten Weißwein
bestellt und waren dann auch dort am Essen.
Und sagten dann zu dem jungen Mann, der bediente, uns geht es doch gut.
Und dann dachte ich in dem Moment, ja, ihm geht es ja erstmal,
vielleicht macht er seinen Job gerne, aber er muss euch da bedienen.
Und er wird hier garantiert so viel verdienen, so wenig verdienen,
dass er, wenn er in eurem Alter ist, nicht um 16 Uhr Gold behangen mit zwei
Gläsern Weißwein dort sitzt und für 14 Euro Pasta bestellt.
Das ist definitiv so. Und das wird aber völlig ausgeklammert.
Und wenn man sich aber dann umguckt, sind das natürlich die meisten,
die da nicht sitzen werden.
Ja, genau.
Und das ist das, was sich auch bei diesen Hochzeiten natürlich zeigt.
Deutschland ist sehr, sehr, sehr groß. Ja.
Jetzt hat ja die S.T. Williams so, dieses, ich showcase hier nur,
ich hab damit, hier gibt's weder ein nationalsozialistisches Familienbild,
noch sonst irgendwas, ich hab mit dem allen nichts zu tun und trotzdem wird
das alles so hoffiert und cool gefunden und das ist natürlich,
die Erklärung liegt auf der Hand.
Hamza Ahmed advocatet women voluntarily surrendering their autonomy by presenting
it as an aspirational lifestyle, which makes it so popular with conservatives,
misogynists, white nationalists and religious fundamentalists.
Ja, wir haben das ja eben bei Hamza Ahmed schon gehört.
Es geht ja nicht um das inhaltliche Rollenbild, sondern es geht nur um die Abhängigkeit.
Das macht es so attraktiv.
Wenn die Frau irgendwie anders erklärt, warum sie sich abhängig vom Mann macht, würde man halt das.
Aber jetzt ist es halt dieses traditionelle Familienbild, an das man auch nochmal
historisch erinnern und anknüpfen kann und so.
Aber es ist diese Abhängigkeit, diese Machtasymmetrie, die da diese hohe Attraktivität
hat, weshalb es eben, ich hab dann diese Videos gar nicht, aber El Shapiro und
so, die sind natürlich alle Feuer und Flamme für dieses Ding.
Frauen liefern sich ihrem Mann aus. Dieser Mann soll dann ganzartig mit dieser
ihm hingelegten, zu seinen Gunsten ausbuchstabierten Machtasymmetrie umgehen.
Und damit öffnet sich noch die nächste Dimension.
Wives, respect your husband. It's biblical. It's in the bible.
You treat your husband as the head of the household and obey him.
It's a sacrifice, but it is a sacrifice well worth it.
Und das soll ein zusammenhängendes Verhältnis sein. Du, als Frau,
musst nicht von deinem Mann abgeben, weil seine religiösen Glauben ihn schädlich verhalten lassen.
Wenn du deine Frau folgen willst, Sei ein Mann und folge Jesus und gebe ihm eine Reason zu.
Ja, wenn Hamza seine 40 Seiten aufschreibt, was seine Frau eine sein soll und
er dann sich ausdenkt, was sie in ihre 40 Seiten über ihn schreibt,
steht natürlich dran, mein Mann muss dem Pfade Gottes folgen und so weiter.
Also hier schleicht sich einfach diese ganz sakrale Ideologie wieder rein,
aber auf so eine vulgäre Art und Weise.
Ja, erstaunlich, dass man ja es wahrscheinlich nicht mit Leuten zu tun hat,
die jetzt in die Kirche regelmäßig gehen.
Genau, die erfinden sich dann noch ihre eigene Theorie.
Ja, aber die dann doch nochmal sagen, als Autoritätsargument ziehe ich mal die Bibel heran.
Ja, und dann könnte quasi jeder Pastor auftauchen und denen einfach in YouTube
Häppchen erklären, was angeblich in der Bibel drin steht und es wäre dann für
die die Theologie, nach der sie leben.
Naja, das ist ja bei den frei evangelikalen Sekten da in Lateinamerika,
zum Teil auch in Deutschland oder in Südkorea ist das ja der Fall,
wo ja genau diese Bilder auch vermittelt werden.
Ja, und dann hast du ganz schnell so eine, also dann braucht man eigentlich nur darauf warten,
wie nach diesen ganzen Dating-Videos dann die Beziehung zu Gott-Videos kommen,
die dann, also, dass da, wie soll man sagen,
Einflugschneisen für politische Manipulation und so drinstecken,
wenn man nur erfolgreiche Videos macht, indem man sowas erklärt und weiß,
also die sind an Feuer und Flamme, die gehen genau mit meiner Argumentation
mit, also das ist natürlich super gefährlich.
Wie wird das sein in Deutschland, wenn man jetzt mal schaut,
die Konservativen suchen,
eine neue Möglichkeit konservativ zu sein.
Es ist ja ein völlig entkernter Konservatismus und jetzt hat man so eine Pechstein,
die da irgendwas von der traditionellen Familie erzählt.
Aber eigentlich ist ja schon mit Ehe für alle und auch mit den Lebenswirklichkeiten
der CDU Politiker eigentlich dieses Modell kaum noch vorstellbar.
Also Friedrich Merz oder so könnte das vielleicht noch verkörpern,
aber es ist jetzt nicht so stark vorstellbar, wenn man sich die Politiker unter 40 ansieht.
Ist das noch was, was wir da, was uns droht, dass wir auch noch mal so eine
in diese Debatte oder bleibt es einfach so eine, die Politik brauche es gar
nicht bespielen, weil es schon so eingesickert ist.
Man hat Fast and Furious gesehen, dann guckt man hier sich diese Videos an und dann glaubt man,
die Grünen sind eine Bedrohung und die Linken sind auch eine Bedrohung für meine
Familie und die muss ich ja verteidigen, wie Dom Toretto das auch immer macht.
Und dann weiß ich schon auch, welche Partei ich zu wählen habe.
Also dass die Parteien das gar nicht mehr explizit spielen müssen.
Also wir haben ja vorhin anhand von Sendeberg schon festgestellt,
dass Merz jede Strömung aufnimmt, so kontraproduktiv sie auch ist,
was ein eigenes Metier, die Politik betrifft.
Und wir sehen ja auch an Söder, wie er da allen versucht nach dem Munde zu reten
und sich dann aber immer selber so diese rote Linie, die er dann doch nicht
überschreitet und so diese harte Arbeit am Exzess sozusagen.
Und in deren Sicht, denke ich, ist das hier extrem einladend für alle möglichen
Strömungen da irgendwie Profit draus zu schlagen.
Weil du musst ja immer überlegen, das ist, wenn du so Steven Bannon-artig rangehst.
Du siehst hier Leute, die reden über Ehefamilie, Kinder, totale Leidenschaft,
wie sie sich komplett investieren wollen und so weiter.
Und dann sitzt du halt daneben und überlegst so, wie könnte ich diese Kraft,
die da drinsteckt, für mich nutzen? In welche Richtung könnte ich die durch
welches innerliche Angebot und was auch immer zerren?
Und da würde ich sagen, ist das alles hochgradig gefährlich?
Das ist ja wie so so ein großes Tanklager, das nur darauf wartet,
mal abgefeuert zu werden. Sie suchen nur noch den Motor.
Und der wird dann als Ideologie einfach geliefert. Also würde ich sagen,
da gibt es religiöse Einflugschneisen, das total ins perverse zu treten. Wir haben hier so, ja...
Auf dieser Beziehungsebene, dieses wie gestaltet mal sein Privatleben,
haben wir so ganz vulgäre Ideen, die total anschlussfähig plötzlich sein können.
Und das Gegenprogramm ist auch nicht vorhanden oder ist auch keines,
dem man einfach so folgen kann.
Also wir haben diese Girlboss-Movements von Influencerinnen,
die Millionen Reichweite haben und schon 20, 30 Millionen auf dem Konto haben.
Und die sagen dann, werde selbst finanziell unabhängig. Ich habe es auch geschafft.
Und dann empfehlen sie einen ETF-Sparplan und damit wird man aber nicht unabhängig.
Oder es gibt ja jetzt auch diese Zeitschrift, die sich an Frauen richtet.
Die heißt, glaube ich, die Finanzielle.
Und da gibt es dann Investment-Tipps für Frauen und für junge Frauen.
Und du hast ja eben noch mal Zahlen genannt, wie viel Geld haben junge Frauen,
die zwischen 20 und 35 sind, sind da so viele Frauen,
die sagen können, wie dann irgendwelche, da sind dann,
werden Interview zu Carolin Kebekus und Co, also Leute, die ein paar Millionen
auf dem Konto haben, aufgrund ihrer Karriere, und die machen sich dann vielleicht
mal Gedanken, gut, was könnte ich damit machen, ich lasse es nicht auf dem Sparbuch liegen.
Die sitzen jetzt da und jede Frau sollte sich Gedanken machen.
Ja, aber die haben vielleicht 5000 Euro auf dem Konto. Was willst du damit machen?
Das kannst du investieren, kannst du auch nicht investieren. Es wird eh nicht mehr.
Hier werden alle in die Irre geführt. Das ist einfach alles nicht sehr gesund.
Wir haben es hier mit sehr toxischen Sachverhalten zu tun.
Und diese Threadwife-Ideologie, egal wie man dreht und wendet,
da kommen immer konservative, überholte Weltbilder in den Köpfen der Betroffenen raus.
Tradwife-Kultur wird von aggressiven Antibetreuung, Antibirth-Kontrollen und
Antisex-Ansichten dominiert.
Und damit werden auch die Frauen wieder ... Es war ja durch Corona auch schon,
machen wir Homeoffice. Dann blieben natürlich die Frauen zuerst zu Hause,
weil die Kinder mussten ja Homeschooling machen.
Und dann kommt Scott Galloway und sagt, wenn du nicht im Büro bist,
kannst du keine Karriere machen, weil ein bisschen Sichtbarkeit gehört schon dazu.
Und in der Hinsicht hat ja so eine externe Entwicklung Geschichte schon,
naja, Jahrzehnte zurückgeworfen. Jetzt kommt die in den Köpfen noch dazu.
Regular old sexism made palatable tiktok aesthetics, just look at the kind of
men who approve of it. I don't like girls who are over sociable,
I don't like girls who know lots of people, I don't like girls who are always out.
Ja, man wünscht sich die soziale, inaktive, ökonomisch mittellose Frau zurück.
Und das ist das neue cool dann.
Ja, das ist Schiller in Reinform.
Es gibt ja so ein Gedicht über eine Frau,
die Schriftstellerin ist und das ist die öffentliche Frau und die ist schon
damit gleichgesetzt, dass sie Prostituierte ist und da wird dann gesagt,
ich wünsche mir eine Frau, die ich nur für mich habe und diese Frau,
aber die Schriftstellerin muss ich mit allen anderen teilen.
Diese Idee ist da. Und es gibt eine Dokumentation, mir fällt gerade der Titel
nicht ein, über ein OneDefense Porno-Paar, das begleitet wurde.
Pornfluencer heißt die Doku und zeigt, wie die dann bei OneDefense und auf anderen
Plattformen dann eine große Reichweite erzielen.
Und da haben wir eigentlich genau dieses Modell, also wir haben nicht das Threadrive-Modell,
aber wir haben dieses Modell der Frau, die nicht am Sozialleben teilnimmt,
die leben weit weg von Deutschland. Der Freund ist ein paar Jahre älter.
Er gibt den Ton an, wie sich dann diese Dokumentation herausstellt.
Also da würde man dann auch sehr schnell sagen, okay, das ist,
wenn man mal wissen wollte, was ist so eine toxische Beziehung,
okay, da ist sie zu sehen.
Und da ist ja auch eine völlige Isolation von der Außenwelt und das Schönste
für mich ist ja für meinen Mann da zu sein und das sagen die sich auch mal gegenseitig
und jeder morgens nochmal für sich im Spiegel, wie toll er ist.
Und damit brauche ich keine andere Gesellschaft. Das heißt, es wird niemand
mehr auftauchen in meinem Radius,
der infrage stellt, ob es eigentlich sinnvoll ist, dass wir hier Pornos drehen
und dass ich hier in dieser Weise als begehrenswertes Girlfriend verkauft werde.
Und das ist eine sehr gute Strategie, die da, was heißt sehr gut,
also eine sehr funktionierende Strategie, um Leute ja aus dem Öffentlichen rauszuhalten.
Und das ist ja der ganz lange Diskurs, dass man eigentlich immer versucht,
die Frau, die die in der Öffentlichkeit steht, ist die Schauspielerin.
Aber die Schauspielerin kann sich schon selbst ihre Kleider nicht leisten,
deswegen muss sie anschaffen gehen und die Herren zahlen.
Und die Prostituierte ist die öffentliche Frau und alles andere in der Öffentlichkeit
als Frau stimmt irgendwas nicht. Und das ist wieder, dass die Frau allein auf
die private Sphäre reduziert wird.
Es ist im Grunde wie in diesem Gaslight-Film.
Man sorgt dafür, dass die Frau sich immer schlecht fühlt und steuert dann über
diese ganz kleinen Hiermann-Lob, Da-Mann-Zugeständnis und so weiter,
steuert man dann dieses Denken.
Aber dazu muss man diese Beziehung halt unter Kontrolle haben.
Also die Frau darf dann nicht einfach die ganze Zeit beispielsweise in ihrem
Berufsleben plötzlich immer Anerkennung erfahren oder so und dann zu Hause zu ihrem Mann sagen,
egal was du über mich denkst, sondern man muss diesem Denken ausgeliefert sein,
also wünscht man sich die Frau im eigenen Hinterhof.
Und diese Gemengelage ist eben wie sie ist. Also das ist bei Ash Sarkar ja sowieso
stark, dass sie da aus England immer diese ökonomische Lage so groß mit reinbringt.
Und wenn wir so eine ökonomische Lage wie jetzt haben, Plus da noch das Dating
nicht funktioniert, haben wir ja bei Hamza schon gehört, dann hat man halt diese
gefährliche Gemengelage.
Die relative ökonomische Sicherheit der vergangenen Jahrzehnte,
eine Arbeit für das Leben, Wohnungen, die man sich leisten kann,
Pensionen und ein zahlloses Leben, wurden in dem Schmutz und Feuer von Neoliberalismus abgeworfen.
Wenn man unter 45 ist oder kein Haus hat, kann das Zukunftsfeld verdammt blöd
aussehen. Man ergänzt dazu die Erfahrungen, die viele Menschen mit Dating haben,
zum Beispiel gegastet oder behandelt, als ob man freiwillig wäre.
Es ist kein Wunder, dass die Leute enttäuscht fühlen.
Intensiv so, mit der Status Quo.
Stürzen sich Frauen irgendwann in solche Abhängigkeitsbeziehungen,
weil Essen, na klar, entweder wir haben einen Sozialstaat oder halt die Familie.
Also eins von beiden muss das Angebot machen und zwar für beide Geschlechter.
Und an diesem Chatwife-Trend erkennt man jetzt auch, in welche Richtung es gerade
wieder zurückkippt, historisch gesehen.
Und da würde ich sagen, ja, da haben wir auf jeden Fall eigentlich eine politische
Gemengelage, wenn der Staat von Anfang an anfängt, dir deinen Weihnachtsmarkt
zu streichen und dich in der Schule nicht mehr verreisen lässt und so weiter,
hoffst du einfach, dass du durchkommst und dann so einen Sugar Daddy findest.
Und da ist man dann zunehmend mit immer weniger zufrieden. Also in der Hinsicht
haben wir es hier dann doch mit dem hochgradigen politischen Thema zu tun.
Und Ash Saga findet im Finale auch nochmal gute Worte.
Es bezeichnet den Leisur der Heimat.
Persönlich glaube ich nicht, dass ich arbeiten soll. Ich soll das hier all'
Tag machen. Es ist wie eine langsame Dress-Up-Session.
Du kannst dich umdrehen, trägst Flöte-Skirts und Dressen, organisierst deinen
Snack-Koffer und backst Brot.
Und schau, das ist auch meine Idee für einen schönen Tag. Wer mag keine Gelegenheit,
schön zu fühlen und schöne Dinge zu essen?
Also Social Media bringt uns Fakes, soweit so klar, auch in der Politik.
Irgendwer kommt und sagt, ich verspreche euch, mit mir als Landrat müsst ihr
eure Gasheizung nicht ausbauen.
Und dann muss man einfach daneben stehen und sagen, sorry, das ist Fantasy.
Ja, so auf Karmioska Level. Man muss die Tagesthemen öffnen und sagen,
wir haben es hier wieder mit einem hochgradigen Ausmaß von Fantasy zu tun.
Hier wird Leuten einfach Quatsch erzählt.
Und wenn dann 51 Prozent der Leute sagen, das wähle ich jetzt,
dann sind das alles Opfer einer Fantasy verbunden mit Social-Media-Fakes.
Dass nämlich zum Beispiel die Politik irgendwas lösen kann, was sie gar nicht
lösen kann und so weiter. Dann hat man einfach keine Klarheit darüber, um was es hier geht.
Wie zu mir mal vor vielen Jahren eine Nachbarin sagte, bei der nächsten Wahl
wählt sie die CSU. Und ich habe ihr dann mitteilen müssen, dass das aus Rheinland-Pfalz
relativ schwierig wird. schwierig wird.
Genau. Ja, wir haben es mit Leuten zu tun, die Fan-Fiction gestalten wollen
und sich fürs Fantasy-Genre entscheiden.
Und denen muss man einfach sagen, sorry, fehlt einfach ein bisschen Wissen.
Aufklärung. Naja, aber da das so viele Dimensionen hat, inklusive dieser religiösen,
behalten wir das eh weiter im Blick.
Ich befürchte, dass wir es im Blick behalten müssen.
Du hattest mir kürzlich einen Artikel aus der Zeit gegeben über ein neues Wundermittel,
Osempic heißt das, und das ist ein Medikament, das für Diabetiker entwickelt
wurde, das aber jetzt in Hollywood vielfach eingesetzt wird.
Und im Silicon Valley.
Unten im Silicon Valley Elon Musk, man kann es deutlich sehen,
er hat deutlich abgenommen.
Es ist also nicht ein klassischer Appetitzykler, wie man das schon immer hatte
und wovor ja sehr oft gewarnt wurde.
Appetitzykler erhöhen Herzinfarktgefahr, Kreislaufschwierigkeiten und so weiter.
Ich glaube, man wird lange suchen müssen, um eine Art zu finden,
der sagt, Mensch, das ist eine tolle Sache, nehmen Sie doch Appetitzykler.
Ja, das greift ja wirklich so richtig in den Stoffwechsel ein.
Ja, also es scheint wohl schon ein ziemlich massiver Eingriff zu sein,
deswegen hat es sich dann nicht popularisiert.
Aber das Problem ist natürlich immer noch da und dieses Ocempic ist jetzt ein Mittel,
das man sich spritzen kann, dass man sich dann jede Woche spritzt und dann hat
es aber einen ähnlichen Effekt.
Man hat keine Lust mehr darauf, dies und das zu essen.
Dieser Nebeneffekt, den dieses Medikament hat, den hat man herausgefunden,
dass nicht nur Diabetiker das einsetzen, sondern Hollywood und Silicon Valley.
Und es ist überall Thema.
Hier mal ein Clip von der Schauspielerin Amy Schumer. Die war bei Andy Cohen
zu Gast vor zwei Wochen. Und auch da wird es besprochen.
Jeder würde das nehmen, also sollen doch bitte mal alle ehrlich sein und Amy
Schumer hat es auch genommen.
So, like a year ago I tried it,
you know, it's like, you know, you try it and I was one of the people that felt
like so sick and like couldn't like play with my son,
I was so skinny and I was just like, he was throwing a ball at me and I was
just, and you're like, okay, this isn't livable for me, but I immediately invested
because I'm like everyone and their mom is going to try it.
Investiert hat sie in dieses Medikament, weil natürlich alle um sie herum es
nehmen, aber ihr selbst ist es nicht gut gekommen.
Und wir müssen das hier auch mal sagen, wir sind ja weder Ärzte,
Apotheker, noch wollen wir hier irgendeine Empfehlung aussprechen.
Wir haben das auch nicht aufgrund dieses Erkrankens in der Zeit bestellt und
jetzt genommen. Und das ...
Muss natürlich ein harter Eingriff für den Körper sein, wenn man so was nimmt.
Man kann es sich nicht anders vorstellen. Wir wollen es aber jetzt mal als Phänomen
thematisieren, denn es gibt da sehr viele neue Entwicklungen.
Nochmal so ein letztes Beispiel, wie sehr Osempic in Hollywood thematisiert wird.
Oscar-Verleihung dieses Jahr. Jimmy Kimmel steht auf der Bühne,
blickt ins Publikum, dass er nur aus Stars besteht.
Er fragt sich also auch, ob er es nehmen soll.
Nun gab es eine große Diabetes-Konferenz in den USA, wo verschiedene Vertreter
der Pharmaindustrie zusammenkamen Und und und, Experten.
Jetzt wurden natürlich neue Produkte vorgestellt. Denn alle springen jetzt gerade auf diesen Zug auf.
Fettreduktion, das ist doch eigentlich ein Riesen-Business. Die Nachfrage ist
groß, das Problem ist ja auch da.
Man hat ja sehr viele Krankheiten, die auch mit sehr starkem Übergewicht dann einhergehen.
Man sieht da von allen Seiten gute Möglichkeiten, jetzt Produkte zu verkaufen.
Da hat der Konzern Eli Lilly neue Daten vorgestellt, was man an Gewicht verlieren
kann, hat NBC berichtet.
Es gibt Mechanismen, die sagen, wann man gegessen hat, und sie bereiten dein
Körper bereit, das Essen zu metabolisieren und sagen, dass man aufhört zu essen.
Der Chefmediziner Dr. Daniel Skowronski sagt, Eli Lilly sei an der Grenze eines Unterbrechens.
Wir glauben, dass eine Medizin wie diese irgendwann die gleichen Werte,
die man mit bariatrischer Surgerie sehen kann, eröffnen könnte.
Im zweiten klinischen Trial von Rettetrutide wurden 17,5 Prozent ihrer,
Körperwerte verloren, mehr als 40 Pound in 24 Wochen.
Also zum einen, hier werden ja wirklich auch medizinische Probleme gelöst im
Sinne von die, also nach den Abnahmezahlen hier, das sind ja zweistellige Kilo-Werte,
das ist ja wirklich ungesund.
Also die werden wirklich gesünder. Zum anderen...
Also mir wurde ja auch immer gesagt, mach dich nicht über dicke Lustig,
die weiß ja nie, warum sie dick sind.
Die Unterstellung mit, die haben keine Disziplin oder so, kann ja zu kurz greifen,
es könnten ja irgendwelche anderen Probleme sein. Nur hier scheint mir das ja
ein Einsatz wirklich gegen den Geist zu sein. Also man wird ja wirklich...
So wird es interessanterweise aber nicht beschrieben dann gleich.
Aber das ist es ja, oder? Ja, wir werden das jetzt gleich hören,
denn das ist ganz interessant, die Argumentation, also wie rechtfertigt man
jetzt dieses Medikament?
Es gibt ja auch Leute, die Magenverkleinerungen machen. Da hat man sehr oft
die Sorge, die Willenskraft allein wird bei so starkem Übergewicht nicht ausreichen.
Deswegen macht man das so.
Beispielsweise hat das Rainer Kallmund so beschrieben. Er hat dann diese Magenverkleinerungen gemacht.
Mit diesem Magenband, wie immer das genau funktioniert. Jetzt haben wir aber noch diesen Fall.
Es ist entwickelt für Diabetiker, die ja oft sich auch Insulin spritzen.
Jetzt sind Hollywood-Stars, wie wir wissen, zu vielem bereit und setzen sich
auch Spritzen. Aber man kann sich denken, das wird jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig
massentauglich, dass jetzt alle Leute um uns herum ständig sich eine Spritze setzen.
Aber natürlich arbeitet man daran, diese Spritze zu überwinden.
Hier nochmal aus dem Bericht über Eli Lilly.
Die Gewichtsverlustversion von der akzeptierten Diabetesmedizin Monjaro.
Es gibt Analysten, die sagen, es wird der lukrativste Droge der Welt sein. Hyperbole?
Wahrscheinlich, ja. Ich denke, Lily, wir versuchen nicht zu viel darauf zu konzentrieren,
welche Drogen wirklich große Verkaufer werden werden. Was wir versuchen,
zu konzentrieren, ist, ob wir Medikamente machen, die eine tiefe medizinische
Bedürfnisse beherrschen.
Es gibt sicher eine Bedürfnisse. Diabetes und Obesität sind zwei der größten
Gesundheitsschwierigkeiten in den USA.
Andere Drogenfirmen suchen auch neue Medikamente, zum Beispiel eine Pille.
Diese sind einfacher zu machen und können weltweit um die Welt umzugehen, effektiver.
Manjona ist jetzt so eine neue Sache, die auf den Markt kommt.
Und jetzt arbeitet man aber eigentlich, arbeiten nicht nur Eli Lilly,
sondern auch andere Konzerne daran, dass man Tabletten auf den Markt bringen
kann, weil die natürlich dann einen ganz anderen Effekt haben.
Wir hören jetzt mal eine Ärztin und Expertin auf dem Gebiet,
Angela Fitch, die aber auch mit dieser Industrie verkoppelt ist, bei CNBC.
Neue Entwicklungen in Gewichtsverlustdrugen. Novo Nordisk, der Hersteller von
Injektionen Ozempic und Wegovy, hat gesagt, dass eine Pillenversion ihrer Gewichtsverlustdruge
15% ihrer Körperwerte verletzt hat, nach den Ergebnissen der späten klinischen Tests.
Pfizer hat einen ihrer Pillenverlust-Kandidaten zu einem Phase 2B-Studium vorgelegt.
Mit uns heute auf dieser schnell entwickelnden Klasse von Drogen ist Dr. Angela Fitch.
Sie ist die Chefmedizinische Offizierin von Known Well, einer neuen Firma.
Sie ist auch die Ex-Direktorin des Mass General Weight Center in Boston.
Frau Fitch, danke, dass Sie heute mit uns sind. Glauben Sie,
es ist fair zu sagen, dass Obesität in Amerika eine Epidemie ist? Ja, das stimmt.
Wir wissen, dass bis zu 40 Prozent der Amerikaner Obesität haben.
Und diese Zahlen werden bis 2030 auf 50 Prozent erhöhen.
Sie spricht hier von einer Epidemie. Ja. und,
Zugleich muss man sagen, ist USEMPIC natürlich wahnsinnig vertreten jetzt in
den sozialen Medien und man kann sich denken,
dass es da nicht darum geht zu sagen,
ich habe Diabetes und konnte jetzt aber hier mein Herz-Kreislauf-System verbessern
durch eine starke Gewichtsabnahme,
sondern es geht natürlich darum, dass eher schon sehr dünne Leute nochmal entsprechend
dünner werden und das ist, was dann auch so Logan Paul und all die da aufgreifen.
Und dann auch so, es werden so Sprüche gemacht wie, ja, nimm das mal lieber weiter.
Also wir haben jetzt so ein, ich meine, wir haben ja eh das Problem,
wir hatten ja hier schon auch im Salon, glaube ich, Studien gehabt zu Mental
Health und Essstörungen und so etwas.
Das heißt, das ist ja auch sehr vertreten. Und wenn man jetzt natürlich noch
suggeriert, naja, du musst doch nur das nehmen, dann kannst du das machen.
Also das wird auch wieder auf ganz andere Seite einen Druck erhöhen.
Erstmal nochmal dieser Unterschied, Appetitzykler gab es schon immer.
Was ist jetzt hier besser? Angela Fitch?
So what do these new drugs mean? They are very exciting for us.
It's a very exciting time. I'm also president of the Obesity Medicine Association,
which is our association of clinicians who practice this, you know,
help patients with their disease of obesity.
And it's never, it's been a, it's a great time to practice obesity medicine
and help patients with this disease state, because now more than ever we have
more effective zu helfen, ihre Gesundheits- und Gesundheitsziele zu erreichen.
Ich denke zurück an vorherige Drogen und die verschiedenen Regiments,
die wir dachten, dass sie effektiv sein würden, wie FENFEN von über 20 Jahren her.
Das hat mir die Idee entwickelt, dass alles, was zu gut aussieht,
wahr ist. Ist es wirklich anders mit dieser neuen Art von Drogen?
Es ist wirklich anders. GLP-1-Agonist, wie viele dieser Medikamente sind,
wie Sie bereits erwähnt haben, sind seit über 20 Jahren in der Industrie.
Wir haben also eine Menge Daten auf diese Medikamente, auf die Sicherheitsdaten, inkl.
Daten, die zeigen, insbesondere bei Menschen mit Diabetes, die diese Medikamente
auch nehmen, dass sie sogar eine Kardiovaskulär-Krankheit verhindern können.
Sie haben also eine Menge Effekte. Es klingt, als wäre es zu gut,
so zu sagen, aber es ist tatsächlich die Entwicklung der Wissenschaft und die
Verständnis Das heißt, wir haben es hier mit einer Risikenabwägung zu tun.
Wenn die Gewichtsabnahme stattfindet, dann verbessern sich andere Werte.
Kann man dafür aber dann das Risiko eingehen, dass das Medikament selbst irgendwelche
Nebeneffekte hervorbringt?
Da gibt es auch Ärzte, die davor waren, dass es Krebs fördern könne.
Es geht sehr viel um Herzinfarkte und solche Fragen. Also das ist schon ein
sehr starker Eingriff, was einem ja sehr logisch ist, wenn man denkt,
wie so ein Körper funktioniert und wenn man gerade so einen Riegel vorschiebt,
dass man keine Lust mehr hat zu essen, naja.
Aber, aber, aber, ich finde ja, ich wollte ja auch schon nach,
also seit Cem Özdemir damals seine Gesundheitsminister, Ernährungsministerkonferenz,
Landwirtschaftsministerkonferenz mit 60 Amtskollegen aus aller Welt in Berlin
gemacht hat, lag das ja irgendwie näher, auch wegen diesen ganzen Empfehlungen.
Dann kommt Söder wieder und sagt, ich lasse mir meine Bratwurst nicht verbieten und so.
Diese ganzen Erkrankungen, wenn sie jetzt sagt, das ganze Cardio-Dingsda-Bums-System
kann auf Vordermann gebracht werden,
wenn man diese Pille nimmt, weil man weniger isst, dann steckt darin ja eine
Aussage darüber, was man eigentlich so isst, was man sich im Supermarkt so kauft,
was politisch als, ja, das dürft ihr im Supermarkt verkaufen und da legen wir
auch keinen Riegel vor, wie viel die Leute davon kaufen und konsumieren.
Das ist eigentlich eine sehr gute Subdiskussion, die hier so mitläuft,
dass Menschen, und man weiß noch nicht genau wie die Pille so wirkt,
und ja gut, wir haben viele Daten, wir machen das seit 20 Jahren und so,
sagt sie, aber trotzdem, wir wissen es ja nicht.
Aber schon allein, dass die Menschen weniger Zeug aus dem Supermarkt essen,
macht sie gesünder. Finde ich, ist schon mal eine gute Aussage,
die kann man schon mal festhalten.
Also man kann natürlich auch andere Schlussfolgerungen daraus ziehen,
außer ich nehme jetzt auch die Pille, sondern man denkt über Ernährung vielleicht dann anders nach.
Aber so war es auch in der Zeit, dass die Autorin einen Selbstversuch machte.
Sie sagte, diesen Artikel kann ich nur schreiben, weil meine Mutter nicht mehr
lebt. Meine Mutter hätte mir das nie erlaubt.
Aber gut, jetzt sei sie nun erwachsen und könne das machen.
Sie beschreibt dann, wie sie erste Erfolge hat. Und dann aber,
dass sie auch wieder nachlassen wird, wenn man aufhört, sich zu spritzen.
Das ist die Frage, die hier an Angela Fitch gerichtet wird.
Im Anliegen. Und wir fragen uns nicht, ob wir diese Medikationen ausweichen werden.
Niemand will Medikationen haben, niemand will eine Surgerie haben,
niemand will eine Krankheit im ersten Stand haben.
Aber wenn wir die Wissenschaft weiterentwickeln und diese Krankheiten behandeln,
damit wir länger und heiliger leben können, ist das das größte Problem.
Also mit anderen Worten, ja, man muss es immer nehmen. Also es ist wie so Beta-Blocker oder sowas.
Genau, chronische Erkrankungen, die man halt die ganze Zeit,
man macht ja auch nicht nur eine Krebstherapie, sondern nimmt halt auch eine Medikation.
Die ganze Zeit. Man macht ja auch nicht nur eine Krebstherapie,
sondern nimmt dann auch Medikamente, um den zu unterdrücken.
Aber hier hat sie jetzt mehrfach Disease, Disease, Disease gesagt.
Das heißt aber jetzt wirklich, dass die Ernährungsindustrie eine Disease ist,
gegen die wir hier ankämpfen.
Ja, und das ist auch was, was sie, ich habe ja jetzt nur ein paar Clips mitgebracht,
was sie deutlich macht, also weil sie von Disease spricht. Das kann natürlich
auch ein Sprech sein, um entsprechende Förderungen und alles zu bekommen.
Das ist ja jetzt nicht interessenlos, was hier geäußert wird und nur an der
Erkenntnis interessiert. Aber, was hier immer so deutlich würde, dass...
Sie sagt, man hat immer den Leuten eingeredet, naja, das ist eine Willensfrage.
Und wenn sie aber jetzt ganz stark darauf abhebt, zu sagen,
das ist eine Krankheit, und wir sagen das bei vielen anderen Sachen auch,
dass es eine Krankheit ist, und wir sagen ja auch nicht über einen depressiven
Menschen, du bist nicht diszipliniert genug, steh mal früher auf,
sondern wir sagen, da ist eine Krankheit.
Und so sagt sie das jetzt auch, was extreme Fettleibigkeit betrifft,
dass es sich da um eine Krankheit handelt und nicht eine Frage von, naja, will halt nicht.
Wir sagen bei den Depressiven schon, steh mal morgens auf und finde eine Routine,
nur halt im Rahmen der Therapie.
Nachdem diagnostiziert ist, dass es eine Krankheit ist.
Ja, und man würde aber nicht sagen, du bist nicht depressiv,
es liegt nur daran, dass du dich nicht am Riemen reißen kannst.
Und genauso würde jetzt auch Angela Fitch sagen, du bist nicht dick,
weil du dich nicht am Riemen reißen kannst, sondern das Problem ist,
dass es da ein Krankheitsbild gibt.
Aber bevor es Kommentare gibt, die Depression hat sehr viel mit Veranlagung
zu tun. Also es ist nicht nur der Lebenswandel, in den man so reinstolpert oder die Umstände.
Aber umso interessanter ist es, die ganze Ernährungssache genauso zu...
Aber Ernährung hat auch viel mit Veranlagung zu tun. Es gibt ja ganz viele Leute,
die ziemlich hemmungslos essen können und nicht dick werden.
Ja, die Legende betont die immer noch ein bisschen über, finde ich. Die gibt es schon.
Und wir haben es auf jeden Fall auch mit so epigenetischen Vererbungen zu tun,
wenn deine Eltern schon mit Übergewicht, dann liegt das, dass der Körper anders
mit Nährung umgeht, auch bei dir nahe.
Also man vererbt diese Art der Veranlagung schon.
Das Problem ist denke ich aber, dass wir heute durch die sozialen Medien und
durch diese ständig eingeforderte Sexiness, die wir jetzt auch da bei den Threadwives
und Husbands erlebt haben, dass man einen enormen körperlichen Druck aufbaut.
Also das eine ist ja zu sagen, habe ich einen Körper, mit dem ich einigermaßen
gesund durch den Tag komme und der mir nicht zu großen Last wird?
Oder geht es jetzt darum, den sexy Körper zu bilden, den man unbedingt haben
muss. Und da ist jetzt schon ein ganz, ganz starker Imperativ von überall zu vernehmen.
Und ich glaube, dass dies genauso wie dieses Bild, es gibt halt nur ein Prozent
der Männer, die die ideale Frau finden.
Und es gibt aber auch nur ein Prozent ideale Frauen, dass auch dieses System,
das ganz stark nur auf diese Sexiness ausgelegt ist und auf Attraktivität,
einen unglaublichen Pool von Verlierern produziert, die dann,
möglicherweise aus Frustration sagen, jetzt verweigere ich mich diesem Imperativ
ganz. Und das ist so eine ganz schwierige Angelegenheit, in der man da steckt,
wenn man über das Thema spricht.
Ja, vor allem ist man nicht, wie schnell das jetzt geht. Es gab gestern einen
New York Times The Daily Podcast zu Chad Chibiti in dem amerikanischen Bildungssystem.
Und im Grunde haben die nur noch eine Trümmerlandschaft gezeigt.
Ja.
Wir haben ja besprochen, politisch, Regulierung, also es gab mal eine Anhörung
jetzt, aber von Regulierung sind wir ganz weit entfernt. Selbst hier,
wo wir den AI-Act schon eine Weile in Planung haben, ist da nichts von zu sehen.
Das Bildungssystem hinsichtlich, wer schreibt hier wie Hausarbeiten,
kann man eigentlich noch Hausaufgaben aufgeben und so weiter,
ist schon komplett vernichtet dadurch.
Und wenn solche Tabletten hier als Pillen,
Also wenn diese Art der Medikamente zum Selbstbenutzen in Form von Pillen,
also wo man sich nicht noch ein Off-Label-Use und dann noch eine Spritze und das erst mal üben und so,
sondern einfach man geht in der Apotheke und kauft sich das als Pille,
dann muss man drei, vier Monate warten und dann kann man aber ganz neue politische
Diskussionen über alles Mögliche führen. Also das geht dann so wahnsinnig schnell.
Auch sieht man ja an uns. Ich meine, dass man jetzt Fernsehberichte aus Amerika,
wir thematisieren das jetzt jetzt hier schon in WhatsApp-Gruppen und auf Instagram
ist das natürlich immer von jetzt auf gleich Megatrend und Megathema.
Die Konferenz war vor zehn Tagen und natürlich gibt es sehr,
sehr viele Videos jetzt zu diesem Thema.
Nun die letzte Frage an Angela Fitch. Wie ist denn das?
Jetzt haben wir viele über Leute gesprochen, die Diabetes haben oder die sonst
wie krank sind, aber auch nicht nur Kranke greifen zu diesen Mitteln.
Was ist mit der Auswertung von Offlabel für Menschen, die keine Diabetes haben,
die nicht obes sind? Man hört Dinge wie Ozympec-Face. Wo fällt der Risiko-Rewards-Szenario sehr ernst?
Das ist, wo wir denken, dass diese Drogen verantwortlich und respektvoll benutzt
werden in einem chronischen Krankheits-Treatment-Pathway mit Ihrem Klinikern,
Ihrem Pfleger, Ihrem Arzt, Wer dir diese Krankheiten hilft, um diese wichtigen
Dinge in unserem Leben zu behandeln.
Ich denke, der Fokus sollte auf Ozempik sein. Der Gesicht ist nicht spezifisch
für Ozempik. Es ist ein Nebenwirk der Gewichtsverluste.
Wenn du also eine gewisse Gewichtsverluste verlierst, selbst wenn du 100 Kilo
verlierst, wirst du anders aussehen, dein Hautstück wird anders aussehen,
etc. Das ist einer der Nebenwirke, die die Menschen beantworten müssen.
So richtig will sie die Frage nicht beantworten. Und du machst ja in deinem
Buch den Punkt, Apple produziert Uhren, die das Herz-Kreislauf-System kontrollieren,
aber Apple vermeidet...
Sie vermarkten an die Enkel? Ja, sie vermarkten an die Enkel.
Aber eigentlich vermarkten es eigentlich die Rentner. Ja, denn die müssen wissen,
ob das alles gut geklappt hat mit dem Herz. Und hier geht es doch umgekehrt.
Hier ist es doch umgekehrt.
Hier sagt man, wir machen hier was für Menschen, die sehr krank sind.
Und wir müssen viel mehr das auch als Krankheit wahrnehmen.
Und wer wird es kaufen? Es ist ja auch jetzt schon, die Linger sind ja teuer.
Ich weiß nicht, war das jetzt 900 Dollar oder sowas?
Man kann sich ja denken, wenn das jetzt auf den Markt kommt,
da wird ordentlich Reibach gemacht. Also das ist ja fast so,
wie man hat ein Haarwuchsmittel gefunden.
Man guckt sich ja genau an, wie sind die Witze von Jimmy Kimmel auf der Bühne
formuliert. Also wird es irgendwann sprechfähig, dass man natürlich einfach
darüber redet, dass man das macht?
Ja, nur wer wird das nehmen? Also wer wird es nehmen?
Und ich glaube, es werden vielleicht zum einen Leute nehmen,
die davon, also die, die wirklich ihr Gesundheitshonest aufs Spiel setzen und
die, die damit verbessern können.
Aber ich sehe eher, dass das so ist, dass hier Leute dieses Produkt nehmen werden,
die einfach sagen, gut, ich hätte gerne noch vier Kilo weniger und hätte gerne den und den Körper.
Aber meinst du nicht, das wird so schnell so reinsickern in die Gesellschaft,
dass man das ganz selbstverständlich auch so vermarkten kann?
Ja, das glaube ich schon. Noch ist das nicht der Fall. Das hat sicherlich auch
mit Förderung oder sowas zu tun, die sie da bekommen. Aber eigentlich stellen
sie da jetzt so ein Lifestyle-Produkt her.
Und die Distinktion ist ja heute auch eine andere. Also das ist vielleicht auch nochmal klar,
wenn wir darüber reden, was unterscheidet eigentlich so auch Klassen voneinander,
dann ist das ja immer mehr das Schlanksein, so ein ganz fittes, gesund sein.
Auch wenn man die 30, 40 weit überschritten hat.
Und das ist nicht mehr, dass man das in Form von gewissen Marken nur vor sich
her trägt. Manchmal werden die Marken ja sehr reduziert.
Klar, es gibt einen Sneaker-Hype oder so, aber es ist zumindest nicht mehr der
Maßeanzug oder das tolle Abendkleid.
Das ist nicht primär das. Aber dass sich so eine PMC-Klasse,
die wir ja schon besprochen haben,
die Professional Managerial Class, dass das Leute sind, die sich sehr darüber
definieren, fit zu sein, gesund zu sein, nicht zu rauchen, all das.
Und da glaube ich, ist das für die die ideale Pille und wird deswegen auch eine
große Verbreitung finden.
Ich spanne jetzt einen ganz großen Bogen. Wir haben die Sexiness zu Hofe,
Menschen, die die größten Ländereien besitzen, haben ganz weiße Haut,
weil nur die Arbeiter hängen draußen in der Sonne rum und so.
Die Menschen, die am meisten Geld für Essen haben, zeigen, dass sie es nicht
machen, sondern sie sind ihrem Körper treu.
Und da steckt ja diese Art von, ich mache das aber freiwillig.
Also ich kann mich zügeln, ich bin ein cooler Typ und so weiter.
Ich entsage freiwillig.
Umgedreht hatten wir das jetzt gerade, um das auch nur kurz anzusprechen,
mit dieser Tauchfahrt zur Titanic. Es ist ja absurd.
Also mir müsste man eine halbe Million zahlen, damit ich mich nicht für acht
Stunden in so eine Röhre lege.
Schon aus klaustrophobischen Gründen und so weiter.
Verdammt, du. Also man müsste dir...
Damit ich es nicht mache.
Wenn jemand zu mir käme und sage, du musst dich jetzt da reinlegen.
Es sei denn, du bezahlst eine halbe Million Euro, würde ich einen Kredit aufnehmen
über eine halbe Million und sagen, ich will auf gar keinen Fall acht Stunden da drin liegen.
Und dann gibt es aber Leute, die haben diese halbe Million und sagen dann von
sich, ich mache das ganz freiwillig, bringe ich mich jetzt in Lebensgefahr,
es kann schiefgehen, aber ich kann es mir ja leisten. Und dann geht es aber schief.
Und das ist auch so ein Phänomen dieser Zeit,
dass man den Angeboten des Augenblicks, die sich einem bieten,
schon allein durch zivilisatorische Errungenschaft oder eigene Leistungsfähigkeit,
ich verdiene besonders viel und so weiter, und dann aber diese Entsagung darstellt,
aber ich gehe nicht in die Sonne.
Ich bin zwar hier im Urlaub und so, ich gehe aber nicht in die Sonne.
Ich möchte weiße Haut behalten.
Ich könnte so viel essen, wie ich wollte. Ich habe das Geld.
Ich kann mir alles kaufen, aber ich mache es nicht.
Oder ich bringe mich mit viel Geld in Gefahr.
Oder ich habe so viel Geld, ich könnte mir 50 Zäune vor mein Haus stellen und
nur noch mit dem Panzer draußen rumfahren.
Aber wisst ihr, was ich mache? Ich gebe das Geld aus, um mich in Gefahr zu bringen. Springe vorunter.
Also all diese ganzen Dinge sind ja Angebote, die vorhanden sind.
Wir hören jetzt Joff Misham, der ist von der Bofors Securities Bank.
Und er sieht doch, dass es da einen großen Markt gibt.
Wenn all diese Menschen Gewicht verlieren und ihr Risiko für andere,
wie Herzkrankheiten, hohe Blutdruck, etc.
Reduzieren, was das zu anderen Pipelines macht.
Ja, das ist eine tolle Frage. Wenn man sich die Vorteile dieser Obesitätsmedikamente
anschaut, dann kann die Ergänzung des Gesundheitssystems wirklich,
wirklich, wirklich stark sein.
Aber wir müssen sie über die breite Anzahl haben. Mein Gegensatz ist,
dass wir dazu brauchen, dass wir kardiovaskuläre Ergebnisse haben,
die das Profil weiter unterstützen. Wir brauchen vielleicht einige pharmakonomische Analysen.
Aber im Allgemeinen würde ich sagen, dass die Kosten in der Nähe der Zeit von
der Droge geführt werden.
Also ich höre hier einfach nur noch,
wir fressen zu viel, es wäre alles besser, wenn wir weniger futtern,
es würde die Volkswirtschaft besser machen, wir hätten mehr politisches Kapital,
das dann nicht für Folgenkosten ausgegeben werden muss.
Also ich höre hier einfach nur noch, wir fressen zu viel, es wäre alles besser,
wenn wir weniger futtern.
Das würde die Volkswirtschaft besser machen. Wir hätten mehr politisches Kapital,
das dann nicht für Vollkosten und so weiter ausgegeben werden muss.
Und einfach nur so die Pille.
Moment, erst einmal, die Pille hat auch selbst einen unglaublichen Markt, den sie da auftut.
Also man spricht davon, ja es sind ja dann immer so Zahlen von 100 Milliarden Dollar Markt.
Und das ist, würde ich sagen, wenn die wirklich so gut ist und keine Nebeneffekte
hätte, dann noch sehr, sehr konservativ geschätzt, wenn wir das mal so über
die Jahre hinweg sehen. aber wie dem auch sei, es ist ein großer Markt.
Die Frage ist natürlich, ob wir jetzt hier auf viel Investoren spreche oder
das ist jetzt jemand, der anlegt in solche Dinge, ob wir da viel jetzt hören
und sagen, ja das selbstfahrende Auto fährt hier schon morgen entlang und kommt dann aber doch nicht.
Und so ist das auch hier natürlich zu sehen. Aber die Moderatorin stellt die bessere Frage.
Ich habe deswegen die Antwort weggeschnitten, weil er die gar nicht verstehen
will, diese Frage. Denn du hast jetzt gerade schon gesagt, ja das bringt ja
volkswirtschaftlich dann ganz viel, wenn die alle diese Pille nehmen und dann
Herz-Kreislauf und Diabetes und sowas sind dann fast kein Problem mehr.
Die Moderatorin will natürlich sagen, ja, aber was ist denn mit dem so BEP?
Economic benefits to the insurers, economic benefits to consumers,
that spells to me pain for some of the pharma companies.
And I'm wondering, you know, a lot of these drugs are probably off patent already,
so they're not big money makers necessarily. But should we start thinking about that?
Ja, die Frage kann er gar nicht beantworten. Also ihre Idee ist,
na ja, wenn diese ganzen Krankheiten verschwinden würden, dann verdient ja die
Pharmaindustrie viel weniger. Nur die Tabletten kannst du ja nicht machen.
Also das ist die möglicherweise disruptive Kraft darin.
Ich habe dann mir noch was anderes angesehen, und zwar Insider News.
Da ist Mia de Graaf, die auch erklärt, wie Osempic funktioniert.
Und sie kommt da auf die Nebenwirkungen zu sprechen. Und das finde ich insofern
interessant, als ich die ganze Zeit so ein Unbehagen habe mit diesem Medikament.
Denn du hast ja zu Recht gesagt, es hat auch irgendwas mit Willen zu tun.
Und dann sagen die natürlich sehr stark, ja, das ist eine Disposition,
die man hat. Oder das hat was mit einer Krankheit zu tun.
Und was bedeutet das eigentlich, wenn ich in meinen Willen in dieser Weise eingreife?
Also wir sind uns zum Beispiel ja alle einig, dass man ständig unter Alkohol
stehend irgendwie ein Problem hätte.
Dann wäre man Alkoholiker und dann würde das bedeuten, also man muss die ganze
Zeit sein Bewusstsein verändern, um irgendwas auszuhalten, was auch immer.
Während wir jetzt durchaus am Abend mal in der Bar was trinken,
okay. Aber wenn das jetzt so eine dauerhafte Sache wird, eine permanente,
dann wird also der Willen beeinträchtigt.
Und bei Beta-Blockern habe ich zwar auch ein Medikament, das ich dann immer
nehmen muss oder es gibt ja noch andere Sachen, oder ein Diabetiker muss Insulin spritzen.
Aber davon ist ja das, was man will, worauf man Lust hat, nicht beeinträchtig.
Das ist ja nur ein Mittel, das den Körper ein bisschen besser funktionieren
lässt, weil da ein Defekt vorliegt oder man irgendwas hat.
So, und jetzt haben wir hier mal ein Mittel, das mir den Appetit nimmt.
Und Myrdegraf führt das mal so aus.
Eines der wirklich interessanten Dinge, die wir sehen, ist, wie es den Pleasure-Center
des Gehirns beeinflusst.
Wir haben also mit vielen Leuten gesprochen, die plötzlich ihren Appetit verloren
haben, nicht nur für Alkohol, Coca-Cola, Brot, Marshmallows,
sondern auch, um Pornos zu sehen oder Gambling oder kompulsive Shopping.
Ich höre von Leuten, die fragen, ob sie es nehmen sollen, ob es gut oder schlecht
ist. Und meine Antwort ist unwahrscheinlich, dass es eine wirklich schwerführende Droge ist.
Du musst diese Droge einmal pro Woche für dein Leben nehmen,
wenn man lebenslange Auswirkungen dieser Drogen haben will.
Ja, du bist ein neuer Mensch.
Und das ist das Stimme. Wir haben diese Diskussion ja schon über den Lachsenumgang
mit Ritalin, dass da vielen Leuten auch Ritalin verschrieben wird,
obwohl sie gar nichts haben.
Ja, und dann aber sich damit einfach so ein bisschen besser konzentrieren können.
Und dann lässt man sich das verschreiben.
Viele andere Dinge in diese Richtung.
Viele Diagnosen werden da schnell gestellt. Da gibt es Ärzte,
die viel Geld auch verdienen mit Psychopharmaka.
Und da werden Leute dann ja zu anderen gemacht, weil man meint,
das sei eigentlich jetzt gerade sehr praktisch. Und wenn man jetzt auch mal
diese politische Dimension noch mal begreift.
Okay, man hat auf diese verschiedenen Dinge da keine Lust mehr.
Und das ist jetzt aber nicht nur das Essen, sondern das sind auch sonst alle Exzesse, sage ich mal.
Welche Subjekte formt man da eigentlich? Und was ist da auch biopolitisch möglich?
Also dass man, dass man einfach sagt, ja, Jugendliche sind in der Phase immer
so ein bisschen schwierig, dann bekommen die jetzt alle mal so eine Tablette,
dann gucken die keine Pornos und dann machen die auch dies und das nicht.
Wo kommen wir dahin? Also wo kommen wir auch dahin, wenn man bedenkt,
ist das, wir haben ja hier die neuen alten Beziehungsmodelle,
nimmt man dann noch gegenseitig Tabletten oder verschreibt die sich,
damit man irgendwas hemmt oder anspornt?
Ich glaube, dass das schon sehr gefährlich ist. So ist das erst mal ein bisschen lustig.
Wenn man drei Kilo verlieren könnte, ohne dass man zu sehr sein Gelüsten entsagen
muss, dann ist das was sehr Verlockendes.
Hier haben wir es schon mit einer Industrie zu tun, die ja immer erst gerade
entstehen. Das ist auch mal nur Hunger, aber wir sehen auch Spielsucht.
Die natürlich eigentlich uns eine Gesellschaft hervorbringt,
die dann, also alle Lust, die ja ohnehin, aufgrund von verschiedenen Diskursen,
Also alles, was ein bisschen über die Stränge schlägt.
Schwierig, also können wir das nicht alles so einnorden, dass wir alle sehr,
sehr brave Subjekte werden.
Vielleicht auch noch eine Pille gegen AfD-Wellen oder so was.
Ich halte das für sehr, sehr gefährlich, so verlockend, dass es auch mal erscheinen mag.
Und ich würde da sagen, wo es ins Bewusstsein eingeht, ist das eben nicht vergleichbar
mit einem Medikament, das ich täglich nehme.
Es gibt Medikamente, die regelmäßig von Menschen genommen werden,
Da können die ins Bewusstsein reingehen. Da haben wir es aber auch mit Erkrankungen
zu tun, die als solche erkannt werden, also richtige Depressionen.
Wenn ich das aber ausweite, das ist ja das große Problem,
wenn ich das ausweite, dass alles, was über die Stränge schlägt,
was nicht so gesund ist für Herz-Kreislauf,
als Krankheit markiere, dann nehme ich damit dem Menschen ungeheuer viel Freiheit
und schmälere die Freiheit des Willens und komme dann da hin, dann habe ich nur noch so.
Nur noch Schafe, die was verabreicht bekommen und dann so in der Herde mitgehen.
Es gibt doch diese eine Serie, mit der ich sehr gefremdet habe,
weil ich nicht genau verstanden habe, was sie mir erklären will,
die du aber dann als, es gibt doch gute Serien, gelabelt hast, Severance.
Ja, da haben wir es ja, genau.
Und die schalten sich ja immer aus und ein. Also eine Person lebt zwei Leben.
Und ich stelle mir bei dieser Pille ideal für, also ideal in Anführungszeichen
wäre ja, man nimmt die Pille Montag morgens und betäubt sich für fünf Tage.
Man wird in dieser Zeit nicht dicker.
Man vergeudet seine Zeit nicht mit irgendwelchen Reels und Insta-Stories.
Man hasst in der Zeit seinen Arbeitgeber nicht, weil es ist einem alles egal.
Man fühlt so ein ganz, ich muss halt hier durch irgendwie, man verdient sein
Geld, man vergeudet es nicht für irgendwelchen Geschmäckern, denen man folgt.
Lässt sich nicht irgendwie von erotischen Abenteuern trennen.
Man ist eigentlich das Sigma Male. Also das ist ja so dieser Mann, der sich nichts mehr...
Richtig, genau. Und dann ist Freitag. Freitag lässt die Wirkung danach.
Samstagmorgen, du wachst auf, zwei Tage Party. Du futterst, was du willst,
weil du hast ja dann fünf Tage Puffer um das Wieder.
Das heißt Cheat Weekend, was dann kommt. Die Pille dämmert dich nicht mehr zurecht,
sondern du kannst wieder alles genießen und so weiter.
Machst deine Social Media Videos, konsumierst die der anderen,
alle haben eine schöne Zeit und dann kommt wieder Montag. Du betäubst dich einmal
wieder komplett und ich glaube, das will Severance uns zeigen.
Ja, und in diese Richtung kann es gehen und das finde ich sehr besorgniserregend.
Und deswegen hier nochmal, du hast ja mal in einem Salon erzählt,
dass du gelegentlich jetzt schon mal eine mit rauchst und ich würde auch sagen,
ja, ist ein tolles Mittel, aber vielleicht jetzt doch mal ein Stückchen Torte sich gönnen.
Yes, da bin ich auch absolut dafür.
Wollen wir noch mal kurz über die Stränge schlagen. Jeremy Fragrance oder wie er auch immer heißt.
Der wird auch der Erste sein, der das auch noch mal probiert.
Richtig. Er wandelt ja auch zwischen den Welten. In meinen Augen ist das ja
ein normaler Typ, der dann sobald das Scheinwerferlicht an ist und die Kamera
läuft, macht er seine Show.
Glaubst du?
Keine Ahnung. Am Ende ist es auch egal.
Ich habe ihn ja gesehen, ich habe ihn tatsächlich leibhaftig gesehen am Koblenzer
Bahnhof kam ein Mann mit einem so weißen Hemd,
wie ich noch keines sah, mir entgegen und er stieg dann in den allergrößten
SUV, den ich jemals sah ein, wurde da abgeholt.
Und irgendwelche Auffälligkeiten, war er überdreht oder so einfach hingegangen
und hat sich in den drei Sekunden.
Hat da irgendjemand begrüßt, ich bin nicht hingegangen, weil ich nicht auch
noch mit in TikTok Video wollte.
Also Jeremy Fragrance ist gerade wieder in aller Munde. Er war ja auf dieser
OMR-Bühne und hat ja da so ein bisschen für Party gesorgt, würde ich sagen.
Und diese OMR-Konferenz, wir wollten ja eh noch ein bisschen tiefer einsteigen,
werden wir auch noch machen, je nach Lücken, die sich geben, bieten.
Und diese Konferenz ist ja total, man weiß ja gar nicht genau,
was wollen die eigentlich, außer wachsen natürlich.
Da gehen 70.000 Leute hin und die gestalten diese riesige Bühne.
Und dann ist der Westermeyer selber auf der Bühne und jeder zweite Satz ist,
und damit ihr was mit nach Hause nehmt, und damit ihr hier was lernt.
Und wir haben uns natürlich gefragt, was könnt ihr hier mitnehmen und so,
ja. Also man sieht so richtig, wie sie sich Gedanken gemacht haben,
dass sie sich selber wundern.
Sag, komm, so viele Leute, wir müssen denen ja irgendwas bieten, die ganze Zeit.
Also wir werden die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Fakten durchgenudelt und so,
als ob man nicht einfach da hinfährt, um halt da zu sein. Ich meine,
400 Euro, die die Firma bezahlt und so weiter, das ist für alle da ein Urlaub.
Keiner braucht eine Rechtfertigung auf der Bühne, was man da jetzt genau macht und so.
Aber gut, ich würde sagen, dieser Auftritt von Jeremy Frankens ist irgendwie
so sinnstiftend für diese ganze
Veranstaltung, denn da wurde mal genau das geboten, was man da wollte.
Man geht zu Festivals hin, das heißt Festivals, um da auf der Bühne Quatsch
zu sehen, um sich gut unterhalten zu lassen.
Sascha Lobo hat über Feminismus abschaffen, hat vorher auf Harz gesprochen,
das scheint mir unseriöser zu sein als Jeremy Fragrance.
Genau, manche denken noch, man muss da irgendwas, also man darf da noch was vorgaukeln.
Wurde aber dann gestört von Mareike Kaiser, das war sehr schön.
Mareike Kaiser ist dann auf die Bühne und hat gesagt, wieso sitzt du eigentlich
hier, du bist ja Millionär und was tust du denn für Frauen?
Und das ging, also das war das, was Abdul eben angesprochen hat,
so wir brauchen mal in den Vorstandsetagen auch jetzt drei Frauen und hier könnt
ihr ein Coaching buchen, ich erkläre euch, wie das geht.
Und da war dann schön, dass Reike Kayser das einfach mal so gestürmt hat und
ihre Position vertreten hat.
Sehr gut, ja genau, sowas wünscht man sich ja eigentlich.
Ja, dass wenigstens mal was passiert.
Genau, so ein bisschen, ich will nicht sagen Ehrlichkeit, aber so ein bisschen
so Wahrhaftigkeit und nicht nur Bühne und dann Hinterbühne.
Wir wissen alle, wie es in der Hinterbühne zugeht, aber vorne auf der Bühne
wird noch irgendwie die Show gemacht.
Naja, Jeremy Frakens kam jedenfalls einfach und hat gesagt, ihr wollt eine Show.
Der Vortrag hieß irgendwie, wie Jeremy Frakens das Aufmerksamkeitsspiel gewinnt
oder sowas. Da würde ich sagen, naja, das hat er euch einfach vorgemacht.
Wir gehen das mal so ein bisschen durch, denn warum nicht? Wir wollen teilhaben.
Dieses Mindset ist so relevanter als andere Dinge. In so einem richtig alten
Buch steht zum Beispiel drin, die menschlichen Zellen werden gebaut aus Nahrung, Luft und Wasser.
Krasses Statement, oder? Früher war das noch viel unkomplizierter,
so Sachen. Guck mal, der sagt so Sachen.
Die menschlichen Zellen werden gebaut aus Nahrung, Wasser und Luft.
Okay. Das ist aber nicht der primäre Grund von Gesundheit, das ist nur secondary.
Der primäre Grund für Gesundheit ist das Mindset.
So, er kommt auf die Bühne, das sagt er einfach so. Das ist ja ein Talk.
Es wurde ihm noch keine Frage gestellt. Da kam er drauf an. Das war halt seine
Botschaft irgendwie. Dann fabuliert er da so ein bisschen rum und man fragt
sich so, warum sagst du das gerade? Also keine Ahnung, ich wurde eingeladen.
Wir haben jetzt gerade eben über eine Pille gesprochen, die dein Mindset verändert.
Genau.
Und deswegen ist diese Mindset Sache ökonomisch wird es nur schlechter.
Haben wir auch heute schon gesehen. Und jetzt konzentriert man sich aufs Mindset
und entweder macht man es mit Autosuggestionen oder mit der Pille.
Genau. Dann kommt jemand wie Abdul und versucht die Show zu stören und sagt,
naja, Worte, also nur Sprache, nee, wir könnten ja auch mal ein paar Strukturen ändern.
Nein, finde ich hier nicht statt. Das ist das Mindset.
Und irgendwer hat in irgendeinem Buch geschrieben und dann erinnert er sich
so grob. Ja, steht halt in einem alten Buch. Das ist irgendwie crazy.
Und der Moderator versucht dann Fragen zu stellen.
Es drängt sich ja so ein bisschen die Vermutung auf, dass diese überdrehte Art
von dir so ein bisschen Masche ist, dass das Kalkül ist, um einfach...
Einfach auch eine Entertainment-Figur zu sein, ist das so?
Das ist so irre, ihm das so zu fragen. Der Typ kommt auf die Bühne und macht
erstmal 10 Minuten Monolog. In einem weißen T-Shirt. Genau. Macht dann noch
einen arbigen Liegestützer und der ganze Kram.
Und dann kommt so diese Frage, ja dürfte ich nicht mal so ganz,
ist das eine Masche von dir? Machst du hier gerade eine Masche?
Ist das gerade eine Show oder ist das ernst?
Oder bin ich hier gerade in einem Vortrag von Jürgen Habermas?
Ja wirklich, also ich dachte wir reden hier über Bruce und so,
aber jetzt kommst du hier und machst jetzt so ne Show.
Stimulantien von uns ist Signifikanz. Guckst du dir Luke Skywalker an bei Star
Wars? Geil, geil. Spielst du World of Warcraft Level 60 Charakter.
Geil, significant feeling. Ich bin selber Luke Skywalker und deswegen macht
mir das Spaß aus mir so ne signifikante Stimulation zu machen.
Das finde ich sehr ehrlich, sehr wahrhaftig. Dreh- und Angelpunkt ist Signifikanz,
also wichtig zu sein, sich wichtig zu fühlen und dann diesem Gefühl oder dem
Wunsch, den man hat, auch möglichst zu entsprechen.
Also die Leute dann auch wirklich zu begeistern, nicht nur so tun als ob.
Also rumlaufen und denken, ich bin ja der Coolste, obwohl man so ein Kuscher
ist und so, sondern dann einfach auf die Bühne gehen und sagen,
ja, ich mache das hier für euch.
Ich weiß auch, warum ihr hier seid. Ihr wollt sehen, wie ich durchdrehe und
also drehe ich hier für euch durch. Und wenn dann so eine idiotische Frage kommt,
wie ist das nur eine Show, dann beantworte ich die nicht, sondern mache halt
einfach weiter die Show.
Also ich fand das irgendwie, das passt ja wirklich wie Arsch auf Eimer,
dieser Talk zu dieser ganzen Showse, die da ablief.
Don't hate the player, hate the game. Wir müssen das Spiel nicht spielen.
Aber in dem Attention Game ist es häufig so, dass Leute auf dominante Energien
reagieren, ob sie wollen oder nicht.
Alles klar.
Ja, Punkt.
Was will er uns jetzt damit sagen? Was heißt denn, die Leute reagieren auf dominante
Player? Also das er ist ein dominanter Player und das löst was aus.
Den sollen wir jetzt nicht deswegen kritisieren.
Wenn er auf die Bühne geht, ist er, egal wer noch auf der Bühne ist, der dominante Player.
Das ist ja das, was wir auch bei
Donald Trump, irgendwie das große NATO treffen. Was macht Donald Trump?
Drängt sich einfach vor, stellt sich in die erste Reihe, schubst alle noch weg
und so und damit ist das Ding erledigt.
Also das, was er hier sagt, dem kann sich kein politischer Journalist entziehen.
Nein. Das ist ja das große Problem, das wir haben.
Genau. Solange die Kamera läuft, beschreibt er uns ja einfach,
wie es läuft und um das zu untermauern, performt er das auch noch gleichzeitig.
Also ich habe mich da gut unterhalten gefühlt. Inhalte? Irgendwo Inhalte?
Es sind viele Wege, die nach Rom führen, aber ultimativ simple message.
Ich habe auch ein Buch gelesen, das heißt Psychologie der Massen,
so richtig krassen Shit habe ich teilweise schon gelesen.
People like simple messages und ultimativ eine der Messages,
die auch von Jesus kommt, weil über den Lehren von Jesus und Gott,
seinem Vater steht gar nichts, kann ich hier tot umfallen, scheißegal, über Gott steht gar nix.
Kann ich hier tot umfallen über Gott? Steht gar nichts. Scheißegal. Also keine Ahnung.
Gustave Le Bon hat er gelesen. Psychologie der Massen.
Ja, Psychologie der Massen. Also Crazy Shit hat er gelesen. Und da steht krasses
Zeug drin. Inhalte, egal.
Die müssen runtergedampft werden auf simple messages.
Und was könnte die einfachste Message sein?
Es reicht auch einfach ein guter, netter Mensch zu sein. Diese simple message
möchte ich auch gerne weiterbringen an euch.
Okay, danke dir. Okay, du hast schon ein paar Learnings gedroppt.
Wir haben ja hier viele Marketingmacher und Unternehmen und Markenmacher im Publikum sitzen.
Die wollen ja immer gerne möglichst was lernen hier bei OMR.
Ja, Learnings. Das ist immer interessant, wenn bei OMR irgendwelche Podcasts
gemacht werden. Dann geht's immer um, was waren so deine Learnings oder hast
du da noch Learnings? Ja, das hat alle Dinge dadurch zu. Alle sagen die ganze
Zeit Learnings, das macht mich ja richtig aggressiv.
Ja gut, man kann ja noch, so wie er jetzt, es hast ja viele Learnings gedroppt,
aber dass man die ganze Zeit die eigene Manufaktur nochmal darstellt mit,
ja wir haben uns vorher ganz viele Gedanken gemacht, was ihr hier lernen könnt
und so weiter, weil damit ihr das, wer auch immer, PR-Abteilung,
Human Resource, wer das halt auch immer bezahlt, das erklären können,
was ihr da gemacht habt, das war wirklich so ein bisschen peinlich auch zu sehen.
Wir können jetzt auch alles hier immer so anmoderieren. Guck mal,
Stefan, jetzt habe ich mir hier ein Thema ausgesucht, damit ihr noch was lernt,
da habe ich dir was mitgebracht.
Das ist ganz wichtig, damit ihr wisst, warum ihr eingeschaltet habt.
Also das sind hier die Learnings.
Wir versuchen auch aus Jeremy Frakens noch mal irgendwas rauszuziehen. Wir versuchen es.
Das ist das Geile. Also eines der Dinge, die die Leute wollen, ist Freiheit.
Aber auch ich bin nicht ultimativ frei, denn auch ich bin der Sklave von Gott.
Und das ist auch gut so, weil sonst wäre ich ja Gott, was ich nicht bin.
Deswegen gibt es nur einen Gott, der über uns allen steht.
Okay, ähm, lasst uns doch mal über digitale Plattformen sprechen.
So, also der hat gerade, dieser, äh, naja, er hat gerade wirklich den dämlichsten
Spruch aller Zeiten gebracht.
Also Dümmeres kann man auf einer Bühne nicht sagen. Jetzt kommt die Anschlussfrage.
Wir haben eben schon gehört, du hast anderthalb Milliarden Plays auf TikTok. Eine krasse Zahl.
Wie machst du das denn mit so vielen Plays auf TikTok?
Ja, der Mann sitzt da mit seinen Moderationskarten, er wird jetzt einfach diese
Moderationskarten wegmoderieren, egal was kommt.
Und wenn Jeremy Frakens sich jetzt nackt auszieht, wird er einfach die nächste
Frage stellen, glaubst du TikTok wird in zwei Jahren noch erfolgreich sein?
Und ich finde aber diese religiöse Komponente dann doch noch mal entscheidend.
Vielleicht haben wir doch nicht nur hier ja einen Performer,
sondern auch einen, der auch noch, also der ist ja guruhaft selbst.
Jetzt sagt er aber über mir selbst steht ja noch Gott, wie das ja bei Gurus oftmals ist.
Also wenn sie nicht eine eigene Religion gründen, dann ist das bei den Freievangelikalen
ja auch, dass sie so eine Guru-Funktion haben. Aber natürlich gibt es darüber
Gott. Und das wundert ja jetzt schon, dass überhaupt Gott aufgerufen wird dort.
Also das kannte man ja sonst nur aus irgendwelchen amerikanischen Preisverleihungen oder so.
Heute wieder Kern des Motivs. Wir haben angefangen mit Senneberg und wie dann
im letzten Clip der Politikwissenschaftler sagt, naja, wenn die Leute orientierungslos
sind, sagen sie, egal in welche Richtung, wir brauchen jemanden,
der als starker Typ dasteht, dem wir dann folgen.
Dann haben wir über Threat Husbands gesprochen, also Frauen,
die sich mittellos ausliefern wollen.
Die sagen in der Bibel steht es aber auch schon.
Genau, dann haben wir den Kirchentag, wo nochmal die Geschichte vom großen Aufrichter
der Welt, also egal was passiert, der richtet uns immer wieder auf.
Nizima by Chamomile Fragrance,
der, während der Moderator sich fragt, was könnten wir dem Publikum hier als
Orientierung bieten, welche Learnings können wir droppen, sich denkt,
ich hol mal Jeremy Frakens auf die Bühne.
Weil er genau weiß, Einheit ist ihm eh egal. Man will einfach darüber reden
können, was Jeremy Frakens auf der Bühne, oder zumindest sagen können,
ich hab's bei YouTube gesehen, ah, ich war dabei.
Ja, also sowas einfach. Das sind so die neuen Leuchttürme. Und ich finde,
Jeremy Frakens, der ja so ein bisschen hier inhaltlich dann doch drauf eingeht,
was er da macht, ist sich darüber ja schon im Klaren.
Er ist da für 20 Minuten gebucht, also liefert er da 20 Minuten.
Wenn die Leute dann nachher über ihn lachen, ist ja egal.
Hauptsache seine, was weiß ich, fünf-, sechsstelligen Monatsumsätze laufen halt.
Und das läuft halt nur über diese Aufmerksamkeitsschiene. Also es ist sozusagen
eine Win-Win-Win-Situation.
Er als Veranstalter kann dem Publikum was bieten, Jeremy Fragrance kann seine
Aufmerksamkeit aufbauen und das Publikum wird auch noch gut unterhalten.
Und wir auch hier. Also in der Hinsicht, man darf halt nur nicht jetzt irgendwie
von der OMR-Seite kommen und sagen, ja, bei uns, das ist die wichtigste Konferenz überhaupt.
Wer bei uns nicht ist, kann danach nicht richtig Online-Marketing machen,
weil, ja, dass es um Aufmerksamkeit geht. Also guten Morgen.
Naja, Jeremy Frakens kann hier doch noch ein paar Business-to-Business-Tipps
geben im Aufmerksamkeitsspiel.
Zum einen würde ich euch empfehlen, wenn ihr auf Social Media seid,
euch in eine extreme Energie zu steigern, sehr viel zu posten und wissen,
auf welchen Plattformen die Attention derzeit ist.
Okay, das war jetzt richtiger B2B-Talk. Das ist doch cool. Auf welcher Plattform ist denn die Attention?
Im Moment ist ja vieles so TikTok-ifiziert im Sinne von auch YouTube hier,
ich bin gleich bei Google, die machen auch so, die pushen eher die vertikalen Kurzvideos.
Das heißt, da ist die Attention im Moment.
Dann, logischerweise, willst du in einer geilen Energy sein,
wenn du das machst. Und dann einfach sehr viel posten. Das ist ähnlich wie ein
Album von Eminem oder Macklemore.
Wenn der zwölf Songs rausbringt auf seinem Album, der findet vermutlich alle
geil, aber er weiß vorher nicht, welches viral geht. Ich poste um die 20 Dinger
pro Tag und am nächsten Tag sind 18 wieder weg und zwei bleiben hängen.
Ja, also da hat jetzt wahrscheinlich sehr viele Leute haben sehr viel gelernt.
Aber das weiß man doch, bei TikTok wird das doch so anempfohlen, diese Leuten.
Naja, du musst halt mit viel Energy machen, das ist der Unterschied, denn ohne Energy...
Ich empfehle dir, dass du in deinem Mindset bist, dass du immer geil drauf bist
und dann viel postest und weißt, wo derzeit die Attention ist.
Das möchte ich auch noch sagen, das habe ich in der Vergangenheit schon mal
gesagt, es gibt so ein Ratten-Experiment und zwar...
Ja, jetzt erklärt er denen das Ratten-Experiment, was ja im Grunde bedeutet...
Es gibt viele Experimente mit Ratten.
Ja genau, aber es ist halt so dieses... Ach ja, das wollte ich euch noch sagen,
also das war ganz wichtig.
Die Menschen, die ihr per Social Media da irgendwie ansprecht mit eurem Online-Marketing
und so weiter, das sind alles Ratten.
Und die funktionieren so wie in meinem Experiment und dann erklärt er denen
das so und beschreibt dann so,
beschreibt dann so, ja, da ist diese eine Ratte und der werden so Drogen gegeben
und dann fühlt die sich immer mega stark und das sieht man dann auch im Verhalten,
im Sozialverhalten, also die kommt dann so in den Kiffich rein und sagt,
ey, ich bin die geile Ratte und das Tolle ist, es weiß ja keiner,
dass das nur durch Drogen ist und nicht durch eigene Leistung,
dass die nur aufgeputscht wurde und die anderen Ratten, die reagieren dann trotzdem
drauf und sagen, das ist die geile Ratte.
Also das war die Botschaft, die er da sagen wollte und es endet dann so.
Also guckt, dass ihr immer euch wie einen Gewinner fühlt, wie auch immer das in eurem Mindset ist.
Weißt du, check dir das, dass ihr euch immer wie ein Gewinner fühlt,
sogar wenn ihr physisch im Arsch sein solltet. Das ist so relevant.
Okay, schön, noch eine langweilige B2B Frage. Deine Reichweite auf TikTok ist
ja größer als die auf Instagram.
Das ist im Grunde der Anti-Abdul.
Das ist genau das Gegenteil. Das ist wirklich großartig, ja.
Machst du die Sprache, fühl dich wie ein Gewinner, sag den Leuten einfach,
du bist ein Gewinner und dann bist du auch ein Gewinner. Tu so als ob.
Und dann habe ich aber gedacht, klar kann man das auf der Bühne sehen und dann
sagen, der Jamie Freckens, das ist ja Kasper und so, aber ganz TikTok ist ja
voll beispielsweise mit Videos wie dem hier von Anthony Hopkins.
Und es wird passieren, glaubst du mir, kein alter Idiot wie ich.
Es hat in meinem Leben gearbeitet, es wird in deiner Arbeit arbeiten.
Also glaubst du mir niemals. Glaub, glaub, glaub.
Man findet halt so Worte dafür, eine Semantik, für die es keine strukturelle Entsprechung gibt.
Nur ist es ja so, dass tatsächlich, wenn es um Bühnenerscheinungen geht,
dieser Auftritt nur dann funktioniert, wenn man sich genau das sagt,
was Jeremy Frequencer sich da sagt.
Also klar, es gibt Leute, die haben starkes Lampenfieber und zweifeln dann im
Moment kurz vorher daran, dass sie wirklich diese Show spielen können.
Dann sind sie auf der Bühne und können es. Dann ist die große Erleichterung
da. Bei denen, die keinen Lampenfieber haben, ist es grundsätzlich so,
dass man etwas macht, was eher ungewöhnlich ist. Dass man sich einbildet,
man könne vor Leuten auftreten.
Warum sitze ich nicht da unten? Warum stehe ich da oben? Das ist die Frage, die sich da stellt.
Das Ganze funktioniert nur, in irgendeiner
weise klar macht dass man das kann und das
ist aber dann wie man auf der bühne wirkt hängt ja dann nicht damit zusammen
wie viel expertise hat man jetzt gerade heute mitgebracht und jeremy fragens
kommt ohne expertise kommt einfach nur performativ dort als der große showmensch
und das ist doch aber nichts was also.
Klar, jetzt macht der Anthony Hopkins auch so merkwürdige Videos dabei TikTok
und ist damit erfolgreich, aber dieses Schauspieler-Dasein, ja,
man kann das übertragen, dass wir das im beruflichen alle irgendwo machen.
Das ist ja der Versuch. Also bei einem Bedarfungsgespräch findet das natürlich auch statt.
Würde man ähnliche Tipps geben, geh da selbstbewusst rein.
Wenn du keine Ahnung hast zu einer Frage, sag das auf keinen Fall,
sondern sage, ja, guter Punkt.
Ich glaube, wir müssen noch was anderes bedenken, also diese ganzen Tricks.
Also man muss faken, bis man es dann macht, bis man es geschafft hat.
Und das ist definitiv so.
Anders sind ja auch unsere ganzen Fernsehexperten zum Ukraine-Krieg nicht zu
erklären. Die können das. Also Carlo Massala spricht halt im Brustton der Überzeugung.
Wir sehen hier ganz klar, das ist das Ende von oder so.
Und dann sagt man Mensch, toll, so eine Expertenmeinung.
Nehmen wir doch heute Abend ins Fernsehen. Und das ist das Jeremy Fragrance Prinzip.
Genau, und die Frage ist halt, kann man das generalisieren?
Bis zu einem gewissen Punkt, ja. Aber da, wo dann tatsächliche Leistung abverlangt
wird, das wird ja bei Jeremy Fragrance bei 20 Minuten nicht abverlangt.
Der sagt ja immer nur, ja, ich motiviere und mache und tue.
Bis zu einem gewissen Punkt. Die Frage ist ja, wo ist dieser Punkt?
Also kann man sich zum Beispiel ein U-Boot einfach stabil wünschen,
weil man ganz viel Leidenschaft in das Projekt trägt? Ich gebe dir ein anderes Beispiel.
Ich kenne einen Herzchirurg, der mir mal Ähnliches sagte.
Denn der ist natürlich wahnsinnig renommiert und ist Professor und hat alle
möglichen Preise bekommen. Das
heißt, er hat von außen auch noch mal zugetragen bekommen, sie sind gut.
Und dann kann er noch auf seine Statistik gucken und sagen, ja,
so und so viele Operationen geglückt.
Aber trotzdem ist das eigentlich eine Möglichkeit, dass man sagt,
ich operiere da jetzt gleich jemand in meinem Herzen und wenn ich das falsch mache, dann stirbt er.
Und das geht nur mit der Autosuggestion, ich bin der Größte und das wird eine
richtig gute Operation und wenn sie nicht klappt, dann war der Patient quasi schuld, so in dem Sinne.
Anders ist nichts machbar. Und das, was hier sehr stark bei Jeremy Franklins
und all diesen anderen Leuten,
auch mit denen er da kooperiert, man kann da auch nicht alle Namen nennen,
weil man dann auch immer so Abmahnanwälte am Bein hat, da geht es ja darum,
dass die irgendwelchen jungen Leuten erzählen, na, du bist Krankenpfleger,
dann guck doch mal auf deinen Lohn, jetzt mach doch mal hier so ein Dropship-Business
und wenn du nur an dich glaubst, dann wird das schon.
Und da kommen wir natürlich genau in diese Schiene rein,
dass man damit unglaublich viele Unglückliche produziert, ganz viele Verlierer
und denen aber dann auch noch sagt, ja, dann hat wohl das Mindset bei dir nicht
so gestimmt, sonst wärst du ja erfolgreich.
Genau, also den Chirurgen, da gibt es ja große Soziologie zu,
ja, das ist so ein bisschen wie in der Küche mit den,
erfolgreichen Köchen, die so mit einer besonderen Leidenschaft,
um dann auch so ein Team mitzureißen.
Und dann geht es so um Peak-Performance wie in so einem Schauspiel.
Es nützt gar nichts, 15 Uhr gut drauf zu sein.
Man muss 20 Uhr den Moment treffen und oder bei so Sportlern,
die dann einfach den Punkt treffen müssen. Da spielt Leidenschaft,
innerer Dialog, Mindset und so weiter, psychologische Betreuung und zwar abseits
von medizinischer Notwendigkeit, sondern einfach nur, um wirklich noch Leistung rauszuholen.
Nur wenn da 70.000 Leute sitzen, die Online-Marketing machen,
dann beginnt das so bei E-Mail schreiben und Also da ist man ja völlig falsch
am Platz und wenn Anthony Hopkins...
Die bekommen doch auch immer so Anfragen jetzt, ne? So, wollen sie werben für und so weiter.
Also das ist halt was Marketing üblicherweise macht.
Überall, wo sowas stattfindet. Und ich gehe mal wieder zu meinem neuen Lieblingsphilosophen
Scott Galloway, der was zu dieser Passion-Industrie sehr scharf urteilen sagt.
Vloggers on YouTube make more than $13,000 a year? You know what percent?
Three percent. Three percent. Oh, that's pretty good. Okay, but a working wage over $50,000?
Less than half a percent. Right. So just be careful, kids. Passion is Latin
for there's no money here.
Ja, da hat er absolut recht. In Hollywood, hat man immer gesagt,
also in Los Angeles, leben nur fünf Prozent der Schauspieler so,
Also bekommen die Jobs, die sie haben, so gut bezahlt, dass sie allein von der
Schauspielerei leben können.
Die anderen 95 Prozent nicht. Und bei den Influencern war das auch meine Zahl,
schwank zwischen drei und vier Prozent, die tatsächlich vom Influencer-Business leben können.
Und das hat mit Passion nichts zu tun. Und Anthony Hopkins ist ein sehr guter
Schauspieler, wie wir wissen, aber der hatte sehr viel Glück auf diesem Wege
gehabt, weil es auch noch,
sehr viele andere gegeben hätten,
die ähnlich gute Leistungen verbringen könnten. Das ist einfach so.
Genau. Am Ende gehört zum Glück dann auch, wie sieht man denn aus und was ist
hier gerade gefragt? Und dann trifft man halt genau den Zeitpunkt.
Ja, oder man hat einfach jemanden getroffen, der einen da nach vorne bringt.
Also das sind so viele Zufallsbegegnungen.
Und das ist ja auch bei Jeremy Fragrance, wenn man das mal genau nachvollziehen
würde, was ihn so erfolgreich gemacht hat und welche Mechanismen da dann hinzukommen.
Und das finde ich auch gerade bei so einer Figur, bei einigen dieser ganzen Influencer,
sollten sich auch dann die seriösen Medien, also jetzt nicht OMR,
sondern die seriösen Medien fragen, inwieweit man diese Leute protegiert,
also inwieweit man diese Effekte unterstützt.
Denn es gibt ja vielleicht auch Leute, die gut performen können und noch inhaltlich
mehr zu sagen haben, außer dass Gott über ihnen steht.
Ja, na ja, war halt eine Performance, die stattfand. Zwei kleine Kapitel habe
ich noch zum einen Arbeit, nur weil wir gerade beim Thema waren.
Passionen auf der einen Seite, harte Realität auf der anderen Seite.
Arndt Kirchhoff, der von mir vorhin schon angesprochene Vize der Arbeitgeberverbände,
also bei uns gibt ja dann den Dachverband der Arbeitgeberverbände und so weiter,
da ist er Vizechef, war im Fernsehen, um nochmal, und den ersten Clip gucken
wir nur so, um uns warm zu hören.
Wie kriegen wir das jetzt hin mit dieser demografischen Lücke?
Selbst der Bundeskanzler sagte bei Anne Will, wir haben mit 7 Millionen Arbeitspersonen
Mangel in den nächsten 10 Jahren und so weiter und so fort.
Es gibt auch noch ein paar Reserven im Inland. Also wir können auch im Inland
noch das ein oder andere Potenzial frei machen. Wenn wir zum Beispiel den Anspruch
auf Kindergartenplätze erfüllen könnten, dann könnten auch noch mehr Frauen
im Arbeitsprozess sich engagieren.
Was sagen die Threadvibes dazu? Also hier stoßen die Ideologien aufeinander.
Denn Ideologie, man muss es wirklich so sagen.
Ich fand es wirklich bemerkenswert, wie sehr hier, und das hat man bei Thomas
de Maizière vorhin auch schon gehört,
wie sehr die Bevölkerung einfach
als Verfügungsmasse, das Primat Arbeit unhinterfragt, er braucht Arbeiter.
Ja, das sind dann auch noch normale Menschen, aber erstmal brauchen wir Arbeiter
und so. Und das hat er so in zwei Clips, wo das einfach so deutlich wurde.
Oder wenn wir auch die Arbeitszeitgesetze mal ein bisschen flexibilisieren würden,
insbesondere die Rente mit 63 abschaffen würden, die haben uns zwei Millionen
Facharbeitskräfte gekostet, die könnten wir dringend gebrauchen.
So, ihm hat die Rente mit 63 zwei Millionen Facharbeitsplätze gekostet.
Nun wissen wir ja, wenn dem einen etwas was kostet, ist es dem anderen was wert.
Was haben eigentlich andere gewonnen dadurch, dass ihm zwei Millionen Facharbeiter fehlen?
Zum Beispiel kann man das mal mit in die Waagschale werfen, zum Beispiel so
als Journalismus drumherum, sodass ich dann ein Clip dazu spielen kann,
wie Carmen Joska hier klug nachfragte.
Ja, wollen sie denn die Lebenszeit den wieder wegnehmen oder was?
Nein, wird nicht gefragt.
Es ist so erstaunlich, weil das wird ja ausgestrahlt an Leute,
die wahrscheinlich jetzt gerade zu Hause sitzen und von dieser Rente mit 63 profitiert haben.
Und die bekommen das jetzt so gesagt und sollen das jetzt auf sich beziehen
oder nehmen die das auch schon so wahr, dass die sagen, ah ja gut,
für mich hat das noch gut geklappt. geklappt. Ja, aber die anderen sollen jetzt mal ran.
Naja, es ist ein bisschen so, da gucken ja Leute, die in Rente gingen lange
bevor die Entrennen mit 63 kamen.
Also die jetzt sozusagen, ich habe doch gearbeitet bis 65, warum machen das die anderen nicht?
Und man muss auch immer wieder sagen, auch wenn man jemanden wie ihn,
und man kann ungefähr hören, wie alt er ist, Leute, die die Tagesthemen gucken,
Sehen dort nur junge Leute.
Das will ich mal gerne, dass das jeder so kurz einfach für sich versteht, was ich damit meine.
Wir sehen das immer, gerade die Jüngeren, und sagen, wir werden hier nur von Alten regiert und so.
Aber diese 71-Jährigen, die das im Schnitt, die sind ja 71 Jahre alt,
die das gucken, die sehen nur junge Leute im Fernsehen, obwohl die wirklich
40, 30, 20 Jahre älter sind als wir, die wir so darüber reden.
Naja, richtig crazy fand ich seinen Spruch hier.
Und es könnte auch nicht schaden, wenn wir mal vorübergehend zwei Stunden pro Woche mehr arbeiten.
Das wären Maßnahmen, das muss ja nicht für immer sein, aber das wären Maßnahmen,
die im Augenblick mal helfen würden, weil wir haben Arbeit ohne Ende.
Sie muss nur gemacht werden und wir würden sie auch gerne schneller machen.
Also, es kann ja nicht schaden mal 2 Stunden mehr zu arbeiten.
Nur dieses vorübergehend muss ja nicht auf Dauer sein. Was glaubt er denn,
in welchem Zustand wir gerade sind?
Also sind wir gerade nach?
Wir sind eigentlich in der Normalität, aber gut in zwei Jahren wird es dann toll sein.
Sind wir eigentlich gerade nach Corona und Krieg oder sind wir gerade vor der demografischen Wende?
Wann soll denn die Normalität wiederkommen, wo wir dann nicht mehr zwei Stunden mehr arbeiten?
Vor allen Dingen sind wir ja in einer kriselnden Wirtschaft gerade.
Man kann sich ja vorstellen, wenn wir eine boomende Wirtschaft hätten,
wie viele Arbeitskräfte dann noch in seinen Augen gebraucht würden.
Das ist ja doch ganz erstaunlich, wenn man sich diese Zinsentwicklung ansieht.
Wir haben ja jetzt gerade eine inverse Zinskurve,
was bedeutet, dass also kurzfristige Kredite höher verzinst sind als längere
Kredite und das ist ja erstmal kontraintuitiv,
denn längere Kreditlaufzeiten brauchen ja eine höhere Sicherheit,
also dann würde man ja wahrscheinlich auch eher mehr zahlen müssen.
Aber nein, es ist umgekehrt, weil man damit rechnet, dass die Zinsen langfristig
gesehen dann wieder fallen. Warum?
Weil man davon ausgeht, dass wir in jetzt sehr absehbarer Zeit eine ordentliche
Rezession wohl bekommen können.
Also das ist zumindest ein Indikator, wenn man so eine Inverse Zinskurve hat
und da frage Ich frage mich auch, warum das so wenig als ein Problem angesehen wird.
Da ist ja nicht nur die Frage, wie arbeiten wir da alle mal ein bisschen mehr.
Sondern da sieht man schon, dass wirtschaftlich richtig viel gerade auch daneben geht.
Also dass das in diese Richtung geht und dass diese Zinspolitik,
die die EZB betreibt, natürlich eine ist, die darauf hinauslaufen muss,
eine Rezession zu produzieren.
Wenn man die Inflationsraten erheblich senken will,
dann muss man die Nachfrage senken Und die Nachfrage senkt man,
indem man eine Krise produziert, die sich so, beziehungsweise die,
indem man die Nachfrage senkt hat, produziert man eine Krise.
Und die Nachfrage senkt man, indem man zum Beispiel keine entsprechenden Lohnerhöhungen
und all das gibt. Und da muss man doch mal das in ehrlicher Weise kommunizieren.
Und ich finde das interessant, also ich habe jetzt auch noch mal sowohl im Handelsblatt
als auch in der FAZ so Kommentare gelesen, wo immer noch gesagt wird,
ja die Zinsen müssen weiter nach oben und das ist gut und das soll weitergehen.
Eigentlich ist es ja wie beim Lockdown, wie bei Corona. Man hatte diese Inzidenzen.
Man hätte jetzt Politik machen können, indem man sagt, also Luftfilter in Schulen,
da dies, da das, dann früh die Selbsttests.
Also man hätte einen ganzen Strauß von politischen Möglichkeiten gehabt.
Und was hat man die meiste Zeit getan? Man hat auf oder zu gesagt.
Man hat Lockdown ja oder nein gesagt und hat daran auch alles festgemacht,
hat auch den Diskurs darauf verengt, wer nicht für den Lockdown ist,
der ist offenbar Querdenker oder ein Mörder.
So und damit und jetzt hat man auch nur so diesen einen einzelnen Hebel Zinsen
höher höher höher und das macht die FED ja genauso und das wird auch in Großbritannien so gemacht.
Bei der FED ist es ein bisschen anders und ich wundere mich eigentlich darüber,
dass wir immer noch die Diskussion darüber haben Zinsen hoch Zinsen runter.
Wir führen ja gerade so einen großen Streit über diese Subvention.
Also die Amerikaner bezahlen einfach für jeden, der pro Jahr einen Gigawatt
Solarzellen herstellt, 110 Millionen Dollar werden einfach ausgezahlt für fünf
Jahre. Deshalb alle Hersteller darüber gehen und wir uns dann fragen,
aber können wir denen hier nicht auch einfach solche Incentives geben?
Was wir sagen, wir behalten die hier.
Und auf der Ebene sieht man ja schon, wie inkompatibel alles ist.
Das nämlich hier in Deutschland einfach heißt Schuldenbremse.
Amerikaner so, naja wir hatten jetzt so ein 100 Jahre altes Gesetz,
das uns daran hindert, immer höhere Schulden aufzunehmen. Wir haben das mal ausgesetzt.
Also nicht nur wir haben die Schuldengrenze angehoben oder so,
sondern gibt's nicht mehr.
Bis Januar. Ja, aber so für die nächsten anderthalb Jahre ist einfach,
also für diese Präsidentschaft hat der Präsident, ja, hab ich dem McCarthy abgerungen.
Der wusste wahrscheinlich auch nicht genau, wie ihm geschieht,
wie man jetzt gerade sieht. Also es geht ja drunter und drüber im Kongress.
Einfach dieses hinderliche Gesetz, von dem ja Israel Klein sagt,
es ist das gefährlichste und dümmste Gesetz.
Einfach negiert. So, wir in Deutschland, wir kleben weiter an dieser Schuldenbremse
und keine journalistische Diskussion vermag das zu ändern.
Eigentlich müssen wir die Schuldenbremse schon längst hinter uns lassen und
auch über die Mandate der EZB nachdenken, sie nämlich wie bei der FED so ein bisschen auszubauen.
Auch Arbeitsmarktregulierung und so weiter und so fort und in deren Sicht ist
die FED da schon ein bisschen anders aufgebaut.
Ja ein bisschen, aber es geht ja auch.
Ja, die hat natürlich erst mal nur den Sinn so als Steuerungsinstrument,
aber jetzt ohne Schuldenbremse dort können sie, also Schuldengrenze,
können sie eben auch nochmal an das Geld zur Verfügung stellen.
Die werden demnächst die Frage haben, ja sind es wirklich nur die Staaten oder
können wir nicht einfach auch Anleihenkäufe machen, sodass jedes Unternehmen
zu uns kommt und uns Geld braucht und dann zahlen wir denen einfach das Geld
aus damit und so weiter und so fort.
Und da haben wir ja null Fortschritte in Europa.
Ja, wir haben Isabelle Schnabel, Lagarde, die haben jetzt alle nochmal das bekräftigt
und es kann noch nichts in Aussicht gestellt werden, wann es mal anders wird.
Das heißt, man geht jetzt immer weiter, produziert diese Rezession,
produziert das ja in der Immobilienwirtschaft, das ist ja so verrückt.
Und da gibt es auch von Seiten der Ampel überhaupt keine Reaktion darauf.
Das heißt, es ist wirklich desaströs, wie wir regiert werden.
Also das kann man bei den Immobilien auch mal sagen. Deutschland möchte 400.000,
Wohnungen pro Jahr bauen und schafft gerade mal 200.000 gerade.
Und es werden noch weniger werden. Und gleichzeitig kommt die Baubranche und sagt...
Also wenn so wenig gebaut wird, müssen wir alle Leute entlassen und selbst wenn
es danach wieder anfährt, die Konjunktur, die Leute, die wir heute entlassen,
kommen nicht wieder zurück.
Das sind nicht EU-Ausländer, die hier bauen, die sind dann in aller Himmels,
also die sind dann einfach nicht mehr da. Wir können nicht einfach wie im Gastro
dann sagen, ja, dann können wir die Studenten jetzt wieder einladen in Nebenjobs
zu machen. Nee, wir brauchen einfach Handwerker und so und die gibt es dann nicht mehr.
Also haben die die große Angst vor dieser Lücke, dass sie einfach ein,
zwei, drei Jahre lang alle entlassen müssen und danach den Anschluss nicht wieder finden.
Und gleichzeitig möchte eigentlich der Staat, dass noch 200.000 Euro mehr Wohnungen
gebaut werden und die kriegen es nicht hin. Nur wegen diesem finanzpolitischen Blödsinn.
Wirtschaftlich ja sehr sinnvoll. Wir haben das ja nicht immer mitbekommen.
Da will man, um Wirtschaftswachstum herzustellen, den Bausektor immer weiter
aufblasen und das ist ja dann fast geplatzt.
Hier gibt es eine reale Not und ein reales Interesse von Leuten,
die gerne bauen würden, aber sich diese Bauzinsen, die Immobilienkredite nicht leisten können.
Und man müsste nur an dieser Schraube drehen und dann würde das andere ja funktionieren.
Es ist Bedarf da. Es sind auch Handwerker da, die es machen würden.
Es ist die Immobilienbranche, die jetzt wartet auf Aufträge. Man setzt es nicht um.
Öffentlich bauen.
Und das ist so wahnsinnig, wenn man sich das ansieht und dass man diese Zinspolitik
nach wie vor immer so durchwinkt,
das ist, also ich glaube doch, ja, es mag ja so eine Kritik an Neoliberalismus
jetzt so überall durchgesickert sein, aber die eigentlichen funktionalen Schrauben,
an denen zu drehen wäre, an denen wird nicht gedreht.
Ja, es ist einfach ein großes Drama, weshalb wir hier mit einem neckischen Thema schließen. Frauen.
Wir mögen Frauen, wir sind zwei Männer. Es gibt auch Männer,
die keine Frauen mögen, aber viele Männer mögen Frauen. Und Frauen mögen auch Männer.
Aber was, wenn die Männer, also du hast es mir ja schon gesagt.
Wenn sie nicht dürfen. Wenn die Männer nur alleine sein dürfen oder wollen.
Genau. Annette Dittert, England-Korrespondentin, eigentlich schon glaube ich
in Rente oder so, aber sie wird immer mal wieder, ich weiß es nicht genau,
sie ist immer mal wieder da.
Und sie hat einen Bericht über die Clubs in London mitgebracht.
Gar nicht erst zu versuchen, braucht man es als Frau. In noch immer 15 der großen
und wichtigen Londoner Clubs. Wie dem Brookes oder dem Whites.
Denn die sind weiterhin strikt man-only.
Frauen sind als Mitglieder hier unerwünscht. Das sei einfach schon immer so
gewesen, heißt es, wenn man fragt.
Eine Tradition, die allerdings in Wirklichkeit gar keine ist,
Erklärt uns Seth DeVos, der sich damit viel beschäftigt hat.
Tatsächlich ist das eine erfundene Tradition. Denn als die Clubs im 19.
Jahrhundert gegründet wurden, gab es hier durchaus Frauen.
Gentleman-Clubs als solche gibt es erst seit vielleicht 100 Jahren.
Im exklusiven Savills-Club im Londoner Mayfair treffen wir Quentin Lance,
der mir beim Gespräch im Bücherzimmer erklärt, dass es ihm und seinen männlichen
Mitstreitern um etwas ganz anderes geht.
Es erlaubt uns, über Männersachen zu sprechen und nicht zu sprechen.
Männer, vor allem englische Männer, sprechen nicht gern.
So können wir Männer dem hier nachgehen, ohne das ewige Gerede der Frauen.
Ja, ich denke, Frauen sind anstrengend. Manchmal eine echte Qual.
So. Worum geht's hier in diesem Bericht?
Sie fährt da hin und sagt, hier ist noch viel alte Kultur übrig,
da werden Frauen nicht zugelassen. Wir kennen die Geschichte,
Frauen wurden nach und nach in die Sphären vorgelassen, nur noch nicht in diese Clubs.
Dann kriegen wir zwischendurch eine Exkursaufklärung, na ja,
Frauen waren ja schon mal zugelassen, wurden dann aber ausgeschlossen.
Und dann haben wir diese Erklärung am Ende, wo er hier sagt,
die Frauen quatschen uns zu viel. Wir wollen unsere Ruhe haben.
Man geht aber in den Club, also man könnte ja auch zu Hause bleiben,
wenn man seine Ruhe haben will. Na gut, das ist dann gleich die Familie.
Ja genau, man will in den Club und dort ungestört, unter seinesgleichen,
nicht unbeobachtet, aber ungestört.
Man will sich auch ein bisschen zeigen. Die ziehen sich da toll an und die fühlen sich da wohl.
Jetzt ist ja die Frage, dieser Bericht läuft ja so darauf hinaus,
daran Kritik zu üben, Also im Sinne von, die Frauen sollten da auch rein.
Und soziologisch ist eigentlich wahnsinnig einfach zu erklären,
womit wir es hier zu tun haben,
denn in diesen Clubs, wo sich, naja, die etwas gestandene politische,
wirtschaftliche, wie auch immer, die Sicherheit leisten kann,
die Elite trifft, da geht es ja informal zu.
Also da ist ja gerade nicht die Hierarchie des Arbeitsplatzes oder des politischen
Machtgefüges oder so, sondern da könnte man einfach hin und da sind dann mal alle auf Augenhöhe.
Wenn da jetzt eine Frau mit dabei wäre, wären ja nicht mehr alle auf Augenhöhe,
sondern dann würde sich informal alles um die Frau drehen.
Denn jeder würde seine Trophy Wife mitbringen, mit der vielleicht noch angeben,
dafür ist sie ja da, oder wie auch immer.
Oder die eigene Tochter, dann müssten sich alle da irgendwie benehmen,
weil wir ja kein schlechtes Bild abgeben und so weiter und so fort.
Und meine Vermutung ist, die halten hier einfach dran fest, und zwar völlig
zu Recht, weil entweder es gibt diesen Club ohne Frauen oder es gibt ihn nicht.
Ja, es hätte einfach einen ganz anderen Charakter und diese informale Sozialgestaltung,
die da stattfindet, würde von Frauen einfach aufgestört, weil Frauen insbesondere,
wenn sie hübsch sind, würden dort die Aufmerksamkeit auf sich ziehen.
Ablenken, sodass man diese Gespräche, die man in solchen Clubs dann führt,
nicht mehr führen kann. Also die gäbe es dann einfach nicht mehr.
Also das ist ein Ort, an dem man beispielsweise flirtet, an dem man jemanden
kennenlernen kann. Das macht man in tausend Bars.
Ja und hier ist die Gewissheit, wenn ich dahin gehe, wird das auf keinen Fall passieren.
Weder mit mir noch mit den anderen.
Ja.
Das Phänomen funktional ist es relativ äquivalent, aber es ist ein bisschen.
Ich meine, Frauen haben ja auch ähnliche Einrichtungen, also jetzt nicht in
dieser Weise tradiert, aber es gibt ja auch reine Frauenrunden oder es gibt
auch Tage im Schwimmbad, wo nur Frauen reingehen.
Sauna.
Genau, es gibt Sexspaces.
Dann gibt es Schwulenbars oder Lesbenbars, die auch entsprechend separiert sind.
Also es gibt natürlich welche, wo alle rein dürfen, aber es gibt schon auch
welche, wo es eine klare Grenze gibt. Grenze gibt, dass kein Mann in eine Bar
für lesbische Frauen reinkommt.
Also die beste funktionale Äquivalenz, die mir dazu einfiel,
die glaube ich sehr viele Leute nachvollziehen können, um dann zu sagen,
naja, vielleicht ist es da ähnlich.
Wenn man in seinem Freundeskreis junge Pärchen hat, die dann plötzlich Kinder
bekommen, kann man nicht einfach mal nachmittags zudehnen und abhängen,
weil die sich die ganze Zeit ums Kind kümmern.
Man ist froh, wenn man mal drei Sätze wechseln kann, bevor wieder,
ah, was machst du da schon wieder und das Gespräch ist schon wieder unterbrochen und so weiter.
Furchtbar.
Und so wie kleine Kinder da einfach stören und man sich das auch eingestehen
muss, ja die stören da wirklich. Da kann man nicht einfach drüber bügeln mit,
ja die Kinder sind doch so süß und überhaupt und so. Nein, die stören da einfach.
Ja, man ist da eigentlich ein anderes soziales Gefüge gewöhnt und kann nicht
mehr ordentlich miteinander kompensieren, weil die ganze Zeit das Kind da irgendwie stört.
Und genau so ist das in so einem Club. Wenn man da plötzlich junge,
hübsche Frauen mit dabei hat, stören die einfach dieses Gefüge.
Man kriegt einfach mit Egon kein klares Gespräch mehr hin, wenn er die ganze
Zeit eigentlich nur Pamela hinten gefallen will.
Und sich nicht mehr auf einen selber konzentriert. Und deswegen bewahren die
sich da diesen Schutzraum.
Und Frauen machen ja Mädelsamen da auch, um ungestört über alles mögliche reden
zu können, was die Männer nicht mitbekommen sollen.
Oder auch, um sich miteinander zu beschäftigen und nicht immer auf einen Mann bezogen zu sein dabei.
Und ich glaube, es gibt ja auch Damenclubs, aber nicht so etabliert wie jetzt diese Herrenclubs.
Aber eigentlich wäre das das Gegenprogramm, das man dann aufmachen kann.
Ich glaube jedenfalls, du hast recht, würde man ja sagen, wir öffnen das für
Frauen, dann ist es halt was anderes. Also dann ist es eine Bar und die gibt es zahlreich.
Ich glaube, es gibt nur ein einziges Problem, weshalb diese Herrenclubs oft kritisiert werden.
Und zwar treffen sich da wichtige, mächtige Leute, Männer.
Und dort im Informellen werden oft die entscheidenden Dinge besprochen.
Und dadurch können natürlich solche Männerbünde entstehen, aus denen die Frauen,
die aber auch in wichtigen Positionen sind, also die auch Politikerinnen oder
Wissenschaftlerinnen, was auch immer sind, Da werden Sie aus dieser ...
Aus diesem inner circle ausgeschlossen, da kommen sie nicht rein und da hier
viel geschäftliches auch verhandelt wird,
ist das natürlich dann sowas, wo sich so eine Männerherrschaft weiter durchsetzen kann,
einfach weil die zwar die ganze Zeit mit Frauen auch zusammenarbeiten und kooperativ
sind, Aber dann wurde doch gestern so alleine im Club nochmal unter drei Männern
ausgemacht, wie wir es am Morgen in der Kanzlei machen.
Und das ist glaube ich der Punkt, der sicherlich ein nennenswertes ist.
Ich glaube, dass es aber auch immer mehr Frauennetzwerke in dieser Weise gibt.
Also das wird nicht ganz auflösbar sein, dieses Dilemma.
Genau. Es gibt einfach soziale Phänomene, die sollte man gar nicht so arg problematisieren,
dass man sie so gleich als müssen abgeräumt werden, sondern dann hat man spezifisches Sonderproblem.
Das müsste man dann wieder anders lösen. Aber deswegen mit so einem Tenor,
warum darf ich hier nicht rein und ich sollte doch eigentlich und so.
Nö, dann wäre es einfach abgeschafft. Dann hätte man das Problem nicht gelöst,
sondern einfach abgelöst.
Ein Phänomen abgelöst. Dann wäre der Safe Space zerstört.
Dass so wenig geredet wird, wenn Männer zusammensitzen. Ich gehe relativ regelmäßig
in eine Cocktailbar und manchmal sind am Anfang nur ein paar Männer schon mal
da und dann ist es so unglaublich still und dann schweigen so alle ihren Drink
an und dann ist man wirklich so erleichtert,
wenn jetzt mal Frauen reinkommen und mal so ein bisschen paliert wird.
Also das ist ja wirklich so eine Maulfaulheit bei Männern, finde ich schon.
Kommt drauf an, ob die sich kennen oder nicht.
Das ist jetzt nicht unser Problem, wenn man Podcaster ist, muss man ein bisschen mehr reden.
An der Bar kennt man sich ja nicht. Hier gibt es ja hohe Zugangshürden und dann
weiß man auch, die, die da sind, da gibt es ja auch Rituale des Aufnehmens,
sodass man sich niemals unbekannt, sondern man weiß dann, wer da durch die Tür kommt.
Und dann, wie, also das fand ich auch wieder interessant, in diesem 1940er-Film
wird ja sehr viel gezeigt, was man auch heute nicht nochmal nachstellen könnte,
sondern es muss halt manchmal wirklich ein Film von
1940 sein und nicht einer, der auf Retro gemacht ist,
wie zum Beispiel, also klar, als Problem markiert, dass selbst der Bruder oder
der Onkel oder der Cousin in das Haus gehen kann und beim Ehemann erfragen muss,
ob man jetzt die eigene Schwester oder so.
Und sehen darf oder nicht. Dann sagt er einfach Nö. Und ich bin mir ja ziemlich
sicher, entweder du musst mich schon körperlich überwältigen und das machst
du aber nicht. Und deswegen sage ich einfach Nein und drehe dir dann den Rücken zu.
So, das war ja sehr beeindruckend. Und das andere ist eben, die sind neu in
der Stadt und dann gibt es diese Szenerie, wie da in der Kirche halt das sonntagliche
Ritual. Und danach gehen aber Männer und Frauen getrennter Wege.
Also die Männer biegen nach links ab aus der Kirche und versammeln sich da mit
einem Taxi sozusagen und die Frauen gehen zum Spaziergang. getrennt.
Und dann dieses Konzert, wo wir den Ausschnitt gesehen haben,
wo man nicht einfach reingeht, sondern kurz an der Tür sagt,
wer man ist. Und dann wird das einmal laut in den Raum gerufen.
Jetzt kommt übrigens Mellon, Familie Mellon hier, die Ehepaare Mellon,
sodass alle wissen, die sind jetzt da.
Okay, mit denen wollte ich ja eh noch reden. Man hat ja auch kein Telefon oder
so, sondern da musste man dann darauf achten. Und das sind alles diese kleinen
Feinheiten, die damals einfach so in den Film reingerutscht sind.
Weil klar muss das im Drehbuch stehen, weil so ist es ja, also es hat gar nichts
Artifizielles, sondern da wird es plötzlich sehr dokumentarisch irgendwie.
Ich glaube, ich muss mehr ältere Filme gucken.
Ja, unbedingt.
Sehr gut. Salonlektüren haben wir angesagt.
Ja, wir sagen es nochmal ganz kurz. Also wir lesen gemeinsam chinesisches Denken
der Gegenwart Schlüsseltexte zu Politik und Gesellschaft, übersetzt und kommentiert
von Daniel Lese und Xi Ming.
Das Buch ist erschienen bei CH Beck. Wir wollen also wissen,
was wird in China gedacht?
Wie ticken die? Könnte man auch ein bisschen lax formulieren.
Denn unser großes Problem ist ja, von Xi wissen wir fast nichts.
Leute aus dem Westen, die Xi getroffen haben, sagen dann sowas wie Martin Schulz,
ja ein hochintelligenter, gebildeter Mann. Aber was heißt das am Ende schon?
Ende schon.
Und man möchte doch mal wissen, welches Konzept von Gesellschaft wird da angestrebt?
Wie sieht es aus mit dem Patriotismus und dem Nationalen, was immer stärker
gemacht wird? Und was bedeutet das eigentlich, dass so viele...
Unterschiedliche ethnische nationale Gruppen zusammenlegen. Welcher Blick auf Zukunft ist da?
Wie sieht eigentlich diese Politik aus? Also ganz viele Fragen.
Der Konfuzianismus spielt ja noch eine Rolle im chinesischen Denken oder wird
das nur so aufgerufen mal?
Also hier haben wir mal diese Leute, die auch aus dem Beraterkreis sind,
die dicht dran sind, die im Machtapparat vielleicht auch die eine oder andere
Position haben. Also hier können wir mal direkt aus erster Hand erfahren, was da los ist.
Und dann werde ich, die zwei Sachen kann ich jetzt schon mal sagen,
noch sprechen über linken Populismus.
Brauchen wir ihn? Und wenn ja, wie könnte er aussehen? Lässt er sich mit Ökologie verbinden?
Offenbar ist das der Vorschlag von Chantal Mouffe. Sie hat ein Buch geschrieben,
eine grüne demokratische Revolution, ein Band 99 Seiten lang.
Aber da verspreche ich mir, dass wir noch mal einige Antworten finden.
Und ein Roman, den ich sehr empfehlen kann,
Victor Justin, der Tanzende, ein Mann, er ist verschüchtert,
geht zum ersten Mal in den Club, als er noch ein Junge ist, kommt dann nicht
klar, kommt wieder, kommt immer noch nicht klar.
Und irgendwann tanzt er sich frei und geht ganz auf darin, im Club zu tanzen.
Eine Welt, die mir völlig fern liegt, aber als Roman mochte ich der.
Ticket für den World Club Dome schon gekauft, gebucht, nächstes Jahr.
Was ist das?
Das ist die größte Techno-Veranstaltung im, das findet hier am Stadion statt, auf 10 Bühnen oder so.
Tatsächlich?
Ich will auch mal dabei sein.
Ja, dann musst du vielleicht auch den Roman lesen.
Ja. Ich bin sehr gespannt.
Was wirst du uns präsentieren?
Ich werde euch überraschen mit dem, was ich selber jetzt noch nicht weiß,
was ich mitbringe, aber ich lese ja eh immer erst die Woche vorher.
Den Monat nach, dann entsprechend.
Nochmal der Hinweis, der Live-Salon ist auch jetzt abrufbar.
Im letzten Salon haben wir über Dirk Oschmanns Buch gesprochen,
das für Furore gesorgt hat.
Der Osten eine Erfindung des Westens und jetzt sind dann neue Texte angesagt für nächste Woche.
Der Salon ist, wir sagen es nochmal, manche finden es komisch,
dass wir es immer sagen, aber manche fragen dann auch nach, wie kommt man durch
den Salon. Also es ist immer, weiß nicht, wie man es genau macht, deswegen ganz kurz.
Also man kann den Salon buchen über Spotify, dann kommt man zu Steady.
Man kann auf Steady den buchen. Man kann über Patreon gehen oder wenn man Apple-Kunde
ist, geht das auch via Apple.
Man kann auf der Seite neu20er.de auch da direkt die Links anklicken.
Da ist ein großer gelber Button.
Dann müsste man das eigentlich alles finden, wie man in den Salon kommt.
Wir würden uns freuen und danken auch für die Unterstützung,
die uns ja auf diese Weise zuteilt wird.
Und er ist ja noch bis morgen, also den 30.06.Mitternacht Probemonats kostenlos.
Das heißt unsere große China-Besprechung kann man noch, wenn man morgen sein
Probeabo abschließt, ist das ja noch mit drin.
Tatsächlich.
Das kommt ja in den nächsten 30 Tagen, also um sieben, um genau zu sein.
Dann könnte man das noch mit abdecken.
Sonst ist man ab 2,50 Euro dabei. Wir wünschen einen schönen Monat.
Yes.